[Music]
round five of the US chess championships
will was a taale of two tournaments in
the open section four draws out of six
games barely made a dent at the top of
the standings as world number two Wesley
so maintained his slim lead over the
rest of the pack in the women's section
all the favorites won their games in a
completely bloody round leaving the only
three women with championship
credentials tied for first going into
the rest day the players are refreshed
and ready as the second half of the
tournament gets underway round six live
from St Louis coming up
[Music]
next
hello and welcome everybody we're back
in business with day six at the 2017 us
chess championships in day five we've
seen plenty of exciting chess with nine
decisive results out of 12 games
possible the players are going to come
out guns blazing for another explosive
round here at the US Championship let's
go back to the studio and see the
matchups for day with yaser jeen and
Maurice thank you Christian good
afternoon Jennifer yes I'm Jennifer
Jihadi I'm back with the a Saran and
Maurice for another week of excitement
at the US championship and US Women's
Chess Championship we did have a rest
day yesterday so for those of you who
forget where we stand let's take a look
all
righty well world number two Wesley so
leads this tournament by half a point
just behind a roving pack Nakamura
nitzki jeruk Robson and a Cobian don't
count out Fabiano Carana the defending
Champion just a half a point behind that
group in second place meanwhile in the
Women's Championship it's very tight at
the top our defending Champion Nazi pidi
is tied for the lead as well as our
raing favorites Arena crash and Anna
zatonski no surprise there with all
three of the highest rated ladies in the
field and a tie for first now let's take
a look at the parans in the championship
section lots of great games today we've
got carolana versus kky kky is on a
wrong now Fabiano Karana needs his first
win this will be a big game to watch as
will Wesley so versus Ruan niobian and
I'm also excited about the youthful
battle between two Olympians Shanklin
and Robson yes that one will also catch
our eye throughout and in the Women's
Championship we have a massive matchup
Arena Crush vers vers Nazi pidi the
battle of the 11 the seven time Champion
verse um Nazi pidi who is our reigning
Champion exactly and their game last
year the featuring the same colors
decided the championship in a dramatic
final round a beautiful game by Nazi
pidi so we'll see if Irena can uh find a
better position today but now we have a
Maurice Ashley with his thoughts on what
we'll see
today well what do the fans want but
exciting games bloody battles and
victories and that's what we have seen
so far in this tournament it has just
been incredibly rich and contentious in
the US Championship 11 decisive games
out of 30 they're averaging at least a
couple of wins every round but the
ladies look at them 21 decisive games
out of 30 you could expect to see
Fighting Chess every single game when
they clash and this Clash had better be
decisive for one Fabiano Carana because
he has not yet won a single game in this
competition the number three rated
player in the world with his hands full
so far and he's going to have a
challenge ahead of him the ultra solid
gakamsky now back in business after a
couple of ugly losses this matchup
should be contentious indeed and of
course all eyes are on the man of the
year virtually GM Wesley so the last
eight months or so he's simply been
unbeatable 61 games without a loss and
last year he tasted the blood of this
man vuan akobian 24 moves is all he
needed to decide the victory akobian
will try to stem the Wesley so tied in
this matchup but all eyes will be on
this one as well Karissa Yip this is a
good matchup between the youngster she
is in her second Championship trying to
round herself into form and challenge
these ladies but Anna's a tunsky man she
has just regaled us with her tenacity
her fighting spirit and her
determination she sits at top the
leaderboard she'll try to win this one
against the youngest player in the field
and try to make some distance between
herself and the other two leaders and
well there they are the best of the best
aren Crush seven time Champion she has
been the dominant woman's Champion for a
decade but she got her title stolen from
her by Nazi pidi in What was a
tremendously exciting game we remember
from last year you can expect this one
to be Revenge under mind for arena and
Nazi trying to say I'm the new Champion
now I wear the crown it should be a very
exciting day here in round six of the
championship thank you Maurice that's
right and you know with Nazi having a
two record against Irena Crush W and no
draws Chim that is really impressive and
I you know both both games weren't um
the regular theoretical channels so I
think maybe today arena is going to take
it into something more Theory oriented
where she has more experience in
preparing for major competitions and Nai
well clearly she's going to have to mix
it up that two record speaks for itself
in nai's favor so Arena has to change
her approach uh to this game that's
right last year she played Knight F3 on
the first move so after Knight F6 G3 D5
it had a not super theoretical flavor to
it and that seemed to favor Nazi well it
worked out for her in the end it was a
really a tense Affair and she simply
outplayed Arena at a certain moment and
one decisive and see out played arena
with white in the previous year as well
but in that game um Arena went on to win
the championship anyway right because uh
Nazi um very solid sometimes you she
just didn't score enough victories in
that Championship she played great right
um and a lot of people remarked she
might have played the best chess of the
tournament but just too to many draws
exactly she Drew herself out at first so
this year um very interesting to see
what kind of approach arena is going to
take in the opening my guess is that
she's going to go for something more
mainstream this year and start with one
B4 as opposed to C4 and Knight F3 like
you say more challenging uh opening and
there we see um University of Michigan
student a ver showing up for the game
yeah um she's got a two points and you
know anything can still happen in this
tournament uh it's it's very crowded at
the top even Sabina fer and T vaman
they're only half a point ahead behind
the leaders
right and let's take a look at the prize
money for this the richest national
championships in the world that's right
Easter's coming up what's in their
basket well 50k for first prize here in
the US championship and a total prize F
of
$200,000 and serious bragging rights to
go with all that Moola that's right
meanwhile the Wom Women's Championship
we have 100K prize fund 25k for first
and of course all the players um get
something for their trip here to St
Louis and there's differentiation at
every prize point so in these last
rounds players will have some of the
money on their mind and how does that
work Jennifer for example if there's a
tie for second and third how is how do
those prize monies get they're split
that evenly yeah the difference is if
it's if there's a tie of first there is
a playoff for the money because we have
an overall champion and those playoffs
um determine not only the title which is
of course the most important but also
the other related prizes like like first
second or third okay other other opening
predictions today what do you what do
you take on Wesley so and veru niobian
well uh last year that as Maurice was
saying it was a dramatic and very
exciting scintillating game actually
between Wesley and VAR in an E4 r Stein
French defense uh so Wesley opened E4
but in this tournament and throughout
his whole streak he's been using a kind
of English ready Queen Pawn uh openings
as well as E4 in other words he can
really mix it up he's a seriously
difficult Target a moving Target in the
openings for all of the top players and
it just depends upon his mood um
Wesley's play has been effortless
throughout the streak and he just
impressed everybody frankly that's right
well today I I I think he might stick
with E4 against veran niobian um of
course these guys have the history with
the um game in the 2015 US Championship
the inspiring note uh as Wesley famously
got forfeited for writing on his score
sheet yeah that was such a difficult
moment in his career and it's kind of
amazing to look back and think um how
far he's come since then I mean who
would have thought that he'd have like
such a a a terrible moment in his career
and since then just like a glorious ride
exactly it was really really difficult
uh for him but boy did he overcome it in
style and I was wrong because it was on
the menu yes an English opening like I
say he mixes it up very well now in
terms of O openings for white it often
happens that a player has a severe
weakness against for example 1 D4 or
against 1 E4 and uh in this case um well
bar is a very experienced French defense
player and Wesley said well let's take
it into the channels of the English see
that's why I was expecting E4 because a
lot of times people don't play E4
because they don't want to see a Berlin
yes but um when their opponent plays a
French you know why not just uh take
take on in a in a principled fashion but
of course this makes a lot of sense as
well and now fuan already thinking for
over a minute that's a bit of a surprise
CU is a very professional player
absolutely but it goes to show how
Wesley often times upsets the apple cart
so to speak in the opening bar
undoubtedly expected E4 now he has to
readjust his uh thinking he's played E6
going in I think into his Queen Gambit
declined style positions very quickly
Knight at C3 now hyperbole aside I
really see this round as crucial for
Hikaru nakamura's chances he's playing a
very dangerous opponent in Alexander
shabalov and
Alexander shabby has been uh tossing
away points left right and center and
today Hikaru needs to write his train to
get into first uh he's playing the black
side of an open Sicilian shabalov
thinking should he challenge shabala
should he challenge Hikaru in an open
Sicilian with D2 D4 as we know shabalov
has only one speat that's right and I
think he should because
that's the way I mean uh shabalov with
his uh great opening preparation and
excellent tactics I think that's his
best chance against a higher rated
player go for the jugular go for the
main lines um of course the other big
option would be to play something like
Bishop B5 but Rosal Lio I think more
positional strategic channels maybe not
uh sh uh shabalov strength if he does go
for D4 by the way uh hikaro specific
move order he's not playing into a
nidorf okay so do you think we would see
as fesov in this case probably although
it's always possible that he'll play an
accelerated Dragon I mean that is
another opening that's sometimes played
when you play the night C6 uh variations
yes uh the sikov a favorite of yours uh
uh Jennifer uh is also an incredibly
sharp duel but these days with the
engines with the D bases it's amazing
how deep this specific defense has been
analyzed by the world's top players
that's right but I I actually never
played the S col black but I find it I
thought you did I thought you were a big
one but I like I like well I like seeing
it though because it is very
double-edged and fun of course yeah I
mean I have Bishop all these lines with
Bishop G5 and Knight D5 we have a lot of
fun with the this fash of and let's step
into our game between Arena crush and
Nazi p right and uh it does look like
Irena has steered the game towards more
traditional channels and I love that
decision um in particular well a queen's
Indian defense in fact but then came the
early Bishop B4 check um normally you
toss in Bishop A6 before you play this
specific move order of Bishop B4 check
what's the difference here in this case
since you uh sorry let me just put that
on the board normally you like to play
Bishop A6 attacking the pawn on
C4 provoking the move D2 B2 B3 before
tossing in the check the difference is
that in this case Knight D2 is a bad
move thanks to Bishop
C3 okay because of that move B2 B3 so
Bishop B4 check gives white the
additional option of Knight B1 to
D2 uh as opposed to Bishop D2 the main
line but even yeah even Bish D2 um
normally when you play the the uh BOGO
Indian after Bishop D2 there's other
moves besides B6 right so A5 Queen E7
and so forth but in this particular case
Okay Bishop D2 uh takes Queen takes oops
excuse me uh Bishop B7 Bishop G2 this
has been a main line for ages and ages
going back to Kappa Blanca and uh Max
irva I remember playing uh numerous
games myself on the black side of this
particular line which is a a crazy line
by the way Knight takes Knight G5 um
lots of fun in this particular line
Queen takes Bishop takes
B7 uh you think you're lo you think
you're winning as wh as white till you
see this move Knight takes E2 very
intriguing exchange sacrifice again
going back to the
1920s so so let's see what uh we'll keep
our eye on that game but overall I like
the choice for Irena I think she's good
at these positions and I think it's
great that she got into more theoretical
channels against Nazi agreed agreed and
she she was very Ki in that opening
decision she made against tatev um
played her brilliant her best game of
the tournament this far by the way
talking about sikov look at this one oh
gosh I thought we were looking at jamura
I did too but a game we wanted to keep
our eye on as our defending Champion
Fabi caruana did open E4 and got all
right let's play an open Sicilian the
fov and one of the best games in the
tournament so far was G kamski's win
yesterday well two days ago rather Den
Jeffrey yes yeah that was that was a
fine Victory by G so back in style and
well Bishop takes F6 one of the more
sharper uh lines not the T to the medi
Knight D5 leads to more positional
channels after Bishop E7 and takes on F6
precisely so Bishop takes F6 forces
black to recapture with the pawn
doubling up these pawns on the f file
and then we have the move Knight D5 now
on the the old days uh it was a big
challenge for white both two moves you
had to prepare for Bishop G7 as well as
F6 F5 these days you want explain why G
takes F6 as forc yes absolutely
absolutely cuz of course if you could
You' like to play Queen F6 but the
tactics don't quite work out here
exactly Queen takes F6 runs into Knight
B5 Queen d8 now there's lots of lots of
uh funny lines with Bishop takes B5 a
takes B5 Knight takes B5 then there's a
rook A7 Rook A7 Rook A5 Rook A4 Queen A5
check guys doesn't quite work because
after B4 you can't take on B5 because
there's there's a um a little Fork at
the end of that variation oops and there
goes your queen yeah I always thought
Rook A7 was the was the move here and
and and it could very well be there's
also Rook A4 there's Rook a five this
but Rook A7 let's let's call that a main
move but white doesn't have to sacrifice
a piece he also has this very nice
positional move C2 C4 uh
attacking this Pawn weakness you really
can't take on C4 and in these variations
essentially White's getting a big
initiative both in the center and the
queen side thanks to this awesome Knight
on the D5 Square uh G takes F6 is again
the main move Knight
D5 and let's say Bishop G7 today that's
this kind of superseded F6 F5 big
theoretical battle going on here and
that's have on the board indeed yeah and
now how about shabalov did he go in for
the spov as well I yes with hi Carlo
nakam no he played it in a very
positional way he went Knight C3 E7 E5
Bishop C4 so interesting thing Knight C3
could could just transpose um after for
instance G6 or I guess Knight F6
is after Knight F6 or G6 or E6 there's
all sorts of potential transpositions to
Mainline Sicilians but in this
particular case after Knight F6 Bishop
B5 we get into a Rosal Lio style
position where uh White has kind of
black has committed as night to F6 he
doesn't have a lot of the flexibility
that he would prefer now the problem
with Knight C3 has been this move E7 E5
as black tries to equalize Bishop C4
maintaining a grip over the D 5 Square
D7 D6 D3 the players are uh in a
well-known well trodden theoretical
position black basically has been
equalizing a lot of these games uh for
hikaro it's going to be very hard to
create an imbalance and as I was saying
at the top of the show I really feel
that this is a again hyperboy aside a
make or break uh game for Caro just
because shalov has been losing so many
games now about the transpositions with
E3 um so we can't play are you say we
can't play sasov anymore can't we play
E6 or something here E7 E6 oh yes you
can and then for example after F5 so
it's a way to get a favorable Ras Lio
the reason is cu to me kn C3 seems odd
because I can still play any Sicilian I
want to play but you also give me the
option of playing E5 so I guess if the
idea it's it just seems like more work
for night for to play night C3 cuz you
have to know what to do against E5 and
then you don't really sub subside you
don't um eliminate anything right those
tricky transpositions though these
players are so very KY they may have
come with a particular defense in mind
and then they get you know mised and
they're playing position they don't one
Maurice well some interesting battles
taking place on other boards as well the
openings just by themselves you look at
them you say okay this one's going to be
a war so I'd like to draw your attention
to some of those games this one Daniel
nitzki who has played enterprising
openings throughout the competition
especially with the white pieces he's
facing off against World Junior Champion
Jeffrey Jong in what is a great match up
of two of America's Finest young players
you see this position after the move C4
was played Jeffrey accepted it play the
Queens gamut accepted and E4 the most
principled of the moves although not the
most popular one usually you see Knight
F3 and E3 well Knight F6 attacking the
pawn E5 Knight D5 Bishop takes E4 quick
Tempo on the bishop the bishop dropping
back and now Knight C6 of course in this
position you cannot make this blunder of
taking with the queen because of check
and your queen is hanging and Knight C6
doesn't help because you lose the queen
to that pin so Bishop to D3 Knight C6
and now Knight to E2 not allowing a pin
on this diagonal well the pin came
anyway and now F3 chasing the bishop
back and now Bishop to E6 dominating the
square D5 is this bishop this Knight
this queen and now the move Knight bc3
and we have a position that is
absolutely interesting white has space
but black has this Square unbalanced
battle going on there we see another
unbalanced battle going on between these
two youngsters on this board Jennifer Yu
and Maggie Fang after Knight F3 D5 G3
this move Bishop G4 has been getting
some action lately much more popular
these days interesting variation
actually you can find in American chess
magazine a whole article written about
this move both of them probably read up
on that line after Knight to D7 C4 C6 in
this trade we see the early Sally of the
queen to A4 move that you wouldn't
expect an early queen move but she's
trying to pin this Knight maybe getting
Knight to E5 well Knight F6 was played
and now Knight to C3 with threats of
possibly taking this pawn and then
picking off this bishop on this side
some tactics that black has to watch out
for the engines giving an early Bishop
F3 as a way to somehow bring that
position down Tamp it down a bit but
this one is not going to get tamped down
at all Knight F6 Knight C3 A6 played
Karina mova against the youngster
approve of her could I went with
Katarina yesterday to a juvenile
detention center we went and played
against some young men uh and we played
a a tandem Simo where I made moves and
she made moves and I got to tell you she
acquitted herself quite well there were
some boards where I just had to play
mate because she was just kicking it
with the tactics every time it was her
turn on those boards we played about 22
young men as a matter of fact and they
were in awe at the games we were playing
in fact sometimes something would happen
on a board I got to say that you know
player tried to make two moves and
Katarina would say hey Maurice did you
just blunder a piece I said uhuh no way
what are you talking about and uh we had
to fix those positions a little bit they
were uh in awe the fact that we could
remember all the games of course that
was the case well she has come with
Fighting Chess on her mind today the
moved Knight to B3 naris special from
earlier in the tournament and after E6
the point made that if this had been
played in that naroditsky game I think
it was the game nitzki versus Ray Robson
Ray did not play this move the move G4
is possible and aov her could has been
staring at this board for quite some
time after seeing this move she did not
think about the potential Nuance of her
last move so we're going to see a real
Battle Royale in this one as Katarina
tries to get herself back into
contention in the women's tournament
thank you Maurice and Jennifer we have a
phone call yeah our first phone call
today welcome to the show let us know um
your name and where you're calling from
hello
hello uh this is
urish from uh bua turkey I'm calling
from Turkey I don't have any questions I
just want to thank you all Jan Yas and
Maurice this is a great show and
uh I I I'm very happy to watch your show
and uh guys you are being watched all
over the world
thank you for the compliment turkey uh
with a shout out uh for our show I love
it I mean I was in Istanbul Turkey for
just a couple of times and it's just my
uh it's one of my favorite cities I've
ever visited just uh so interesting and
so vibrant and what a history of course
as well I remember also the uh two
olympiads that turkey has hosted and the
players really enjoyed EST stand as well
so thank you turkey I wanted to turn our
attention to the game between kis yep
and Anna zatonski if not only just to
describe the the the name the defense
that Anna has played she's playing what
is called the fort KNX variation of the
French defense you just got to like that
the fort KNX variation speaking of
history and after Knight D2 in a French
tares Knight takes E4 this early
exchange the move Bishop D7 and what is
the idea behind this move Bishop D7 well
if you look at the position there's one
piece in Black's Army it really doesn't
have a great view uh this Pawn on E7 E6
blocks the light Square Bishops light
Square Bishop hence the move Bishop D7
and after Knight F3 Bishop C6 black
spends to Tempe to bring this bishop out
into the open and control the center
Bishop D3 Knight D7 Bishop E3 now this
is I think this is uh Karissa not being
aware of all the nuances here in this
particular opening defense by Anna Queen
E2 for many many a decade has been
considered White's principal and really
only way of getting an advantage Bishop
B3 is kind of blocking your queen from
defending E4 when you put it there it'd
be better off on like D2 or G5 or even
F4 does Bishop on E3 if you imagine the
situation where white wants to bring a
rook to the half of open E file and
Menace a potential Knight E5 in the
future your Bishop E3 is in the way so
uh for a lot of players they're very
happy to play Knight F6 and after Knight
takes F6 Knight takes F6 the question is
really where white is putting the
pressure on Black's position and black
Black's game is ultra solid uh we
recalling the game of tatv and Arena
Crush Arena really limited t have's
ability to mix open the position and
took away her attacking potential which
is exactly what Anna wants to do against
this very young and talented Carissa y
but the thing is in this line um Carissa
could could get attacking Chances with
this queen E2 queenside Castle's idea
okay well let's just say what what one
line that I liked as black and I
remember playing this many many a year
ago was in case of the shorts side
castles you you were mentioning the
longside castles this move Knight E5 is
very suggestive I mean look at that you
you put your knight in the middle of the
board and you want to capture this
bishop and really wreck the pawn
structure well be very careful because
the shoe could very easily slip off and
after trades and queen D5 there was a
secondary purpose of putting that Bishop
on C6 you got the double attack against
the pawn on G2 with a threat of Maiden
one and you want to pick off this Pawn
on E5 now you mentioned the superior
idea Jennifer for white uh in this
position queening to once again with the
idea of castling long right yeah and I
would prefer to have my Bishop on D2 or
D5 right or F4 or anywhere but not E3 I
think Carissa uh shows that her
inexperience but I still go for this
plan of cine Queen side um I think that
that's what she should do if she wants
to try to get Advantage almost
especially if she has a bishop 3 because
now these ideas of 95 are kind of off
the table exactly well put and Maurice
uh over to
you well an exciting game of foot yet
again in the position between Wesley so
and varujan akobian this line that
Wesley decided to play had seen some
mileage a few years ago just a few years
ago 2013 there were a lot of highlevel
games quite a few games and quite a few
victories for white the move Bishop F5
had has been scene and now just daring
to move G4 which Wesley said come on
with it that's the kind of move I want
to play on this board and after Bishop
to E6 H4 was played but VAR was prepared
for this line I should say however those
games in 2013 quite a few games saw
black going down in flames so little
surprising that he would go for exactly
this position but we have it on the
board G4 Let me refresh my board as some
more moves have been played after H4
Knight D7 G5 was played and now 86 and
G6 10 moves in and a pawn has already
been sacrificed on the board fg6 Bishop
D3 Wesley playing instantly he started
the game as you know with 90 minutes
with a 30 second increment he has now
gained almost a full of five minutes on
the clock after his move Bishop to D3
VAR responded with Knight to f8 so it
seems like we are absolutely in varian's
preparation as well a dynamic battle
after only 11 moves will vuan go down in
under 24 remember he lost last year with
the black pieces in 24 moves and he has
dared the hottest player in the world to
come get him this should be a good one
yeah it should be a good one I I can't
say I like it for for veran this looks
like Wesley's gonna have some fun today
um you know there's a I would I wanted
to point out that um sometimes people
like to make a a point about the uh the
the horrible game from two years ago
where W was forfeited against fuja
niobian but now these guys are actually
teammates on the archbishops right and
the champions of the pro league that's
right so from Rivals to uh teammates on
uh the debut champions for the proess
league so exactly um how how how
relationships can change quickly in
chess right exactly and they're very
professional about it too uh we have
another phone call Jennifer Yes welcome
to the show let us know uh your name and
where you're calling from
hi guys um my name is Shaker and I'm
calling from India hey hello Shaker uh
hello uh first of all let me say that I
find your commentary extremely
insightful and instructional thank you
and also kudos to Maurice for his great
work thank you thank you and to your
question yes I have a couple of
questions on
tactics um my first question is that um
the tactic that I frequently have
problems with is a Desperado
tactic um uh I mean especially if both
sides are making two or three Desir
moves one after the other and the
problem is that I have uh I I frequently
have difficulty keeping track of the of
a material count in my head and try
trying to figure out at the end who's uh
who has the advantage especially over
the board and because of this frequent
uh over the board I try to avoid uh desp
tactics so my question is uh is there
any technique that players use to keep
lack of material or um should I simply
just practice more Des tactics well
thank you for the question and uh I know
tactics is something Jennifer that you
love a great deal you have a lot of uh
uh inspiration with the tactics uh to
the man's question how would you answer
that one well I definitely don't think
you should avoid it because if you want
to get better you have to no matter what
type of style you have you have to win
some games with tactics so don't avoid
them um and uh definitely studying more
tactics particularly um
Desperados uh will help uh also I think
that what I notice people who aren't
good as calculating a lot of times they
try to count the material throughout the
variation and I think that's wrong
instead what you want to do is get
better at visualizing and then when you
get to the position that's the the final
that you're trying to evaluate then you
look and see what the material situ
ation is so don't try to like keep a
counter in your head cuz that's going to
get in the way of the picture of the
chessboard which is really the most
important thing that you need to get
right thank you and Maurice your uh
thoughts about tactics and how do you
improve your Tactical awareness uh Jen
said it so perfectly I think she's
absolutely right and all you can ever do
is just keep studying variations after
variations tactics tactics puzzles you
start with the easier ones you get to
the harder ones and you just keep doing
it and you grade yourself I used to
grade myself that I saw every single
variation that was in the puzzle if I
missed a variation scratch it not good
enough I have to be great at every
variation all the Salient lines so being
thorough as thorough as possible even if
it's obvious you'll be as thorough as
possible say okay I worked out every
variation there's nothing there the more
of those you do the more your vision
just builds and builds over time and
about Desperados we had two very
very um salent things that you should
look at in this tournament first of all
got a kamski's Miss against veran
niobian where he lost because he missed
his Desperado tactic C Tak C4 that was a
key one so you can see it happens to
even the best and the other thing I tell
you to look at is go to the game uh a
couple rounds ago that would be round
four where Fabiano carolana was uh
showing off some analysis um and uh
against Jeffy Jeong that's right and
that was a a brilliant um web of tactics
involving lots of Desperados what you
could do is you could pause the tape and
try to challenge yourself to analyze
those lines and then compare it with
what Fab said yeah exactly and you said
it very well and I say the same thing
don't concern yourself so much with what
comes off of the board but rather what
stays on the board so if you're worried
that you might be a pawn or a piece or
Rook down but you have a mating attack
well that's all important of course it
overrides material con considerations
and just keep plugging away it's the
experience Factor that's going to be um
most
crucial and speaking of material what is
your assessment of the Wesley silver
region of koban you say you like the
extra Pawn but are you shaking in your
boots here as par yeah well this goes
back to the uh days of Michael bod vinck
and many others uh thereafter this whole
Pond sacrifice idea was considered
extremely dangerous for black and most
of the black players of avoided this
particular variation and after takes
Bishop D3 Knight f8 you instantly
understand why um black uh players
wanted to avoid sticking their Knight on
f8 and which um uh keeps the king in the
center white in my experience after
Queen C2 followed by a very quick Knight
F3 and kn5 has been getting some very
serious advantages and I'm sure VAR has
prepared himself well has he made the
right practical decision I would say no
and I think that Wesley uh for one is
very happy uh with this Pawn sacrifice
but you got to love it um veran going
for it he doesn't care who he's playing
you know one thing that strikes me as we
see the camera on Wesley still is that
um his countenance is a lot different
than some of the top players in the
world he doesn't give that like super
super intense look at the board so it
just goes to show that you know you can
have different kind of like positions
and like uh and approaches at the board
he's very composed a real equinity at
the board and you don't get this feeling
of this intense wrath that his brain is
going to explode like you do with Gary
Cas especially oraro yeah or even da
nitzki we saw da early in the tournament
really in great Agony uh while he was
studying a move and Wesley very very
very composed at the board um he looks
great I he looks relaxed yes yes uh so
to the uh position on the board I'm
pretty sure there's a lot of theory in
this game that Wesley has played with
VAR and I'm going to ask uh Maurice to
help our viewers out uh how many games
have been played in this variation
Marice a number of games in this line
and they have favored white primarily as
you said the attack is very smooth but
VAR has prepared very hard for this
tournament and it's hard to imagine that
he's blitzing out his moves or playing
at least as quickly as he has without
having prepared this line and I want to
take you to a game between Fabio and
Carana from five years ago when he was a
mere
2700 player uh yeah 2736 I'm talking
about yeah back in the day now he's 28
plus uh almost 2820 and showing that
that's where he really belongs at 100
points is a lot to gain well he played
this game against mumian back in AA flut
in
2012 and in this position the game
proceeded Knight F3 and now Bishop F5
looking to trade off this dangerous
Bishop Knight to E5 and now Knight to F6
and Rook G1 this was the purpose of the
sacrifice to get the pressure on this G6
pawn and say this Pawn is going to be
mine sooner or later don't act like you
own it well Knight to E4 blocking the LA
on diagonal and now the bishop takes
Knight trade a further trade and queen
B3 threatening Maiden one well Queen A5
check forc the king move and now Queen
B5 and even though they proceeded to an
end game it was white that had the
better coordinations you can see the two
Rooks are in the game the Knight the
bishop all of Black's pieces still on
the back row primarily except this
bishop the bishop did take a pawn and a
slow move Bishop H2 but it didn't matter
because in two moves this is what
happened Knight D7 Rook G6 Bishop F6
Rook to C7 and you can already see from
this position that there's a huge
challenge ahead for black white pie is
just crawling all over him every which
way white went on to win this game
Peruan had better come up with an
improvement to this one because
otherwise Wesley will have a smooth
Victory here today as well and Wesley
did play Fab's move Knight to F3 on the
board right now thank you Maurice and we
have another phone call Jennifer welcome
to the show let us know your name and
your
question hey my name is Joel and I'm
from around a yers old stomping grounds
in Seattle
Washington um my question is I I came to
chess late in life I'm 29 years old uh
but when I was 27 I got an account on
chess.com just to see kind of where
would I be at because I knew the rules
and I was I think I was ranked at 700
level and now I'm at 1500 and so in the
last couple years I've been getting
better but uh for a couple hours of
practice a day could I actually expect
to maybe someday get to Master Level or
is my brain um I guess too too closed
off that's kind of my question to you
guys is with hard work what can I expect
in these later years in life well first
of all thank you Joe for the question
and I think it's a question that many of
our viewers have 29 years old coming
late to the chess game but incredible
Improvement Jen from 700 rating all the
way to 1,500 rating shows there's some
Talent there I I like I think that it's
possible if you say that it's not
possible then it's 100% possible so it's
definitely you got to believe you got to
start with the uh the idea that it is
possible I think it's hard one of I've
had a couple students who've made
massive improvements even as adults but
one thing that they share okay one of
them was a genius like just like really
like IQ is like off the charts and a
mathematician so that was like kind of
like an unfair sample case um but the
other um didn't have like a 9o5 job
right so I feel like either being a
genius or not having a 9 to-5 both
really help right well for me it's about
determination as well as opportunity as
you just very well put it if you're
full-time or even doing you know 50 60
hours a work on your job it's going to
be very difficult for you to dedicate
yourself and to really uh get better but
if you have opportunity why not Joel go
for it Master on its way Maurice did he
say 29 was
old that's the other
issue I didn't want to challenge that
come on man you got plenty of time
you're telling us you're studying two
hours a day you're putting in two hours
a day that is the biggest challenge of
all is being able to consistently put in
a couple of hours at a time that's
awesome and I would say absolutely shoot
for it go for Master you don't know what
your talent level is and your talent has
been on display the fact that you went
from 700 to 1500 that says that your
mind is soaking it up why not go for it
you know see us in a few years when
you've made Master absolutely it's
actually what's harder is if you've been
playing chess for 15 years and then you
want to improve to um at at the age of
27 28 if you just learn chess you can
actually kind of think of that as an
advantage because your brain isn't
riddled with like bad habits from
perhaps having like the wrong coach or
you know not studying when you were
playing um as a teenager and we've got a
couple of comments coming into # us
chess Champs I think uh Maurice is going
to like this one Psychiatry forever says
Love Jennifer yaser and the stunningly
handsome and Dapper Maurice that's three
adjectives keep it up
guys stunning handsome and Dapper delete
delete delete delete and this is a tweet
so they had like a limited number of
characters they still got that all in
just at Maurice Ashley please so I can
retweet that right well thank you very
much Dr Cricket winnows wow okay
compliments we love them keep them
coming um going uh back to the game of
Alexander shabala versus iaro Nakamura
for a moment the it's been a very
unexpectedly for me just a positional
maneuvering game right now it's all
about control over the D5 square and
make no doubts about it white has that
square firmly in his M Ms castles
castles knight uh C3 to D5 I think a lot
of Sicilian players don't like to see
that Knight stuck in the middle of the
board and hikaro has been stewing over
this position for quite some time um and
it's going to be very hard for him to
create a favorable imbalance for himself
uh the whole board is closed and with
this Knight dominating on D5 now what do
you think when when when uh Alexander sh
of Was preparing this morning um do you
think uh that he thought that there was
a good chance that this position would
appear over the board because Nakamura
could have played any number of other
things exactly no I don't because it's
so Hikaru we talk about moving targets
well he's one of the most difficult
players in the world to pin down and I
don't think that shabalov had any
particular expectations of what type of
uh defense hiara could play he car could
play a Berlin he could play frenches he
could play all kinds of things and to
get this particular position I think
that shaba will be very pleased with the
outcome of this opening Maurice someone
else who may be pleased with the outcome
of the opening is varujan akobian take a
look at this line we had mentioned this
move Knight F3 by Fabiano Carana back in
2012 he won that game in style and we
showed that Queen C2 though has been the
much more popular move in this position
Knight F3 3 Bishop F5 was only played
once in fact Knight F3 itself was only
played once and that was in the faab
game and it looks like VAR has come up
with his own novelty because this move
has not been seen before and in fact
it's the engine's very first choice so
he must have looked at this line vuan
niobian prepared it and now he has a
chance to spring it on one Wesley so the
engines are saying that this position is
slightly better now for black after this
move what does Wesley have against this
line did he expect to see it is he
surprised by the move now on the board
we'll see this player has not lost a
single game in 61 tries and it looks
like he's not that stunned because Rook
G1 has been played on the board by him
he played it fairly quickly as well but
the engines are definitely liking black
no question about that the engines even
more so like black after that last move
Bishop H5 is a suggested move now
clamping down on this Pawn on G6 saying
I'm not giving it back to you come hell
high water or you're going to have to
disrupt your play somehow to get it back
the engine saying also the H Pawn is
hanging with the Rook on G1 I don't know
if I had white in this position I'd be
looking my chops thinking there's some
rich possibilities here but black has
the pawn for now and you may have to
prove real compensation with the white
pieces so we definitely have a big
battle of foot in this game thank you
Maurice yeah in my understanding of this
whole line I had actually started with
the move Queen C2 I hadn't given the
move Knight F3 consideration I was
surprised that Fabiano in the database
had played the move because the idea of
Queen C2 is very straightforward you
don't want to allow your opponent this
opportunity to pin the Knight because
that Knight really does belong on E5 you
sacrificed a pawn you sacrificed the G
Pawn for a very clear purpose of getting
that Outpost with this particular Mo
move order that he played that move
Bishop G4 was very disruptive I like the
move Knight F6 I can understand very
well the the computer's greed uh the
move Bishop H5 you want to be able to
capture this Pawn on H4 but this Knight
on F3 being pinned like that that really
disrupts the natural flow of the attack
that Wesley was trying to concoct
Maurice
and another theoretical battle going on
at least the nitki game remember he's
been playing such creative chess it
looks like he's landed the first blow or
at least gotten a nice advantage and
look at him hovering over the board you
don't like when a player is taking up
that much air space over your chess
board you see how the the very tall
naroditsky is almost halfway over the
chess board and there's Jeffrey Jong
just leaning back trying to figure out
what to do next as this is an intense
battle going on right here take a look
at this great position white has gotten
we were here in our variation Queen to
D7 played looking maybe to queenside
Castle uh not without Tempo the Knight
about to head to the C5 Square Bishop to
D5 giving himself some space but now
Knight to C5 taking advantage of this
queen move which may have been a slip
Queen C8 Bishop to D2 the in are saying
all right quickly play Knight to C4 and
try to trade off this bishop remember
this bishop went to G4 to E6 and to D5
that's a number three moves the queen to
D7 and to C8 that's two this Knight was
once on F6 and now to D5 and then over
to B6 so he's been moving a lot of minor
pieces and all he has to show for it is
this Square now he played the natural E6
the engines preferred Knight C4
immediately be contentious threaten the
bishop and the pawn but after Rook to C1
not a real Pawn sack this bishop doesn't
want to go down here and find himself
trapped on this Square suddenly you see
all of the space for white the engines
are saying really nice position for
white if you decide to trade off to give
yourself some room after this move and
let's say you try to Castle in this
position the engines already giving
white a full Pawn Edge because of this
space B4 coming a lot of pressure on
this side and the two Bishops as well
remember Queen C2 will come with Tempo
it looks like Daniel nitzki has gotten
himself a fine position once again and
Jeffrey Jong in trouble remember he just
lost a game to gakamsky one time you l
lose could pre- Sage two he does not
want to go down yet again and see
himself completely knocked out of these
championships thank you marce that move
Queen D2 Queen D7 Pardon Me by Jeffrey
really does look like a slip but
Jennifer unfortunately we've got a
commercial break but we'll be right
[Music]
back
I'm Mike maeni manager of the Cardinals
and chess fanatic many people don't know
that St Louis has a chess history as
rich as its baseball at the
world-renowned chess club and Scholastic
Center of St Louis across from the World
Chess Hall of Fame our goal is to teach
play and promote the sport come to the
Central West End and
exper
[Music]
question on Twitter from
damass uh I should not have pronounced
that uh that was a bit of a trap
yeah for those of you who are new to
chess it might look like ba3 is an
illegal move here because white advances
PA two squares not one but it's a little
something we
call and you can do that but you have to
do it instantly you can't wait for a
move like let's say play King E7 King G2
and I'll try because I couldn't do
it I'm sorry this is this is too funny
forward this is a software glitch I'm
pretty sure there not a
lot Lawrence hello
Lawrence yeah I'll play four against
Lawrence and now is going to play
something against me which we discussed
at length uh during the course of my
stay yeah he told me this is excellent
G5 this was what I was kind of hoping
for because now I think E5 is quite
strong no lawence this is not how chess
Works sadly it would be much much more
fun if chess actually worked like this
but I don't think it does or maybe it
does well that's me regretting what I
just said said how did I get from there
to here is a little bit beyond
me and what's worse I will never hear
the end of
it my quality of life has just gone
downhill tremendously because I'm
actually sharing the office with the
[Music]
guy
welcome back to the 2017 us Chess
Championship we were intrigued by some
of the variations in Wesley so um versus
a Cobian a huge game today um as if
Wesley so manages to win another game he
could really um start uh running ahead
um and we've got uh you were mentioning
Rook G1 Bishop H5 that the night on F3
is pinned and and we were discovering
that uh Queen C2 is possible anyhow now
because after Bishop takes F3 there's
Bishop takes G6 check and Knight G6 uh
Queen G6 King D7 Queen F5 check uh with
Rook G7 behind and uh this uh looks like
uh too much to handle exactly no that
peace sacrifice works very very well for
black but against the move Queen C2
remarkably uh VAR should not be
capturing the Knight on F3
rather instead he should just capture
this Pawn over here on H4 at First Sight
uh it releases the Knight to go to E5
and white looks like he's got a
dominating position till you analyze one
move for further with this move G6 G5
keeping the The Rook on G1 contained
while also stopping all of these
sacrifices on the G6 pawn two pawns for
for black and VAR saying come and get me
and what about Knight G6 here how's that
work at least attacking at least I'm
threatening your Rook on h8 well you
better give this move Pawn takes Knight
takes Pawn takes a double look the
attacker gets attacked yes who's hunting
who remember that Bishop on H5 actually
controls the D1 Square so White's king
is not escaping to the queen side
anytime soon in this particular line and
if I were to play that that's kind of
fun still so if I play G7 G7 I just want
to see how this how the those yeah
Bishops are cool they are and I have
check I have one
move Queen
H4 hello I don't think uh you didn't get
on a 61 game uh non- losing streak uh by
getting your king uh by having Wesley's
King exposed very very dangerous line
for Wesley and Maurice back to you yes
this game certainly because of so many
imbalances in the position is really
attractive to the eye you know this kind
of game we love to look at because
Anything could happen and take a look at
this explosive possibility that could
happen on the board Queen D7 at first
the engine had suggested this move and I
was intrigued by the move it looks very
solid you keep the pin alive you prepare
castling queenside why not well the
engine suggests the enterprising Rook
takes G4 I had to do a double take when
I saw this move I said what's the
purpose of this after Queen G4 you got
rid of the okay you're not pinned but
you're not able to move your knight it
just seems to be no real point to this
move well check this out Knight takes D5
another sacrifice explosive on D5
threatening Knight to C7 and if you were
to take this piece now Queen A4 check
and you start to see the method to the
engine's Madness after this check don't
move your king that's just going to
catch your queen in a noose don't drop
your queen back to block the check
because of a pin on B5 five suddenly
that's horrible as well so we see this
queen A4 check also don't try moving
your king over because Queen A5 check
this bishop and this queen harmonized
and this Pawn on D5 going down with
check if you try to block simply Queen
takes D5 check and The Rook is hanging
and this is all she wrote in this
position so now you see that Black's
choices are limited only Knight to D7 is
possible and now Knight to E5 and this
Knight coming under tremendous pressure
the queen hanging at the moment as well
hey remember G six that's hanging with
cck too it turns out that black is
supposed to be okay according to the
engines with this sudden Desperado the
move that the move that he was talking
about the sacrifice throwing that move
that the previous caller was talking
about throwing it now trust me in caller
even us GMS would have missed something
like that or maybe we'd see it because
we're desperate to get out of the
situation Bishop to B4 with check and
suddenly this King uh this queen and
Bishop are harmonizing against this King
forcing white to actually play the move
Queen takes B4 if you move the king over
this queen starts with Perpetual check
possibilities at least and now the move
now that he's no longer pin Knight takes
E5 Bishop takes E5 and the line goes
Knight to E7 and is apparently now okay
for both sides the engines cryptically
giving triple zeros in this position a
favorite assessment saying ah it was
just flash tactics no big deal at any
rate we see instead it looks like he has
played Knight to F6 as VAR against this
attack I don't recall this being one of
the engine's moves let me get to this
position Rook to G1 no it didn't feature
it actually now I'm seeing it as the
third best option Knight to F6 on the
board and this allows white to play a
move like Queen B1 or queen C2 some of
the lines you guys were discussing at
least in that general direction very
rich position guys crazy chess with all
these imbalances absolutely great to
look at but I got a funny feeling that
VAR could go down in the next 10 moves
well again uh double double edged
position and VAR uh I feel has come to
this game well prepared this hasn't been
uh unexpected let's put it that way
funny to me that Knight F6 is the third
best move in the position when to my
eyes it's the most natural move Bishop
H5 might have been the best move uh
looks a little unnatural what do you do
in the opening well you're supposed to
be developing your pieces and the move
Knight F6 certainly would have had my
stamp of approval but Queen C2 as you
were mentioning Maurice that may be a
reputation of Knight F6 Maurice not a
reputation actually the only reason
Knight F6 the engine considered the
third best moves is because the engin
thought that black had better they
thought black should have played Bishop
H5 and gone for it in this position let
me just go back a move to this one they
thought that here the move uh Bishop H5
should have been played or even Queen D7
in the line we just saw where white is
is like throwing out pyrot Technics to
get equality it is not that white is
better in this position and KN at six
doesn't signal that black is necessarily
any worse according to the engines Queen
C2 only draws after takes takes check
Knight takes on G6 Queen check King to
D7 and now the Eng is saying you better
play this sequence fearlessly going into
this line I mean those of us who'd be
shock who'd be terrified of a potential
Rook G7 crashing into the position we
have to face a Fearless engine after
Queen to D7 this kind of position if
you've already prepared it with black
you probably looked at it and said oh
I'm safe those of us seeing it for the
first time thinking first time wait wait
wait you really want to play chess like
this this could be big trouble for you
but if VAR has prepared it it looks as
though it is black for choice in this
position by a long way and it's going to
be Wesley having to figure out is he
actually just going to make a quick draw
out of this position wow interesting uh
game to be sure I just wanted to turn
our attention to the game between Fabby
and Gata for a moment because it seems
to me I've seen this POS the exact
position that the players have achieved
quite a number of times I'm sure there's
a lot of games in the database uh
because after this move F6
F5 uh what what has been played Knight
C2 F5 F4 by G closing off the king side
in the center preventing Knight E3 where
the eye where the Knight is eyeing these
two very nice outposts F5 and D5 the
players actually played this position
very slowly and this
seems as far as I'm concerned uh all
Theory Maurice I just saw the camera
there just for a second did I see Wesley
get up from the board it's his turn uh
that's a bit of an unusual no oh he's
back okay I thought I'd seen him just
get up for the for a second so it must
have been a different image but uh this
position here I I'm telling you this is
very solid for black right now in this
game and yes of course it's a popular
linez Queen H5 has been played by fabbi
after much thought move I'm surprised by
in the game between Hikaru and shabalov
Hikaru aiming for this light squared
Bishop this is a bishop that white
absolutely doesn't mind seeing disappear
from the board because of course he's
controlling all the light squares so if
you can get rid of another light square
piece from a positional standpoint seems
like a good trade for white no matter
what happens in that position but uh it
seems saru is going for this line in
fact after the move A4 the engines don't
have Knight C4 as a move even in the
first three moves the top three moves of
the engine they're ignoring Knight takes
C4 Rook C8 is one Knight F6 is another
Rook E8 is a third Knight C4 not showing
up as a great move right here to me it
just seems odd to trade off this night
for this light Square Bishop when you
should be preserving pieces that can
trade off on D5 maybe on the E7 Square
because this bishop is the challenge
kind of a a strange move by Hikaru we'll
see what his 2800 eyes have in mind
after playing such a move thank you
Maurice and I just want to turn our
attention to a crucial game in the US
Women's Championship between Reena and
nii let's go back to this opening
position we left it after the move
Bishop B4 check Bishop D2 was played by
Arena and after the trade on D2 she
recaptured with a Queen Bishop to A6
tickling this Pawn on C4 Queen C2 all of
these moves look like uh well-known well
trodden Theory until we see this move C7
C5 all right with the trade of the dark
squar Bishop Arena said let me capture
that pawn and let me start to pounce on
this backward D7 Pawn especially the
square D6 arena is aiming to try to get
her Rook to D1 and quite likely probably
this Knight to D6 if she can do that she
would have a strangle hold on Black's
position D6 by Nagi and we're up to date
with the players uh is this a position
that black is interested in uh defending
for a long long time with this backward
Pawn after Rook D1 I think arena is
going to be pleased with the outcome of
this opening and we've got Grandmaster
Robert hes um he's in which is great and
he actually has a lot of experience from
uh coaching the Women's Championship
team in the Olympiad exactly and he says
um points out that Sabina foer if not
for an unfortunate slip against Crush
would actually be in clear first in the
Women's Championship and that's true
Saina foer is in plus one and she's had
opportunities in this tournament to be
have an even greater score now she's
mixing it up against against T
abrahamian and not only that uh Sabina
is the only player in the field to have
all decisive games no draws three wins
two losses and a shout out to Robert you
did such great work for our US Women's
team thank you Robert
Maurice fellow New Yorker Robert hes
glad to know you're watching and fellow
Nick fan as well yeah it's not another
bad year for us we're going to get it
together at some point this position
between Sabina foer and tatev Abraham
very interesting position an interesting
moment in the game we talk about
exchanges right here Sabina stopped and
thought for quite some time I got a
feeling y you would have probably played
instantly in this position the imbalance
that's created after the move e takes F3
well-known one D4 is pretty much
Unstoppable and now these two Bishops
Bishops had already been conceded by
black in this game and you see this
bishop on this long diagonal looking to
make some trouble after Queen E7 Rook F
to E1 one D4 will happen at the right
time F4 will also happen maybe after
moving this bishop Off The Square so
this trade on F3 creating an imbalance
that looks good for white another trade
on F3 that took place is in another game
this one between Anna Zony and Carissa
Yip again the idea of two Bishops
against a knight and a bishop we see it
here Carissa Yip played Queen to C2
right in this moment this queen and this
bishop were on her Knight she said Queen
C2 I dare you to take this Pawn well
Anna knew better taking this Pawn allows
Bishop to E4 with a hit on the B7 Square
so she didn't want to take that but she
did want to at least take the bishop
take the Knight and Fracture the pawn
structure and then play the move C6 now
this Pawn is under threat a dynamic
position with open file on the G file
reminiscent of the Wesley so game
against verua niobian where there's a
lot of action happening on that F3
Square as well and a third game on the
women's side showing an imbalance here
the two Bishop Bishops against the
Knight this bishop also traded back here
on F3 so we see this theme popping up
again and again with the black pieces
and that light Square Bishop Bishop F3
E6 the game proceeded very quickly into
this active line as A6 move Queen drop
back B5 she said here we go E4 D4 and
after E5 F4 so these two Bishops trying
to prove that they are dominant in this
type of position very imbalanced play in
all these games again the players are
refresh and ready looking for a fight
today sure it does feel that way don't
it doesn't it that they players are
really come to this round with a great
deal of energy and after the move Knight
F6 in that Wesley so game that we've
been keeping a careful eye on Wesley has
actually taken quite some time as he's
now looked at those lines with Queen C2
Bishop F3 Bishop takes G6 that Perpetual
check that Maurice uh showed as earlier
and uh Robert had a comment on that game
as well he said that he thought it was a
strange DEC decision by so um for such a
practical player to play Knight F3
before Queen C2 agreed agreed I was a
little bit surprised that uh Wesley
allowed it is us going to go to the game
between uh da and um Jeffrey Jong
because when Maurice left it he just
played this move uh Rook takes C5 and
Maurice was
explaining that with all of the space
Cas and two Bishops that uh basically
the only thing black has to say about it
is this bishop on D5 and with this move
Queen E7 which for me was a little bit
surprising I play this line as black
this Queen's Gambit accepted variation
and I've gotten into oh pardon me A2 A4
uh I meant to say not A3 um I really
feel very
uncomfortable in this position as black
I don't like that Knight E4 Knight C5
and I think that Jeffrey has just fallen
into a line that is very difficult for
him however he does have uh the famous
tactic on tap which is this Knight takes
D4 Knight takes whoops black okay let me
just play a bad move for white for
example
B4 no Knight B4 Knight takes D4 Knight
takes D4 Queen H4 check and how many of
us who have ever played chess have not
fallen for a tactic like this I think
everybody and in my case probably about
times yeah Fork you Fork you all right
so uh but in any case I do feel that
Jeffrey is under severe pressure and
Daniel has actually played a very
impressive tournament thus far and he
stands amongst our leaders so um well
behind so yeah behind the the pack of
contenders he's in the contending pack
no question and let's take a a look at
the standings to remind you we've got
Wesley so ahead of Nakamura and nitzki
jeruk Robson and aian so a nice mix of
Youth college students Olympians in the
contending pack but this game today
between so and aian so huge because if
so manages to um attack and defeat a
koban he has a chance to run away with a
tournament meanwhile if koban draws or
wins that also allows the pack to catch
up with Wesley exactly so a really big
game and we're still waiting for Wesley
to make a move he does still have a
10-minute Advantage but um this is a
critical moment and he's taking his time
yeah because if there's nothing better
than that Perpetual check that mauie
showed that would be a big uh
theoretical win for VAR and Maurice back
to you it's definitely a surprising
situation and he's played Rook
G3 uh let me just first talk about this
position and then we'll let you go on
that move Rook G3 which he surprised all
of us with Nakamura with the black
pieces playing this move Knight to A4 we
talk about this exchange all the time
Bishop for Knight usually it's Bishop
takes Knight as we've seen on many other
boards in this case it was Knight takes
Bishop creating the imbalance and when
you play Knight takes light squared
Bishop generally speaking is because you
feel like you're going to dominate the
dark squares you removed uh this light
squared piece you removed you removed
your knight from the board so now the B
sorry you have this you have this piece
and your opponent has this piece so
therefore you're going after the light
squares this bishop is the key piece you
have a piece that your opponent doesn't
have it's the opponent who thinks they
have the dark squares I had that
backwards excuse me so I have a knight a
knight and a bishop these three can
control dark squares you're left for the
bishop that can only control light
squares and these two pieces can control
dark squares to compete but I'll always
have my extra piece that can control
dark squares so you think you're going
to control light squares when you make
an exchange like this one but in this
case it's obvious white has no problems
on the light squares he's got D5
underlock he's got C4 he's got E4 so
black doesn't have any light Square
domination and likely all likelihood
Black's going to take this Knight at
some point now it is also known that
sometimes this Knight can become a paper
tiger it looks good but it's not doing
anything on that square that hurts
anyone so black can proceed with King H
G6 F5 and continue his attack in the
position so maybe that is the point that
that Nakamura is going after I remember
a famous game illustrating this point
between vasel ivanchuk with the white
pieces and Gary kaspar with the black
pieces and Gary just showed he said your
Knight's on D5 I don't care I'm just
going to work around it and it was like
mad magic the way he got his attack
going so the the big critical question
is this clear positional Edge if you
going back to the old school classical
players they'd say white is dominant
here I mean are you kidding look at that
D5 square that he just owns and there is
no way of ejecting this piece if you
keep trading you'll just keep trading
off until another piece lands on that
square we'll see what Hikaru is thinking
about in this positional struggle in
this game but we got to get to the other
one guys take a look at that Wesley so
playing Rook G3 which was not on tap for
the engine uh seriously Maurice thank
first of all thank you for that uh
explanation what's going on a very
positional game but this game between
Wesley and VAR about to explode I really
don't like this move Rook G3 of course
the motivation was very clear uh uh
Wesley uh protecting his Knight on F3 in
order that he can play the move Queen C2
and get out of the PIN but guess what
look at this King on the first rank the
move that immediately starts uh begs to
be played is this move G6 G5 fighting
for the initiative what is Black's idea
of returning the pawn sacrifice well
after H4 takes G5 H6 takes G5 Bishop
takes G5 Rook H1 check hello that's not
a move that white wants to see and white
would be forced to retreat with the move
Bishop F1
and that just it it feels all WR 94
could be a problem yeah well it just it
just feels wrong in the position that
you would want to allow this Knight E4
like you can't take because of Pawn E4
and I'm wondering about the tactics
after Bishop E7 Knight takes G3 Bishop
takes d8 Rook takes F1 well Knight E4
can I play Rook G4 J oh that way I can
take on uh I can take on G5 but that's
not what I wanted yeah exactly I'm
thinking you want to go Queen
D7 this game is has been explosive from
the start but it sure seems to me that
VAR has a big chance of of stopping the
Wesley train uh what a streak and what
would that mean Maurice you're inting
sir dead on point yeah sir that back
rank Rook G3 just allowed as you feel
the air of that King fell he's like
where you going get back get back stay
back here too late G5 is a huge move and
the injuries are screaming for it and if
we look at the line after G5 this Pawn
is under attack so if you move your
Bishop he's taking it for nothing he's
just going to capture the pawn so must
be very careful here H takes G5 H takes
G5 excuse me Bishop takes G5 Rook check
of course you can't bring the Rook back
because of this pin along this diagonal
so you have to play Bishop to F1 to save
your queen the in is actually giving the
very Nuance Queen C8 yes instead of
Queen D7 just to avoid the Knight E5
shot so your queen is completely out of
any range of this Knight and now you
have trouble with Bishop H3 potentially
coming and also dangerous Bishop to D6
what's he doing on G3 I mean that Rook
is trapped on that square and will
likely be sacrificing itself very
shortly the engines give Bishop takes on
F6 for now and now this move G takes on
F6 in the position and still this Rook
is a problem these squares are covered
this Knight's going nowhere
how can this be anything but worse for
white the only problem for black right
now is castling that doesn't seem like
it's going to take too long to do Wesley
is in absolute trouble if G5 lands on
the board he will be in serious danger
VAR is not known to take a lot of risk
but this seems one of those Pawn
sacrifices returning the pawn that is
without any risk it's just a good-look
position and he sees it I'm sure he sees
it the question is will he play it now
in this this streak Wesley has not done
it smoothly like 100% smooth don't be
fooled he has had horrible positions he
has had dead loss positions the one
against raor in tata steel comes to mind
he was dead in that position but somehow
he finds a way to squirm out of it who's
going to be the one that stops him and
lands the blow well I can tell you the
rest of the field is hoping that it will
be one VAR Cobian to stop wesy and Wes's
just walking around eating some like
what is that a Snicker some kind of
candy bar like whatever is happening he
seems like he's okay but this man knows
he has a golden opportunity will he find
and play the move G5 well he's a French
player so he's used to playing G5 for
the attack and by the way um Grandmaster
Josh forell actually chimed in as well
he said he thought that Wesley should
pre-move 14 Rook takes G4 pre-move
referring to what you do when you're
playing a bullet or a Blitz game and you
play the move regardless of what your
opponent's going to play right so he
must not have agreed with Rook G3 either
and uh we'll keep our eyes on on VAR and
see if he plays that move G5 giving him
the initiative against a super hot SE
we'll be right back um and we'll have
more for you in that
[Music]
game
e
[Music]
welcome back to the 2017 us chess
championships and there we have it
Peruan Coan did play the move G5 and on
the board now so sine yes absolutely
that was the move that was begging to be
played I don't know if Wesley actually
underestimated the strength of this move
G6 G5 sacrificing the pawn and he's got
to take it and he and he's done it but I
mean the analysis that Maurice gave was
really um scary piece of analysis for
Wesley so's fans as verian with this
move Rook H1 check seizes the initiative
now the the really tough move here I
think most grand Masters are begging
uh to play the move Queen D7 in order to
be able to Castle you develop your queen
to this nice diagonal you protect the
bishop you you threaten this move Bishop
D6 all of the but this really subtle
move Queen C8 the differences between
playing the queen to D7 and the queen to
C8 that's really really hard to decipher
but should VAR come up with this move C
Queen C8 the streaks in real Jeopardy
very quick Rec capture there by VAR on
the G5 and again the line is very
forcing uh there's nothing really to
talk about Rook H1 shck Bishop F1 and
they will get to that crucial position
where the move Queen C8 will give VAR a
huge Advantage should he find that move
and Maurice coming back to you and it's
entirely possible that Wesley missed
Queen C8 as opposed to Queen D7 maybe he
thought he'd make something out of this
particular position although I don't
think he'd play this with G5 in his head
it's hard to imagine you letting a rook
land on H1 with all this natural play
for black but assuming he did see deeply
into the position and saw this position
Queen to D7 Knight to E5 does save white
and black must go into this ending after
Bishop takes D1 Knight takes on D7 and
the best move is to just keep this
bishop in the position Bishop to H5 and
after Knight takes f8 you're not talking
about any advantage at all for black
just zero Edge in this position even
though you have this pin here it's just
not that much for example let's say you
play King f8 now you play Rook to H3 you
got to trade this off and this is a
drawn position suddenly so this position
here would save him but it's a big
difference between the queen going to D7
and he has played Rook H1 we're waiting
for Bishop F1 this move versus this one
now here there is no Knight E5 your
knight just pinned Bishop D6 is
threatened all the nice lines we saw
earlier for black and in this position
the engine is giving a real Edge to
White the only move the engine gives
right now the best line is Queen to B3
Bishop to D6 and now the move Knight to
E5 Bishop to H3 Rook takes on H3 and
this line where you're getting chased
Rook check King takes Queen takes on H3
with check and now King back to E1 the
King on able to Castle black castling in
this position a very straightforward
capture line after Queen to C8 forcing
White's hand
tremendously it looks like a normal
position if only you could play this
move oops you can't your king is caught
in the middle and now it's going to be
Black's turn to have some fun is it
decisive well it's not completely
completely busted right now but
certainly white is in trouble now that
this Rook has landed on H1 when is the
last time you've seen a top game where
Rook H1 check by black has been played
in the middle game and and the Early
Middle game is that can you remember any
game
yes I'd have to go Way Way Back Into The
Archives to come up with that but no I
mean you're absolutely right I it's such
a rarity uh indeed and again this move
Queen D7 in that line Maurice that you
were showing you immediately played Rook
takes F1 check was there a reason why
the queen on C8 couldn't have just
recaptured that Rook it was the bishop
H3 move that you had put down you went
Rook takes right here yeah you went Rook
takes F1 Queen takes H3 I think
everybody in our audience would say whoa
give me that Rook yes indeed very good
point to make here the problem is after
castles suddenly yeah sacrificing
suddenly the King is safe and after Rook
takes now for the moment you're down a
full Rook right except after Queen takes
on B7 it is white who has the advantage
in this position remember step one
you're hanging a rook step two you're
hanging check on C6 step three you're
hanging check on F7 as well F7 this one
let's make a random move well you could
actually play Rook takes here he'll
remove this KN from play just to make
sure you have nothing else and if you
play something like Queen to C8
defending suddenly there's this move
check and queen takes and from his back
to standing and punching is white
because Suddenly It's white who's
attacking in this position Black's King
cut off along the rank and white has all
the aggressive play so a very good point
Y but it looks as though the line does
not win any material at all in fact it
allows white to come back in the game so
he has to be careful there another
little trick it just shows how dangerous
chess is you think I always tell players
it doesn't matter and I've said this
before actually in this broadcast it
doesn't matter if you think you're
winning it doesn't matter if you're
better I'm better I have a great
position I have attacking chances look
at the sweet position I caught my
opponent in the opening good luck with
that that's just the start of your
problems now it's your responsibility to
come up with genius moves to figure out
how to win the game it's not enough to
get a good opening sure you don't want
to have a bad opening but it's not
enough to have a good opening you still
have accurate move after accurate move
consistent an idea tactics to duck
counterplay to make sure you suppress
that's all ahead of you no matter how
good your position is so you have to
play move after move after move and VAR
has a big responsibility on his hands to
find those accurate moves right now so
that's why a Defender like Wesley is
going to sit there and say okay you're
right I messed up I get it I got to
forget about that though and I'm going
to play the position and if you slip up
I'll be back see my thing is I think
fobia might play Queen D7 here just cuz
that that uh end game after 95 doesn't
look too bad and um that might just
coers him into playing the more natural
moov so this is like a really big moment
and we see him thinking which um you
know once he starts looking for
candidate moves I think the chances of
him uh selecting Queen CA go up but well
exactly because if it was a Blitz game
and you had no time Queen D7 is such a
natural move you want to get off the
first or back rank in in this particular
case Queen C8 is really really nice that
that really puts the onus on Wesley and
I'll point out I'll point out that white
is actually uh threatening Bishop F6 in
this position I mean white yes begins to
respond to you like white is saying I do
have ideas white is also quote unquote
threatening to move the queen in Castle
yes and I'm sure that's what that's what
Wesley is hoping to happen maybe he even
expected it to happen happen he might
argue that is what's going to happen I'm
going to move my queen and I'm going to
Castle and if you allow that okay wait a
minute it looks like he is playing Queen
C8 the way he has got his hand the way
that hand looks like it's going
horizontal looks like he's found it and
he's checking again this variation will
he find the move now he's hesitating the
other issue in this game is the clock he
is behind on time is VAR so sometimes
you can get a good position but the
clock is not your friend seemed much
worse in the Championships yes of course
not of course he's fine right now he's
got 40 minutes with 23 moves to go so
he's basically got over an hour with a
30 second increment but any little bit
of pressure he's 27 minutes behind right
now on the clock any little bit of
pressure could cause you to falter but
he knows it he knows it and how sweet
would it be the revenge from that
ignominious defeat last year in 24 moves
to play something like Queen C8 and take
down the man who's had a 61 game
unbeaten streak will he play Queen C8
and he shot a look
at and I like your observation about the
slide you got it8 is on the board it
looked like he wasn't trying to push it
forward but slided I I saw the same
thing saw the same thing absolutely
we've been around the block once tce you
guys play a lot of Blitz you're used to
that that that side to side more like a
poker thing I was like he's moving in
he's moving in but Queen C8 the big time
move has just been played by VAR and
that streak is on the line suddenly
because Bishop D6 all of these threats
in involving Bishop H3 those that
Maurice has been pointing out whoa
unfortunately this game has gotten so
much of our attention we've kind of been
missing some of the action on the other
boards as well
Maurice and I don't know what's going on
on this board what did g just do he just
played the move Bishop from C8 to E6 now
I've written about this before before
but I've also done a DVD on what Grand
Masters don't see the kind of mistakes
they make but also the idea of every
time you move you create a drawback and
I call it iido chess or drawback chess
this move creates a very simple drawback
he controls the E6 Square positional
move I mean controls the D5 Square
positional move simple enough but what's
the drawback to the move well clearly it
no longer defends the A6 Square so your
eyes should be drawn to that possibility
and most people might just see it
instantly what what happens if this
Pawn's just taken off the board suddenly
you just drop the pawn right and what's
your purpose in dropping the pawn
where's the Counterattack what's your
point and the more you look at it the
more the engine looks at it it says it's
just a pawn that's it got tosky has just
blunder a pawn this Knight's going to
rep Park itself Forever This Pawn's
supposed to play A5 in some position and
look at that he knows it and he's
shaking his head disastrous blunder for
gakamsky as he now realizes that he has
in fact made an egregious error and this
one will be fatal against a player of
Fabiano's class he just can't stand it
right now he's expecting to see this
shot on the board Knight takes A6 he's
been saying how he's been blundering
more and more these days making the kind
of blunder you would never ever see from
a five-time world champion uh US
champion a world champion candidate to
see him make the these kind of mistakes
guys I mean he made a a howler against
vuan niobian earlier in the tournament
that was a brilliant Queen sacrifice not
so amazing and astonishing but still
nevertheless attractive this though is
worse by far this is just a this is just
a rookie mistake this even your even
your 1800s out there going not me I
wouldn't L to like that wow absolutely
Maurice egregious and got knows it I
mean and he's just shaking his head in
recognition of this horrible mistake
he's just made which might obviously it
blunders one Pawn but it might even just
blunder two look at him shaking his head
also he's got no Poker Face here
obviously 100 times out of a 100 Fabiano
Carana GNA see this but if he's playing
against a weaker player don't don't go
shaking your head right after you make a
bad move but Fab's probably in shock
probably fa's going where is the
counterplay there's no way he blunder
his Pawn it's impossible I mean against
me Fabby would just take the pawn and
smirk but he's looking at God and going
there's something here there there's got
to be something why would he just donate
a pawn which may be two and I just win
the game without any effort right out of
the opening with nothing going on well
you don't think favano sees gotta um you
know walking around he did not see he
didn't see him he was got was on the
other see Fab's all the way on the other
side of the room okay got God can bang
his head against a wall he could be he
could air scream or whatever silent
scream he can do whatever he wants cuz
fby would have to turn around 180 to
look to see his opponent's expression
and so he's not going to come back to
that board he's just going to let Fabby
look at it until finally he sees the
hammer drop and Knight captures on A6
such an emotional game gotsky playing
one of the most beautiful um games in
either section yes two days ago before
the rest day and now playing one of the
worst yes and and you just saw uh on
your webcam there Fabby kind of just
like what what's going on he was
reaching uh to play his movement Knight
takes A6 once he executes that on the
board I I really feel that
uh he can't believe it he's he's almost
embarrassed like I'm going to take on A6
is this real I mean he clearly sees it
well again and the Very obvious concept
behind Knight takes A6 is Maurice was
mentioning this bishop no longer
defending this
Pawn on A6 means that after Rook takes
A6 it would be materially decisive and
he's done it he's grabbed the Free Pawn
no surprise there our our defending
champion this is huge AER because if
Wesley doesn't win that allows uh
Fabiano to um right back in the mix uh
forget about winning if Wesley loses
then verian leading the tournament
verian leading the tournament Fabby ties
Wesley I mean all of a sudden and then
the rest of the field could Leap Frog
Wesley or even Ty Wesley as well so huge
moment moments happening right now right
away in round six just after the rest
day good thing everybody picked veru
niobian to win the tournament nobody
nobody picked VAR except for VAR and his
wife lovely life uh but but right and
and they Oney old uh but Knight takes A6
and you know got just like just trying
to you know you know hold on to his uh
emotions at this moment because he's
know he knows that he just pitched a
crucial Pond and has just made the move
castles and here comes his executioner
Fabiano Carana who knows now after
castles that that was just a gift yeah
and there should be no way in the world
you get enough counterplay to donate
upon Pawn to this level player where he
can just bring his Knight back to B4
with no effort and there it is instantly
and he knows this is busted yeah he just
snatched a very crucial Pawn too I mean
that was that was holding up the 3 to1
majority on the queen side and now uh
it's it's Desperado time he has to go F5
he has to because he's going to he's
going to lose the game uh if he just
does nothing F7 F5 closes his eyes says
okay I mean I got to go into Desperado
mode now and to try to use this clump of
central ponds to create some tactical
complications and hope that Fabby spoils
it you know the worst part about this
the clock look at the clock times 32
minutes to look how long look how much
he invested in the position to get to
this moment to play Bishop E6 remember
we talked about long think wrong think
if you don't know what's going on
sometimes you just make a mistake he
spent all that time to be down this
heavily on the clock and now he's in
Rapid chess mode after this move it's
it's incredible that he finds himself
here it's 18 moves into the game guys
he's got 22 moves to make to make time
control and he's way behind on the clock
and he's dead loss in the position just
uh it's sad to see it's sad to see him
playing this badly he's somebody you
might have called a dark horse in this
tournament after all he's won it five
times but his self-confidence is gone
and there's some kind of clarity
that's just missing from his play and
he's in deep trouble right now well your
last game though was so beautiful I mean
this whole concept of Rook D3 Rook F3
which he saw um and outsmarted His World
Junior Champion opponent so I think when
he plays well he plays very well but
then unfortunately there's just these
aberration that show up yeah the queen
takes C4 now having said all of the
horrible things about his position what
he's done to wreck it uh why did he play
the move F7 F5 well he's got a Desperado
idea in mind you capture this Pawn so
that's Pawn number two in White's pocket
you drop back with the bishop uh Queen
drops back to grab all of these light
squares notice there is one trick you
don't want to go back to F3 potentially
putting your King on the E file there is
a E5 E4 possibility and black could
attempt to grab the piece in this manner
uh trades on e4 you got to play F3 and
thank goodness for black that he's got
one D6 Pawn to play the move D5 so you
go all the back all the way back to E2
with the queen queen E2 and now you
after the move D you're going to be up
three but guess what after that's
danger you know I mean okay I'm busted
black is busted no question and the
computer will be laughing and saying
plus four plus five but from the human
point of view there's counterplay here I
mean it's easy to go wrong for example I
just throw down some more Pawn
sacrifices F3 G takes F3 Bishop H5 and
there's no way Fabby would sign up for
this so can we bail out earlier with
something like F6 I just like I'm sure
there CL I'm up two pawns right so I was
wondering after this I me instead of
Queen H5 like if I play F6 um and you
play Queen takes F6 Queen F5 and I'm
forcing the trade of Queens uh in the
variation after takes yeah I wanted to
drop that Bishop F7 I was just I was
just glancing at this move F6 because
you can't take with the bishop because
of Queen H6 and if you play Queen F6 I
was hoping to trade the Queens just to
avoid all the fun that you were having
true that I mean uh that's a very
uh stable approach a safe approach uh
that keeps white on top so say it
doesn't look like you have Queen F5
Bishop F5 Bishop A2 because I do have
Bishop E4 there so yeah no I definitely
this is a a professional approach I'm
just saying that in in Goda shoes he
knows he's blundered the game away this
is what he was hoping to try to get some
counter chances by just throwing away
three two three Pawns in a row wow what
a what a turnaround this uh blunder um
has given Fabby and that's probably what
caused Fabby Paws those types of
variations but um seeing that he can uh
either grab the pawns or liquidate um
into a better position gives him a lot
of comfort that he can decide when he
gets closer to the time exactly got to
play quickly got to played very quickly
so it's as though he's saying I plann
this
sacrifice because Fabby doesn't know his
re God's reaction at all we do but fabbi
doesn't M good point again this game has
taken uh this in the Wesley game has
taken
so much of our Focus we haven't even
mentioned in passing a game uh between
Alex and uh Yaro Yaro has been doing
very well in this tournament it's a
grunfeld defense uh players have played
a very theoretical topical uh position
we do have this position on the
board feels like it's okay for black
after we just saw this move Bishop takes
E7 Rook to D D7 still thanks to this
Pawn on E5 I'll give white a small Edge
but I don't think it's anything really
special Yaro yaroslav in his debut here
in these US championships is equating
himself very very well that's right and
meanwhile Alexander onook only on an
even score but if you think about the
field of player he's faced so far um
he's already played against Wes so he's
already played against Fabiano carolana
so he could certainly have a good
tournament himself if he could if he
could uh decisively win this game but we
have a very special guest in our studio
here we have we actually have a couple
of special guests so we're so excited
this year that the St Louis chess club
is partnering with the St Louis fashion
fund um and yes at the opening ceremony
we saw that that was a cute opening yeah
at the opening ceremony the players
chose sketches from the artists of the
inaugural class of the St Louis fashion
fund to determine their pairing Lots
right and we have um we have uh Susan
Sherman and Eric Johnson of St Louis
fashion fund to tell us more about all
of
that yes uh two of my favorite people
the these people are great creative
artists and they're emerging fashion and
chess Susan Sherman the chairman of the
board and Eric Johnson the executive
director welcome to the show thank you
Maurice last time we sat here it was
only an Inception uh conception at its
Inception uh the the idea of bridging
chess and fashion something a lot of
people may not be comfortable with but
you guys have been working really hard
and since then a lot has happened tell
us first of all what the chess design
challenge fashion design challenge is so
as we said last time it feels like it
was just yesterday we were here um we
were pairing six of our incubator
designers with six chess Grand Masters
including yourself to come up with a
chess uniform and they've been working
since January on their sketches which we
unveiled at the opening of the
Championships you know the other night
and they'll continue to work with the
grand Masters in a really solid
partnership going back and forth until
they unveil their prototypes in August
at a big event here in St Louis and then
the winner will receive $10,000 a
$10,000 scholarship it's going to be
tough I mean they're working really hard
on this and taking it very seriously I
know I was with mine uh yesterday Audra
no and uh we're going to
win no doubt we we just we're just going
to win the rest they can keep TR that's
right how's it been going Eric at the
Fashion fun I was down there yesterday
and I saw you regaling a bunch of ladies
with your wit and they were just
laughing it up I didn't even know what
you were saying but the laughter was so
loud you were distracting us well every
day is um an exciting day at the St
Louis fashion incubator and we've been
open now since January 9th we have all
of our six designers in place we're also
really working with the community to
bring them into our space uh not only to
show them what we're doing but to you
know offer the uh fashion and designer
Community here in St Louis tools to help
their businesses grow um so you know uh
again I I uh would say that it was a fun
event we had um the Women's Club uh down
to our space to uh be with our designers
and to understand the incubator and it's
just you know uh a fabulous way that you
know we're getting the word out about
the work that we're doing Susan so us
what do you see as the net effect of
something like this to bridge chess and
fashion together for both fi
well I mean chess what you all have done
here I mean making St Louis the chess
capital I said the United States and
that you're opening they said of the
world has been nothing short of
miraculous and you know we think that in
fashion we can kind of learn from you I
mean you you built this chess campus
we're trying to rebuild a garment
district and you did it in a couple of
years and we're trying to do the same
and I think for us it's really job
creation and economic development so yes
we have these designers and we're
accelerating their businesses but long
term we're looking to bring back
creatives into the Garment District and
really start some small batch production
there and um kind of bring an industry
back I guess you've brought an industry
here we're trying to bring one back but
Eric you're coming out of New York I
know and now you're in St Louis what is
it like how exciting is it to be at the
Forefront of something like this the the
Renaissance once again of fashion here
in St Louis yeah I mean I think it was
really as as I described it to uh to
Susan as I was interviewing for this
position is really a once- in a-lifetime
experience and um you know I think that
especially coming from New York where
you know uh there's so much going on to
come to St Louis where we have this Rich
tradition in this case of Chess and to
be able to merge these worlds and to
create something that together is so
much bigger than any of us could do on
our own is just such a great um
experience for our organization and
hopefully it's uh one for the World
Chess Hall of Fame as well well I'm very
excited about it like I said we're going
to win no no no no I got Emily Jennifer
has a good
chance whatever talk about style that
woman doesn't need a chess uniform that
that that is the truth that is the truth
but Jen I'm sorry you know we're
competitive and uh we we're looking we
got some interesting designs coming I'm
sure they do too but we're keeping ours
in SEC okay cool can't wait thank you so
much for joining us absolutely pleasure
to be a part of this project Susan
Sherman and Eric Johnson doing their
thing for fashion and chess it'll be an
exciting summer as August comes and we
unveil all these spectacular designs
that's right get suited up in that chess
uniform yes yeah
unveil uh our viewers can't see uh a
peak of what some of the designs are
looking like well there are sketches
there there are photographs of the
sketches up on the US Chet Championship
site oh there are so you can check it
out there and uh yeah Maurice is trash
talking but you got to go check out this
website y Ming well those those outfits
I would wear anything that uh Emily
makes wonderful but let's take a look at
uh some of our fashionable chess players
somebody posted a tweet the other day
like since there's so many cameras are
the players more fashion conscious and
more Beauty conscious and I would say
yes I think the players both sides the
open and in the women's paying more
attention to what they're wearing
knowing that they kind of have a
platform with people watching them from
all over the world absolutely and that's
not a bad thing no on the contrary I
think it's great and there is a sort of
a dress code it's not strictly enforced
please no sneakers t-shirts or jeans and
we're not United leggings are
allowed uh but I I definitely have
recognized that thanks to all of these
webcams and the video videos of the
players the players are more fashion
conscious and they're dressing
accordingly that's right it's not just
wearing a suit it's wearing a suit that
fits
right we got a let's take a take a look
uh you you were you were looking at the
so akobian game and we just we're still
in that move Queen B3 continuing to mix
it up he's got to in this position and
fuan a Coan with less than half the time
that Wesley so has so you know uh
fortune favors the Bold they say fortune
favors the well prepared but uh Fortune
also favors the guy with twice as much
time in his clock I'm going to add back
to the saying our block well Fortune
also favors the guy who's got the better
position and definitely veran has got
the better better position Maurice your
insights yes this position is just
horrible for white because his King is
going to be stuck in the middle of the
board that's the biggest challenge here
just looking at this line after Queen B3
the move Bishop to D6 the more the
engines look at it the more they like it
and they're thinking you know what you
might just sack an exchange in this
position because this position is going
to be horrible any second after this
move Bishop to D6 if you play Knight to
E5 now the move Bishop takes on E5 D
takes on E5 then are pointing out the
possibility of Queen to F5 leaving this
pawn and preparing to Castle quickly by
the way leaving this hanging temporarily
but because Queen D3 a monster move
dropping into the position threatening
mate on F1 and you could try as much as
you want this game will be over in the
next few moves this is Unstoppable mate
in fact so D Bishop Bishop takes E5 D5
Queen F5 is a big time move the Eng is
already going desperate with the move E4
trying to keep black out of the position
but it's all over but the crying in this
case so we know this is not a move
Wesley will play so what is taking VAR
so long to play Bishop to D6 it is the
most obvious move on the board just
attack The Rook the only possibility
could be well I should point out this
other possibility Bishop to F4 is
playable and after takes takes the move
Knight to H5 attacking this Rook this
Rook is defending this Knight there's
nothing to do you must capture this
bishop and after this queen takes G4
this seems to be a temporary respit for
the moment to maybe be able to play a
move like Knight to E5 and chase this
queen and look out look out for this
Pawn maybe castles the engine say yeah
that's actually a good move but Rook
takes F1 would wake you up and still
keep a big Initiative for black when his
Queen comes in his Knight comes in he
didn't do any of that I think he might
have missed queen as C I think he miss a
five I don't think that's super easy to
see after B D6 95 and this is the
problem with this position he has played
a move that is far inferior to the
actual move that he should have played
and he has given Wesley so respit
remember again we've said it we can say
it over and over a winning position
means nothing a better position means
nothing sure that's what you want but
sometimes you still have to find great
moves and like you said Jenny might have
missed Queen F5 and if he did did well
it doesn't matter if he did or not
because now 987 is on the board and the
enges are saying Wesley can get out of
here with his teeth still intact because
after takes takes Knight to E5 attacking
the bishop he's now prepared to meet to
move Bishop to H3 with King to E2 then
bring his Rook into the game G7 is
hanging and white is better in this
position unbelievable Wesley so with a
star over his head some Angel following
him he has got a huge break in this
position as VAR has misplayed horribly
in just one he played one beautiful move
and then one howler that just completely
threw away his Advantage well take us
through take us through um this uh yes
how hard is it to see a queen A5 a
couple moves ahead
what think it's really yeah to see
Bishop D6 Knight E5 Bishop E5 Pawn E5
and then to stop analyzing say that's
not that great for me I think that it's
not the easiest move in the world to
find I think Queen F5 here just
especially if you if you don't think
that you're forced to go for this
variation no I you know I have such
great respect for these players I really
do think that they look at these very
very forcing moves and that big time
move Queen D3 I that's what you think he
missed no on the contrary I think that
this is exactly uh the type of forcing
uh moves that the grand Masters
calculate that they see all of these
moves
uh with this uh whole variation that
Maurice was pointing out where okay
there's going to be an exchange
sacrifice to Force exchange
sacrifice um I'm really not too sure why
VAR didn't play uh Bishop D6 I mean it's
such a compelling and obvious move and
the the analysis the the the pathway is
actually very narrow like take take take
take uh it's all Forest yeah but um
somebody did ask actually what we meant
when we said when we call a line linear
and that's what we mean we mean that
there's not a lot of um different
different branches you're just looking
straightforward if you don't have Queen
fi you can't go for the line that's all
there is to it right so um you you move
on to something else and if you do play
it then it continues in a fashion where
it's rather forced I'm still trying to
understand exactly I I do believe the
move Knight f8 H7 gives up the Lion
Share of Black's Advantage I haven't
quite come to the understanding of why
it's that bad F Maurice back to you this
position with Bishop to D6 actually is
as usual very complex black is winning
but he still has to find some genius
variations to prove it even in this line
after Bishop D6 Bishop takes E5 D takes
E5 VAR might be forgiven for even if he
found Queen F5 maybe noticing this
engine move F3 that is losing for white
much worse for white but again not easy
to find the best move the point behind
F3 is if you play Bishop takes on F3
suddenly Queen B7 comes into position
and there just been one tempo lost to
allow white to be able to take on A8
there all the sudden Rook tactics if you
play a move like Rook to d8 suddenly
Pawn takes and there's a mate threat in
your position all of a sudden so that's
not easy to judge if you're going to
calculate especially remember his clock
is ticking down that's been a big Point
here so if F3 the engine
in their Infinite Wisdom have calculated
the move Knight 6 D7 leaving this bishop
hanging for the moment as the best move
now if you play Rook takes well if you
play Pawn takes it's very clear that
this F1 piece is hanging and your king
is getting mated in time but if you play
Rook takes now the move Rook takes F1
King takes Queen takes F3 check and then
you pick off this rook and again you're
winning so Knight not only Queen F5
sacking a piece but also finding Knight
six to D7 this move as well in this
moment not easy that is definitely not
easy to do especially with the clock
ticking down so he decided instead to
play very solidly and in a very
straightforward way and now we have this
new position on the board but one where
Wesley so can breathe a tremendous sigh
of relief the pawn captured after Bishop
takes and you can see the sudden change
in the position there is no Harmony in
Black's play Queen on C8 blocking
castles Knight on E7 not much of a
future Rook on H1 yeah but it'll be
ejected soon and it's not easy to get
away from this B7 point this bishop will
just develop there is hardly any
difficulty here for white he just has a
solid safe position that he can easily
defend it reminds me of that game
between Jennifer Yu and Anna zon no not
Anna Ana sheric and a sherov where
Jennifer was just dying was just getting
killed and her opponent missed one move
the game completely turned around and
then she lost the game because she
didn't defend properly but I will tell
you Wesley so is not losing this game
that way is going to take a miracle now
just to get back an advantage again
amazing the unbeaten streak seems like
it's back intact Wesley so what can we
say guys he's a miracle worker well
we're just about to see this move Bishop
D6 which was the entire intention of VAR
he didn't want to see this move Mo
Knight E5 which is why he played Knight
H7 and provoked uh the the G7 Pawn
coming to the F6 Square he's about to
play the move Bishop D6 but has he
correctly calculated the consequence of
this rather forcing and probably very
good uh exchange sacrifice for Wesley
after Rook takes G4 Queen takes G4 Queen
takes B7 the ailles heal in Black's
position this Pawn on B7 this queen
lands on B7 uh with the threat to the
Rook with the threat to the pawn and if
you drop all the way back well guess
what this is a a a really nice move in
the position for Wesley so which could
turn the position around into a very
favorable endgame suddenly for white
with this move Bishop A6 you don't want
to be in a all the pawns get snip snip
snap snap uh Rook takes D1 Queen takes
D1 Queen takes B7 Bishop takes B7 and
guess what all of these pawns on C6 and
D5 uh would be lost and Wesley would be
in the driver seat in this case that
would be Five Pawns to two pawns uh
veran kovan has played the move Bishop
D6 he has played it forcing this forcing
Wesley a good idea to make a very
powerful exchange sacrifice and I'm
really shocked by var's misjudgment
about this exchange Maurice yes this is
sacrifice is coming and black is not
having any Edge at all and white is
completely out of the woods the engine
is giving possibilities for him uh of of
maybe only limited to a Perpetual
repetition of position in some lines but
that's it Wesley is safe that's that's
it there's not any coming back there a
game that's perplexing to us another
game that perplexed me from the very
beginning this game between hiar Kamura
and Alexander shabalov who had the white
pieces and asked him he said you want my
Bishop go ahead play Knight take C4 I
don't get your positional point now we
like to move A4 a bit more than that a
bit more than A3 but still you want he's
going to drop his Bishop back and ask
you why you put your night here so raro
went ahead and took it and like I said
I've seen this kind of conception before
black just ignoring that side of the
board and playing this way and after
Rook ad D1 now usually the idea is go
for F5 somehow make that work and see if
you can get some play but iaro decided
to play even slower Rook C8 Bishop E1
nice move preparing to bring the bishop
on this side King h8 Bishop to G3 now F5
at some point you can have an F4 move to
meet it Queen to E8 Bishop H4 looking to
get it on E7 F6 stopping him Rook D3
Bishop to G8 he's like Crouching Tiger
right now rook fd1 and yes when you look
at this it's just like picture postcard
for white you play Knight C4 gave away
the squares open up the file and it
looks like at any moment this Pawn could
disappear the only problem is the
problem of the Superfluous Knight white
has an extra Knight in this in this
position he like to take this night off
the board let's could we please remove
both knights from the board could you do
me that favor so that now I can drop
this Knight back to E3 I don't like both
of them fighting for this Square this
night back and suddenly the D6 Pawn
comes Under Fire he can't make that
happen and that's what shabalov is going
to have to be looking at how to get his
Knight out of the way so that the big
guns can come through along the defile
but it's certainly Advantage white here
as black simply has not generated any
counterplay after making what looks like
a dubious trade on
C4 thank you Maurice and what about our
predictions Jennifer well great mind
think light yur because they gave us the
question let's pick the winner but it
was it was it was a few rounds in and
you know how chess players mathematical
they just picked the guy with the
highest rating and with the most number
of points that's why we all hasn't lost
a game in 61 tries
yeah and me on the women's side there
was hardly any dissension there either
you were saying great
minds well you know it's the person who
thinks outside of the box well done well
done I mean you get the two stars for
that incredibly no Arena crush on that
page not one out of five picked the
number two player in the tournament at
seven time Champion that I find stunning
yeah I thought you went for the highest
rated yeah because I did admire her
fighting spirit in the game against Nazi
pidi where you know she had that stamina
she's not one of the youngest players in
the tournament but she was out out there
to 129 moves late I said like to 1:29 in
the morning yeah
partying well the the only reason
actually I didn't choose Anna is I
really um didn't like the fact that he
was getting it she was getting into to
constant time trouble that I questioned
her form and self-confidence because
every game she' gotten in and that's
eventually going to catch up with her
although she's tight for first and doing
well but how is she doing in this game
it looks like she's actually in a bit of
trouble well trouble is the word for it
as the 13-year-old Karissa Yip has a
position she liked she told us her
favorite player mik tall and tall would
approve of this this position that she's
gotten against the four-time champion
Karissa y showing absolutely no fear
take a look at how this happened you
remember she sacrificed a Pawn on this
square that could simply not be captured
after C6 this is where we left this
position then she played the Bold move
F4 and after Bishop to D6 hey say A you
say B F5 why not get rid of that pawn
positional play with E5 trying to keep
the double pawns and block up this
diagonal for the bishop while that
doesn't bother White Castle's Queen side
Castle's King side into the thick of the
Gile fight incredibly after King B1
Queen H4 rook dg1 and this is not that
hard Knight F6 F3 rook f8 and you don't
have to be tall to play Queen to G2
threatening mate in one and after after
Bishop f8 now she's taken on E5 and
there's a big problem here Rook takes on
E5 will it has not been played as yet
but you can see the windup for the move
Bishop to D4 in fact it's not best to do
it just yet because of Rook to D5 but
she can play she finds the Nuance Bishop
F2 chasing this Queen off of this square
and now where do you go because Bishop
D4 is coming you play Queen H well Queen
F4 say Bishop to
G3 uh Queen runs all the way to the
other side now Bishop D4 comes and the
queen can't help out this pin on this
the problem is this F6 Square this is
just great for white that's all it is
and check out the clock times 57 minutes
for Carissa Yip only 17 minutes 40
minutes down is Anna zatonski and she
found Bishop to F2 kudos to the
youngster to understand that that Queen
has to be ejected first before she plays
Bishop to D4 this is a winning position
for white can black somehow entangle
disentangle herself and get out of this
one we've seen her work Miracle so far
guys this is going to be another one
that's a this might be too great yeah
this may be too great of a challenge
even for a lady of Anna zansky strength
the young Carissa yep I really in great
shape not our most exciting game but I
really like that green position earlier
against Nazi pidy but now I'm feeling
like Na's done a pretty good job of
Defending with her King reaching E7 um
and making that pawn on D6 look looks
like less of lemon exactly well let's
take a look at what happened we're going
to go back a few uh turns and we're
going to get to this position Queen E7
Queen D3 and this nice little move
Knight E5 that precipitated the trade of
Bishops and also came the trade of
queens now on this Hedgehog formation
it's pretty obvious that this Pawn on D6
is really
the the pawn the Lynch pin in Black's
position you take off that pawn Black's
structure is simply awful however Naji
has done a very nice job at simply
protecting her Pawn with the move King
E7 these Hedgehog positions I've always
liked for black especially when you get
these endings with the King on E7 I feel
that there's just absolutely no problems
here for uh for black and you can play
if if ever you're afraid you're not
really afraid in this position of Knight
B5 thanks to the answer Knight E4 but if
you ever are you could always play A6
you can bring your Rook to B8 and it's
really really hard for white to put any
more pressure on this Pawn on D6 and
even on a bad day 98 covers big weakness
nai's doing fine what did Arena do
wrong I have to go back and take a look
at that Maurice while you do that yes I
want to show you this position between
Anna and Emily win not a big not a big
game as far as the standard are
concerned but there sometimes you see a
nice move and you say enough respect
check out this move in this game White
had gotten zero in the opening zero A6
and C6 guarding the B5 Square so white
has no breaks over here with black to
play the engines just love getting the
two Bishops and rubbing your hands
together and saying we're going to work
on this nice and slow and you're not
have much to play for the spatial
advantage on this side means nothing
especially without this Bishop guarding
that B8 Square any threats over on B7 by
some Knight showing up this Knight might
Walt over D2 B3 A5 that's nothing you
got no breaks nothing that really scares
black but let's jump ahead because black
is so solid black just castled drop back
and now this bishop saved itself and
that was the first sign of maybe you
shouldn't have let that happen and after
F5 E3 Knight F6 Knight C4 suddenly you
started noticing some challenges here
this bishop is nice and healthy healthy
along that diagonal and now D6 is weak
some decided let me get out of that
direct attack Knight to E5 now is a
moment your Bishop is under attack where
do you put it well she said let me keep
it along this diagonal and play Bishop
to 87 that was a mistake she should have
put it on E8 but she didn't realize that
she wasn't stopping this move B5 anymore
and Anna plated beautiful move we like
moves like this one very instructive
shot the point being if you take with
the a on in this position then of course
The Rook goes down to A7 and there's
nobody home you can't guard this point
of course Rook to B8 runs into Knight C6
is the hit hitting this Pawn hitting
this Rook remember the bishop this way
the pin on this side that's busted and
the other move the other capture after
B5 is C takes B5 allowing that hit and
Black's Pawn structure has simply
crumbled at its foundations white is
well on her way to winning this game
Emily NN having a tough first time here
at the championships as she's seeing
just how difficult it is to play against
the elite women in American chess that's
right and the first championship is
always very hard we've got some news in
the other games let's take a look at
gakamsky who looks like not only is he
down pawns but he's also down all of the
light squares right well but being the
bear of bad news when it rains of Poes
got to just essay this move Rook C8 C4 a
move I really despise uh not only
because of the light scores that you
were mentioning Jen just this D5 Square
Bishop to D5 is a great strategic uh
strategic Plus for white but what about
the attack and the Tactical plus that
comes with the move Queen G6 not
threatening Queen H7 check and not only
I got a pawn in my PO pocket but I got
the attack and the initiative as well I
and also the work on C4 is just a
liability because if for instance if
there's no mate after Queen H7 King F7
we can always play Knight D5 you can't
touch the Knight because we have Bishop
takes D5 check and if you don't touch
the Knight we have checkmate with the
bishop or the queen on D6 oh no this is
really yeah this is very very bad news
again for God to Camp down and and
favano is going to win his first game of
the tournament the defending Champion
staking his claim and a big part of that
is can Wesley be stopped let's take a
look because instead of your move Queen
C8 it looks like Ruan aan did he come up
with something a little bit better he's
played Rook to C8 well let's see F first
of all we did we um VAR did force uh
Wesley into this whole exchange
sacrifice uh situation with Rook takes
G4 Queen takes G4 Queen takes B7 and a A
variation that I was really doubtful uh
is any good for black and he played the
move Rook C8 because Queen C8 had this
um Bishop A6 reputation now here I'm
just actually looking my chops for white
because uh there are some things uh not
to mention the fact that this Knight on
H7 is going to be under attack Maurice
let me go to you right
away well actually black is okay in that
position according to the engines but
you know it's the kind of okay where
like you're okay but you're up an
exchange that's never a good sign
you're you're thinking okay maybe I can
defend this position and make a draw but
another game where black is definitely
not okay by a long shot is the game with
Carissa Yip and Anna zatonski in this
position after Bishop F2 Anna realized
the problem that her Queen face if it
leaves Bishop D4 is going to win big
time material so she played the move
Queen G5 offering her opponent an entire
Pawn in this position Queen takes G5 is
what we expect to see and after Pawn
takes the most important move here is
the move
H4 that is the bomb that's the one
that's going to blow up Anna's position
because now she cannot capture on H4
because she switches directions with
Bishop to D4 and your Rook can't move
because the G file is once more open and
there's threats of f4 as well to pick
off this night you have to be very
careful here you have to at least get
back an exchange you're going to lose
this Pawn for sure and just be down and
exchange in this position so that's the
variation she should play takes takes H4
the engines give G4 as best I'd rather
even go The Exchange down than play this
move G4 straightening out the pawns look
at this wall of Pawns you're down a pawn
your opponent has all the squares the
two Bishops this is just a matter of
time before you lose and she's worse on
the clock 12 minutes left for the rest
of her moves Anna is doing it to herself
yet again and will the
13-year-old be able to take down a
four-time champion who's much higher
rated than she is as well this would be
a dramatic upset here in round six real
Cinderella story no question and there
the young Carissa yep looking at her
position and Anna in agony as she
realizes she's in deep trouble but guess
what Karissa said nope I'm not
interested in your Pawn I want to keep
the Queens on the board because I've got
a big attack I don't want to play a
technical ending even if I even if it's
good for me and this move Queen
F1
uh not a bad choice but boy I'm a pwn
Grabber I would have gone for that uh
line that Maurice was showing with H4 is
this move Queen F1 good enough for a win
for Carissa Maurice he gives her an edge
because Anna is going to have to
sacrifice and exchange in this position
but it wasn't the best way to go we know
as as uh you said yes it's not only the
fact that she would have won a pawn it's
the fact that she just gave no
counterplay whatsoever just gave no
chances Queens are off the board that
means you can't fight back at all
there's no tricks you're going to have
to hope and pray that you have some kind
of Fortress to deal with these Rooks
that are going to scream into the
position or the extra pawn and the two
Bishops that's just BSO that's that's
death here Queen H5 now when you play
Bishop to D4 Rook takes F5 giving back
the exchange Queen takes on F5 with
check King goes in the corner and you do
have the open foul but the mate's gone I
mean there's no more mating attack in
this position black can Crouch with a
move like Knight to E8 and the g file is
just protected you are up in exchange
however and it's going to take some time
for you to get the Rooks into the game
so maybe long term you are going to win
the game this looks like it's winning
for white to my eyes it looks like it's
winning for white and should win but the
the end game guys like karpov guys like
petan
guys like San you wouldn't even want to
see that position against them because
it's going to be lights out and this one
here there could be some play although
it should be lights out here as well but
clearly the youngster she likes the
Queens she likes to attack and she
didn't want to give her opponent any end
game where maybe she might squir with
some Fortress and uh the queen H5 has
been played and I'm expecting Bishop to
D4 to land on the board and she has
played it and without question and
instantly the veteran played Rook takes
at five going into that end game she's
going to breathe a sire of relief
playing this position versus playing the
end game where she knew she was lost
guarantee you say the unan the game
which one would you have been more
afraid of she's thinking the other
position this one here I've got a punch
his chance right and meanwhile um we've
got some moves in our critical game
between so and akopian um Wesley played
the move Queen A6 um after Rook C8 Queen
A6 and you can't uh black of course
cannot capture this Knight because the
protection of the Rook on C8 would be
lost hence the move Rook C8 C7 I had I
was about to say with the queen on B7
the Knight on H7 was under attack but
now with the Rook on C7 protecting uh
the Knight and look okay it's an
exchange there a bishop and a pawn well
not exactly but Knight a pawn for the
exchange but Black's King stuck here a
structural problems and some ideas of
Knight E5 Bishop A4 ideas I'm not quite
sure I feel that the
exchange well practically speaking I
think I pre prefer white but it's just a
smidge it's not the big Edge that
somehow I got myself all enthusiastic
about when I played the move Rook G4 a
more sober assessment is blacks in the
game yeah I mean black pieces are super
uncoordinated but um at the same time
you know once we when we try to get
really frisc for white sometimes there's
going to be some issues in the back rank
or even with C5 or something so Black's
not um completely shed out of
counterplay possibilities but man I
really want to improve my night on H on
I love to play like Knight G5 and that's
why this idea of Bishop E2 is really
effective like Knight G5 we can play
what you mentioned Knight E5 so in order
to improve the position of the Knight it
looks like we have to move our Queen
from G4 so I would be looking at some
Queen moves here for veran followed by
Night G5 very good Jennifer and Maurice
and you know it's sometimes there are
typical ideas that we fall into that
prevent us from making certain moves or
having certain judgments it's known that
when you sacrifice an exchange you
generally want to make sure you have a
pair of Rooks on the board to compete
with your opponent's Rooks so Wesley you
can understand does not want to see his
Rook disappear from the board in this
game his best move however entail that
he did so precisely now Bishop to D3 is
what the engines gave allowing Rook
takes and Knight takes on the Square and
saying that this position here is fine
for white and this bishop is stronger
than it was before but his chances of
winning have dissipated pretty
considerably in this position as well as
black will be able to play Rook C7 and
according to the injes this position was
pretty even the way VAR played it he
went from Big Edge clearly much better
to okay through the edge away the game
is even and so Wesley if he's of the
right mind should be thanking his lucky
stars that he's still here to be talking
about this possibility of maybe winning
maybe okay I guess I'll have to take a
repetition that's how he should be
thinking about the position right now he
might though feel the momentum having
swung so dramatically that he's like
well maybe I should start thinking about
winning this game and if he does that
and over presses he could end up in
trouble but
man uh I don't even want to say the
guy's ever in trouble because the way
he's gotten out of any issues and he has
played Bishop e too he has offered the
exchange of Rooks in that
position looks like basically the
position is just fine for both sides
very good a game we haven't looked much
at yet fer for shamian this one
intrigues me because now that it looks
like Anna's in trouble and Nazi and
Irena might be headed for Splitsville
that would mean that tat verse and Saina
if either of them were to come through
and win this game they would C pull up
to a Ty lead exactly well let's take a
look as you say it's not a game that we
really kept our and here are the
standings you see that t Bahamian and
sabinaa fer in joint four half a point
behind the leaders if none of the
leaders wins they jump right in there
yeah and again we haven't really been
taking a a careful eye on this game with
so much action in the Open Championship
uh but after the this move Bishop F1
King takes F1 A6 Queen D3 Bishop C3 this
is a big uh game for our
standings Knight
E8 H seems a little bit overly cautious
to my eyes Knight E8 Bishop D2 and Saina
is looking with her Bishop on B2 it
really wasn't that an active a piece
that pawn on D4 really blocking the view
of the bishop she's looking to improve
her bishop and I think she took the
right approach with this move Bishop D2
can see that this bishop if it gets out
here to the F4 Square play putting a lot
of pressure on the C7
Pawn uh Sabina will want the opportunity
to use the C file but she's got to
combine it with B4 B5 taking more space
on the queen side I prefer White's
position but this cramp Knight on E8
doesn't make a favorable impression I'm
not exactly sure what tatf had in mind
when she played the Knight on E I don't
see the roote does she want to put her
Knight on F5 you suggest because on the
F6 it wasn't too hot either because of
the point move that uh Robert hes
mentioned earlier um Pawn takes F3 that
unusual um capture KN on F6 really
doesn't have a a lot of natural anchored
squares right well in black shoes what I
would be thinking as Maurice expounds uh
often times I would be thinking as black
that I want to put my pawns on the Queen
site on light squares in other words I
want to play the moves B5 and C6 before
I would worry about the Knight I have to
do attack I I have to worry about some
tactics so I'd first play a move for
example like Queen E8 so that I I could
play the move B5 and shut down White's
initiative going on over there I like I
would have preferred that move if I had
been in tatf Ser Queen E8 with the idea
of B5 now remember if Pawn ever takes on
B6 um black would be absolutely
absolutely thrilled because then she
could switch to the plan of playing
Knight D6 and C4 and then we have an
absolutely stunning night so that's an
important point for the amateurs
watching you don't want to make
automatic captures um and then you
wonder why did I lose this game right
well because you made that night on8
from a zero to a hero exactly uh the
Wayward Knight would suddenly find a
beautiful anchor Square
Maurice an interesting moment in the
game between Carissa Yip and Anna
zatonski you kind of moved that
surprises me after this exchange
sacrifice King A1 you know as black that
again you sacrifice an exchange you
don't necessarily want to trade off your
remaining Rook because you're not going
to be able to compete with your
opponent's Rook that's on the board the
the secondary Rook that's going to be on
the board so in this position to me the
move Rook to E8 is a bit of a shock
because you take the open file but
White's going to challenge you on that
open file and you don't want to trade
off this Rook because White's going to
have another Rook waiting to C to crash
in and potentially cash into the
position Queen B1 she got it she got the
memo trade Queens you win easier that
way Anna said no no no no no none of
that nonsense I'm not trading Queens
with you now you had your chance
youngster I gave you a queen the first
time this time you're not getting it
back and now the move Rook to E1 is was
possible she could have played this
challenging this Rook again I'm saying
why is The Rook on the file this Rook
cannot really get down to these squares
even if she doubled she couldn't get
down there so why are you just donating
this exchange to her instead she played
Queen to C1 offering the trade again and
once more Anna said you're not getting
that guy and now a tactic you don't want
to overlook the move Queen takes on a
six falling for Rook to E1 check oops
that is not going to be pleasant uh to
tell your friends about how you lost
ridiculously at the US Women's
Championship that's not going to happen
Carissa sees that after Queen C1 to move
Queen F5 on the board and once again
then just saying just repeat the
position put the queen on B1 and when
she goes here play the rookie one and
challenge that Rook remember you don't
want to exchange off Rooks when you have
sacrificed and exchange that's the
general tendency this is showing itself
in the game with Wesley so in this
position here after Queen A6 Rook C7 the
timing was wrong for it he should have
played Bishop D3 earlier now with Bishop
E2 takes King takes the engine saying
after Queen F5 which is exactly what
akobian played Queen F5 the engine
saying better for black now before it
was little bit better for white triple
zeros now saying well looks like black
has weathered any white storm and is now
asked white so how you going to make
progress here what are your next few
moves to do anything in this position
while black of course is thinking about
improving this night pretty dramatically
and this King will probably find Solace
over here CU those open files don't mean
mean anything why because white doesn't
have any Rooks for black to worry about
so that's something that is going to
make a white wonder if he' played
perfectly I do want to point out this
game quickly though this one got a
kamsky rolling the Dyson Vegas well
we're in St Louis so I don't know if
that's going to work he's just played F3
after his own exchange sacrifice excuse
me back here he sacked in exchange takes
F3 thanks to his Rook guarding this Pawn
he's looking for some pressure the
engines are saying no we don't think so
no way this is going to work and
suggesting the move Rook to D3
controlling this rank once that happens
even if you get the pawn on G2 we got
Rooks we've got Rook The Rook rank we
got the file we got squares your attack
is going nowhere this position is
completely lost I wouldn't be surprised
if gotta resigned in the next few moves
thank you Maurice
and we have Grandmaster Kristen cherill
our analyst extraordinaire with some
thoughts of his
own thank you guys actually I'm going to
be talking also about the game Fabiano
caruana uh versus Gat kamsky we have
this position on the board guess what
Fabiano did during the free day he
prepared for a long time because this is
move number 14 he has 1 hour and 35
minutes on the clock 5 minutes more than
what he's started with what should black
do he should try to open up the center
for the bishop with a move Queen B7
instead of that Gata play the move F4 a
bad move you're closing up the bishop on
G7 you are taking away the square E3 for
my knight but I still have the route
Knight B4 to get to D5 white stops
Black's counterplay with F5 Queen H5 H6
a loss of tempo Knight B4 black is
already in big big trouble if he plays
Bishop B7 I'm going to blast open the
queen side with A4 and white is going to
have a great Advantage instead of that
black blunders with Bishop E6 and after
Knight takes A6 white is completely
winning Gata is still trying to Bluff
his way out of this game but against
number three in the world that's not
going to work Fabiano is going to get
his first win and he's going to try to
catch Wesley back to you guys thank you
very much Christian and uh I agree one
of the things you don't want in the
field is uh the number three player in
the world catching his wind and if Fabby
wins what appears to All Eyes to be a
winning position that's precisely what
he would do and bring him back into the
competition making him a player for the
first place that's right and Wesley so
positions still not um totally sure
about it it's quite a fascinating battle
and we're going to come right back to
that um after the break all
[Music]
righty
e
yeah
[Music]
he
n
[Music]
he
hello and welcome back to the 2017 US
championships and US Women's we've got a
lot of exciting games um going on right
now um I see you looking at the shabab
Nakamura battle Alexander shabab not
having a good tournament playing against
one of the leaders and the favorites but
Alex's position is really nice oh real
nice hi Caro Nakamura is back to the
wall here uh when we were on break
Maurice Ashley and I were were very
enthusiastic about a beautiful
positional Pawn sacrifice that shabalov
could have played he did not he the this
move uh C4 C5 in our view was really
begging to be played why well look at
White's Rooks doubled on the defile
after the move C5 you're opening up the
defile uh ready for a move like Knight
E7 but first preface it with B4 B5 and
we thought that black in this incredibly
cramped position what do you do you open
up the position for the better placed
white pieces and after this Pawn
sacrifice we we thought hikaru's days
might well be numbered instead of this
this very promising uh Pawn sacrifice
he's played the defensively minded
Bishop H4 F2 and I tell you Maurice I
have never seen shalov back down from a
challenge like ever is this a is this a
confidence issue that he didn't play
that move C4 C5 Maurice absolutely you
know shabalov the Giant Killer that he
is uh he's from the lvan school
sacrificing means nothing to him sacking
a pawn opening the lines in his Heyday
shabalov would have played that line
instantly no matter who was sitting
across from him clearly lacking some
confidence in shabalov right now and not
playing his best most enterprising chess
that said there's some developments
going on whole General developments I'd
like to bring your attention to if we
look at the big board right now I'm
looking at all these
games Kobe and Wesley saw
Nakamura shabalov which is still
interesting not the Fabiano game which
looks winning the ownership game every
single place I look on the board of all
these games in progress right now there
are three games only three that's right
the game of Ana sheric versus nwin the
game of Karissa Yip versus atoni and
most definitely the game between Fabiano
Carana and got a consy correct me if I'm
wrong it looks like the only three games
that are winning that are clear that the
result should be clear Anna sheric you
if you take a look at that you'll see
that she just won an exchange but you
have nine boards going on where the
positions are unclear or interesting or
equal is in some cases but still was
lots of fight and why am I bringing that
up because everyone is under 30 minutes
virtually in all these games well Wesley
has a little over 30 minutes move 26
move 26 move 26 26 is a big number
happening in a lot of the these boards
only actually only one two three I saw I
thought I saw a third board over the
move 30 this board this board looks like
it looks like that's it two games over
move 30 and all of them under 30 minutes
on the clock some of them in terrific
time pressure like this one with 925
left in the game between Ray Robson and
Sam Shanklin there's time pressure
everywhere you know what that means guys
we're gonna have to hurry to keep up
with these gu with these players because
time pressure is about to hit with with
a with a force in these games and when
time pressure hits the blunders start to
creep in so let's see who becomes a
victim of that only in this game does it
look completely decisive sheric
pocketing an exchange in this game
against the youngster and it looks like
Emily will lose this game Fabio in time
as well Fabiano also yes Fabiano is
definitely busted as well those are the
two games where it's clear n clearly
finished so we have three games where
their advantages Carissa y still
fighting to prove herself against Anna
zatonski but the other nine games I can
only say Edge for one side at best no
clear win in sight with time pressure
really beginning to hover over
everyone's heads thank you Maurice I'm
intrigued by this uh this recapture in
the Wesley game that I wasn't expecting
um after 24 Rook takes D1
we were looking at Bishop takes D1 right
that been the move on our radar yeah
yeah it just seems a bit more natural
keeping the king tucked in in C1 but I
think what Wesley was thinking um was
obviously concrete variations but also
from a human perspective the King on D1
has its assets as well in certain
tactical variations with uh the Knight
coming to B5 the bishop coming to B5 or
Knight takes D5 um there's certain
situations where we actually want that
King on D1 so that there's no um issues
with uh our King King on C1 and
capturing with a reach with a check and
not that that Bishop on D6 is hanging so
that's how some of these ideas come into
play exactly I'm wondering what uh
Wesley wants to do about his F2 Pawn I
mean the problem of course is that this
capture Queen F5 takes F2 is looming in
the position does he want to play the
move F2 F3 keeping that Knight and Bay
um wow I talk about all three results
being possible on nine boards that's
very unusual uh I must say yeah it's
true um so in this position what if we
play like Bishop D3 and then you let you
take on F2 and play Knight takes D5
you're forcing us to take on F2 Knight
takes
d uh well here just a second I do have
an opportunity to hit you with a check
um well let's just go with the line for
a second takes on D5 takes on D6 jet now
you've got ideas is like Bishop B5 check
as well by the way G6 Bishop G6 check
that could be a very embarrassing
annoying feature of the position but do
you always have a per if you want no
because I can I can come down with
Knight F1 as well as with
uh yes and you've also got this uh Queen
takes boy double-edged position I'm not
sure if I want to play Queen G1 check
forcing Knight
F1 uh this position is really wild wild
and it is and it is amazing how King
takes D1 adds that extra flavor into the
position it could be good it could be
bad but it makes it more Dynamic Maurice
Dynamic indeed in this position we see
here Dynamic for white if anything Queen
takes E1 we saw the Rooks come off
remember we said you want to keep Rooks
on we see the Rooks come off here and
now black will have to tread very very
carefully in this position because now
that you can't compete with this Rook if
it ever shows up in the position it's
going to gobble everything in sight so
what happened next she played the move
B6 to guard her pawn and after Rook to
G1 she made the slip of Knight to H5
this allowed Queen to E4 suddenly the
queen sitting on the E4 screen now she
really has to play very precisely the
engines giving the move Bishop to D6 is
the only way instead she played slowly
with F6 now trying to stem all the ties
on this side the problem with the move
that Rook again if the young Carissa Yip
finds to move Rook to
D1 Anna is going to be in a world of
hurt she's going to have to hurry giddy
up fast after this very nice move as
well Bishop to E3 making this Knight an
imprisoned character on the side of the
board and now the move King to E8 to
make sure the The Rook cannot penetrate
on any squares and now that you're
Frozen with your knight your Bishop
can't come to D6 your king is playing
total defensive Duty and you have no
counterplay on this side of the board
hey A4 here it comes B4 A5 your side is
about to collapse on this side of the
board and white is in complete control
of the position let's see if Carissa
finds this maneuver Rook to D1 and she
has to make nine moves does Anna
zatonski with less than three minutes on
the clock she's performed Miracles
before but she's asking a little too
much of Lady Luck in these games thank
you Maurice um speaking of raing Queens
for Superior position that's exactly the
opportunity that Fabiana Karana is
looking at right now in the position
that he has against gakamsky gakamsky
well what to say other than it's been a
blunder Fest for this five-time US
champion uh Fabiano there's this Pawn on
F3 whenever there's a Pawn on F3 you're
white with your king uh stuck on the
king side you do not want to see Queen
G2 Landing in the position so Fabiano
with his great material advantage can
simply play the very calm cool collected
Queen H4 a very powerful move he's got
other choices as well that you take the
Queens off the board G has absolutely
nothing to play for in the position
busto indeed Fabiano Carana GNA win his
first game of the tournament but we've
got a new move in so
aian instead of uh what we um were
looking
AT3 F4 was played at attacking the
Knight straight away trying to dislodge
that Knight we were looking at Bishop D3
and now after Knight H3 um their ideas
of Knight B5 and Bishop B5 remain right
well okay but this Knight I suppose is
looking at at um ideas of getting back
into play with Knight F2 check as well
as Knight G1 you wanted to try the
Knight E5 I can try I I'm looking at
three moves Bishop D3 Knight B5 and
Bishop B5 those are like my candidates
right now okay take away the bishop D3
because I got this Knight F2 check you
don't want to see that KN or you just
start with Queen takes that's just over
but but your moves Knight
B5 as
well okay well let's start with one
right Knight
B5 you got I'm assuming black is going
to have to take this there's a queen C2
check let's say white is not too worried
about the queen C to Landing in the
position I notic you didn't you didn't
try to interpolate Bishop takes B5
checks because there's just King E7
right and at the same time I'm also
thinking that uh this bishop on E2 black
has to be careful not to allow Bishop H5
check which would be a scorcher of a
check should that come to pass uh this
is a double-edged game I I hesitate to
say who stands better here um all three
results in my view are possible in this
well it's been it's been that way from
the start actually and um I like this
move Knight V5 for Wesley especially as
this Knight on H3 is still out of the
game I wanted to go back to the game of
aaro Nakamura because frankly even
though I don't like the way and uh
shabby played it uh with the move Bishop
F H4 back to F2 he still I mean Hikaru
has virtually no play and and with his
last move Rook on D2 to B2 it's very
clear that uh White's intentions are now
firmly aimed at that pawn sacrifice with
C5 following up with B5 Karu
Nakamura uh under intense pressure
against the player who's had the worst
luck in the tournament Alexander
shabalov just don't call him
shaby you call him shabby of course
you're not going to like shabby not too
do call him shaba but usually they don't
call him shabby not too shabby and
finally hikaru's uh said enough's enough
I'm tired of uh sitting on the back Rank
and he's just played the very active and
thematic move in these Kings Indian
defense structures of F6 F5 can he break
out of a shell Maurice fascinating
position developing there in shabar
ranks we call him after the musical
musical star Shabba who definitely
unafraid of anything that comes his way
well we'll see if he can show that
Fearless style that he's famous for in
that game the youngster Carissa Yip is
showing it in this game and this one
we're going to see if Anna zatonski can
keep up after F6 she played Bishop E3
with the same threat stopping the knife
for coming to F4 same idea of Rook to D1
King F7 quickly to handle this threat
and now instead of A4 she played B4 very
similar idea now you can't play C5
without pain and the same idea is to
play A4 G5 quickly on the board right
now for zonky but A4 is still the move
with the threat of A5 and just crashing
in on that Queen side black is in deep
trouble in this game lots of time we
talked about lots of time not remaining
for players look at this one that Maggie
Fang and jennif for youu the youngsters
are playing we haven't looked at this
game too much 26 moves in 15 minutes for
white 19 minutes for black 14 moves to
play this thing to the Finish Line 14
more moves to go they do get the 30
second increment but even so this is not
a great situation for either side but it
looks like black controls more space in
this game and one game we expect to
really end very quickly is this one
between anovich and Emily looks as
though white has not opened up the
kingside open files everywhere for white
a really big Edge and Emily down on the
clock with only 13 minutes to go sharp
stuff going on in all the boards we'll
see how the players acit themselves in
the next few minutes thank you Maurice
and again the big game going into this
round in the lady section was between
Arena and nji it's been a bit of a
snoozefest but things are beginning to
tighten up as uh black has just made
this G6 G7 G5 grab on the king side
which was met with F2 F4 by Arena Rook
G8 King F2 uh things are beginning to
percolate over here I like you going to
take black all right I like Black's
position um I have a preference for
black it it's not a big advantage and
and and I I think uh the computers will
probably prefer White's position uh but
uh my experience has told me uh tells me
I should say that uh in Practical terms
I prefer Black's position often times H5
uh and a kingside expansion works for
black Maurice I agree with you guys that
looks like something that black has done
to stem the tie there and trying to take
over the initiative well shabalov did
play C5 not at the same point that we
would have preferred it when he was
blasting through on the defile uh we'll
get to this position here he played this
move Bishop F2 he played a little soft
Bishop to H6 Rook to B2 F5 by Naka C5 by
shaba breakthrough here the engines
think that by allowing this to happen
you basically gave black the file for no
reason just two free moves moving your
Rook over white for Choice still but not
the same gigantic Edge and initiative as
before because you gave black a couple
of moves I want to show you another Pawn
thrust in this game between Onish truk
and zeruk Onish truk after this H3
played G4 daring his opponent to grab
this Pawn if he does of course he allows
the move Bishop to C4 straight threat on
this Pawn and after Rook to f8 gift me
the pawn white looking for an edge here
but not much going on it looks like that
position is essentially equalized the
game though that does not look equal at
all and let's take a look at it and it
has happened the youngster Carissa Yip
we're on the watch for a champion four
time former champ to go down she's
played B4 she's played A5 and look at
that clock Advantage it's moved 36 A5 on
the board she's got only 54 seconds left
counting down spent two minutes on the
last move that she knew was coming
there's no doubt that A5 was coming and
now she's taking on A5 and Carissa can't
even control herself she just wants to
snap back right now and keep the time
pressure on her opponent with no Rook on
the board to defend that side she's got
to pray that nothing crashes into her
position as Karissa is now in complete
control of that game that the engines
going crazy saying that white is
virtually up a piece not an exchange
anymore almost a piece in this position
and guess what's the easy move here Rook
B1 you got an open B file now we ain't
got to worry about it almost resign
after the move Rook to B1 she must have
played it already uh let's see if we can
get a shot of that uh she is actually
thinking about it right now but she
knows Rook B1 is the money move that
position is virtually
resigns I mean The Rook enters the game
that's it that's why I was so surprised
by her offering the trade of Rooks
earlier zatonski even if she was still
lost but just offering exchange of Rooks
that's when you have to be super careful
when you sacrifice an exchange to give
away that last Rook something just
deadens in your position and she did it
and then didn't find any counterplay
anywhere else and now an exchange a rook
is going to come back to haunt her
wow meanwhile we have a move in Wesley
Soul's battle against veran kobian and
it wasn't any of the moves that we were
looking at he didn't play Bishop B5 he
didn't play Knight B5 he played Bishop
to F3 but with some of the similar ideas
that now um taking on D5 is a threat but
uh can black just play uh King E7 now to
stop it then what do we do well one of
the well actually the key problem I
think for VAR ever since he put his
Knight on H7 quite earlier in the game
has been his desire to bring this Knight
back into civilization back into
activity and with this move F4 which was
very double-edged by Wesley I must say
I'm thinking that Wesley has a move like
Queen
F1 in mind very uh paradoxical retreat
but you're keeping that Knight under
lock and key by controlling the squares
G5
F4 um F2 and G1 and you're just think
you're saying hey you put your knight on
the edge of the board let me try to pick
it off with a move Bishop F3 to G2 I'm
looking at the times 20 minutes to 104
check at least and then um why you're
not rescuing you your night just because
you're giving me a check and the times
are two to one in Wesley's favor and VAR
might be looking at this move Queen F1
uh worriedly let me just put it in those
terms can we try to play Rook B7 get
some counter play attack a pawn yes all
of the yes indeed Rook B7 uh you can uh
bet Maurice let me turn it to you for a
moment and the idea is a B3 maybe bishop
B4 and things are I'm starting to
encroach maybe a little bit a little bit
you guys are worried but the engines are
not at all and black apparently is way
better in this position again because he
has that rook and right now he just
needs to trade off a pair of minor
pieces the move Bishop to B4 is what the
engines are saying is the number one
move in this position you mean instead
of King E7 or
after right now right now on the board
Bishop F3 black to Bishop F3 it's black
to move Bishop B and Bishop B4 and his
hand is on the bishop and he's played it
that is the engine's number one choice
and they are saying that this is the
real move here and the deal is that
white had better be ultra careful in
this position it's white who is under
pressure in this position they're giving
the move Queen back to F1 as a move King
f8 and now saying that White's going to
have to try the move E4 E4 in this
position which should not work out in
the long run but he needs to do
something remember this Rook can still
come in the game there's that g file
there's G1 there's active chances for
black because he owns a rook and you
don't and remember we talked about the
exchange sacrifice which Wesley did then
he traded off a pair of Rooks but he
didn't get the kind of activity that he
wanted so now he's fighting from his
back foot with those minor pieces
knowing full well if that Rook ever
shows up in the game from passive
country on C7 to more active
possibilities on G7 and G1 you will get
hurt and so watch out Wesley so now
having to defend this position and he
looks like he's in a bit of trouble
meantime W great move Bishop B4 so the
idea is that if Queen F1 um if the
bishop G2 can always just come to H7 to
stop everything yeah that's move King f8
I certainly underestimated the move king
f8 sorry Maurice you're just in midth
thought there oh no I was just showing
the other position of Nakamura which is
blown up after the pawn breaks and C5
and Nakamura has captured on the Square
C5 yeah sir that Rook maneuver you know
I didn't like losing the two temp no
question about it still but still yeah
you're saying but still but we we really
liked right here yeah you had shown this
possibility that we didn't get the
chance to look at this move Knight to E7
you did the spotted on the break you had
like this move not right now because you
wanted to play B4 first which is
understandable but this move is so
intriguing because the Rooks crash
they're connected the threat was always
there so of course you should have
played B5 but I wanted the fans to see
that great idea of yours but when the
way he played it he moved his Rook away
from the foul now when he plays this
move and allows this opening of this
file black getting play now DC fight by
Nakamura those ideas are gone there's no
more night move night threat whatever
and now you have to change the nature of
the position and play the move Knight to
C4 and it's still white for choice but
not the same way not with that big Edge
from before still Nakamura has to watch
out here but just because he he feels
liberated it's like my Bishop is awake
my Rook on the open file look at that
suddenly I have extra pieces now I just
have to fight him off but certainly he
didn't play with that requisite
aggression and typical aggression that
shabalov is used to so this game has
suddenly turned into a fight uh some a
couple of the grand Masters off camera
they said with nas shaba being in such
bad form and Naka being so much higher
rated than he is they think nak is still
going to win this game and it looks like
they're proving to be more right and
Anna zatonski uh Always In Time treasure
seems like a Perpetual case for Anna
under a minute as she's facing
severe problem and has she completed her
time control Jennifer yeah that's that's
the word that's the word yes she does
have 31 minutes now but her position is
the problem so I think that the the
young Yip is is going to take this one
and we're going to continue to see the
Women's Championship uh break open as
the scores are so tightly bunched
together and usually we don't see that
in the Women's Championship we see a
very uh Big Score winning the event but
I don't think that's going to be the
case this year
well this is where we stand yes three
players tied for the lead Nazi Anna and
Arina abrahami and Ander they're playing
today nipping behind that group that's
right um and meanwhile um in the
championship standings we had Wesley so
in the lead at the beginning of this
round but after this great move by V or
Bishop before is he going to lose end
his streak and break the entire
Championship wide open Indeed that's the
question Marie
and just just a little too fast too soon
Karissa Yip in Anna zon's time pressure
showed her inexperience and didn't spend
the remaining time on her clock which
was about 40 minutes she had making sure
that she had a crushing advantage and a
cold win on the board in this position
here Bishop D6 threatening the pawn on
H2 that looks like the only counterplay
for black if you give away this Pawn
suddenly you have no Pawn in front of
these pawns but your Pawn on A5 is much
further along and you've got a rook to
deal with anybody who decides to step in
your way oh and by the way the bishop
can help out too and we know Knights are
horrible at defending against side pawns
Rook B6 was crushing she played the move
H3 she could gift this Pawn away allow
Rook A6 and now she's threatening Rook
takes on C6 If you defend the Knight
well you drop a material cuz Czech is
skewering and back here that defense of
that pawn did not help and now she has a
huge Advantage with her a pawn going
down the board so she had that with a
just a completely winning position Rook
B6 take the pawn move your Rook down and
start pushing the pawn and it's all
finished and the engines are giving
almost a full Rook advantage in that
line so she didn't play the most
accurate moves instead she played
quickly she made sure there was no
counterplay on this side that's
understandable but not when you have 40
minutes in your clock to just work out
the win maybe she felt like she didn't
need to try to work out a win when she
has this position that she now gets to
play Bishop to B6 of course she still
has an advantage but it's hard to see
exactly how she's going to win this Pawn
after King to D7 in this position I
guess she has this move still but check
out that counterplay she was trying to
stop this is the counter play she didn't
want to see happen at all all of a
sudden her Rook is buried on this side
of the board and she hasn't won the game
yet and this Pawn is trying to make its
way down the board she's going to have
more work to do now that she didn't
think than she would have had if she had
thought about it before allowing this to
happen the defense of that a pawn well
the Pawn's not fully defended yet but
she still has quite a bit of work to do
and Anna is no longer in time pressure
uh Maurice just to continue that line
because Rook takes A6 still looks really
good for Carissa I mean I agree that uh
the P this counterplay on the king side
that could could it could and should
have been avoided but Rook takes A6 not
not Li not complaining not complaining
definitely a very strong move getting
this Pawn will have to calculate some of
the ramifications on this side uh after
takes according to the engine's best to
take with the pawn and bring the king
over here and try to slow this down but
Rook down definitely clamps everything
down on this side and after a move like
Knight to C5 suddenly you're calculating
some things though that you didn't want
to have to calculate a moment ago didn't
need to calculate so we just just want
to emphasize even if it's winning it's a
difference between winning easily easily
and cleanly versus having to start
working even harder she had that
opportunity with a lot of time on her
clock but it's so hard your opponent's
clock is ticking down you get caught in
the rhythm of the clock if her opponent
had 30 minutes on the clock she might
have said okay I see you're threatening
H2 what happens if I play Rook B6 and
take on A6 that looks very strong could
you stop me with that time ticking down
you know what let me just play quick H3
I know that's good and that's exactly
the Trap she fell into even though thank
goodness she has an extra exchange our
Rook is still a beast talking about
winning clean cleanly Fabiana Karana in
cruise cruise control in his game with
godsky everything coming up roses for
the reigning Champion defending Champion
Fabiana Karana here that Aon is just uh
cruising up the board as you say yeah
and uh big victory for our defending
Champion is impending Victory uh two
minutes for G as he's facing a terrible
material deficit and Fabiano really
needing a victory so badly after the
break where he only scored five draws
after some very enterprising and good
play I must say by the defending
Champion he wasn't rewarded however for
it and it it looks like uh Wesley so is
still puzzling out over this position
and you know they still got 12 moves to
make to the time control and it
tremendously Rich position with both
players with just about 10 minutes left
and we do have a move Bishop F3 by
Wesley well bishop3 Bishop B4 was
already played oh pardon me Bishop oh
sorry and now now now Wesley's
considering the ramifications of these
variations with Queen F1 um one thing I
I like about the position is that on
Rook H7 Maurice's E4 comes with a
stronger punch you can't just recapture
so that really breaks open position and
Knight takes D5 bam not the movie we're
looking at Knight takes D5
the idea that the bishop on is hanging
in the end after Pawn takes we at least
we can play Queen B5 check it has wesle
calculated this uh capture precisely
Knight takes D5 the players moved very
quickly there was uh um pardon me VAR
quickly captured the Knight Queen B5
check I believe we have on the board
well let's put the King on d8 so that we
don't lose the bishop with the check
Queen takes and there is this check down
stairs Queen C2 check uh it's over or a
knight F2 is also a possibility it's
over Queen C2 check is winning he did
not calculate this line Queen to C2
check he's lost according to the engines
this move was well do I have the right
position there's a night G1 check here
the king is no but your position is not
the position in the game I beg you
pardon what position so I've got this
position uh after the king is on F7
right now so Bishop F3 Bishop B4 yeah
yeah no I got it I'm sorry your but your
king was on d8 you move the king to d8
yeah you mve the king to d8 the position
apologies yeah yeah so the king is on F7
right and right now in this position
Queen C2 check Queen C2 check and you
only have two moves whichever one you do
will lose lose King E1 is possible Queen
C1 check King E2
yes and now the move this is a great
move but actually there are a lot of
them well let's I want to play Knight G1
the engine keeps asking for other moves
but Knight G1 let's just play Knight G1
as a move King F2 and now the move King
to
G6 whoa that's surprising quiet move
that's a surprising move King to G6 the
point being I I want to make a waist
move like A3 that now The Rook can come
to C2 and you have no checks or any
funny business happening you're just
dead and why couldn't we oh so if we had
played Rook C2 immediately you would
have checked me and I can't go to G6 let
me go back Rook C2 immediately now
allows this check Bishop takes D and
suddenly now you're looking for squares
you can't go to G6 Bishop E4 like you
said King E8 the queen no that's that's
the problem that's the problem you need
to move the king away from check now if
King here after Bishop takes on D5 no
Rook C2 because it's still that check
check now the move Queen to D1 the creep
move coming in and the attack is about
to come with a storm the threat being
Queen to E2 if you play Bishop to F3 of
course now he well I say of course I was
about to take the Knight the engine
announcing mate and six with this move
check the King goes up the board another
check and now you see the reason the
King has moved the rank is open for The
Rook will he see this with the minutes
ticking down this is hard
it doesn't matter once again Wesley so
in trouble he's busted but the moves are
so computer esque that it's not clear
that VAR is going to find those moves
yeah what about what if we just play
human attacking moves how do we do then
y let's take a look like you don't find
these like superb King G6 Queen D1
creepy moves what if we just play some
regular moves like yeah well exactly the
regular moves may be may be good
enough Queen C2 check King E1 the human
move would be Queen check King up Knight
check exact King up take the bishop so
that you're forced to recapture with the
Knight but you know what they say those
Knights can protect your king uh how
about King G3 do we have The Knockout
blow here and if Queen F so Queen F1 or
queen takes E3 that's the human move
right Queen takes E3 yeah check no this
looks terrible for black queen takes B7
Queen F2 check this looks like terrible
for for white yeah the VAR is is all
over this position that variation is
actually not optimal but plenty good
enough plenty good enough the exact
variation you just describe and he can
he can find that he can find that
sequence easy and that one is was well
within the bounds of this player and
that's what he should go for in this in
this position Wesley's just in trouble
but VAR six minutes and change ticking
down wow Christian Chilla asks on the St
Louis chesco Twitter it's a particularly
imprecise game by so he's under severe
pressure will VAR keep his cool and
convert meanwhile we have chess analyst
who just says VAR VAR V so you don't
have only Wesley so fans in the house
plenty of vuan aobi and um as cheers as
well yeah but thises Queen C2 check
Invasion uh uh into uh Wesley Camp
that's really really straightforward and
VAR is really licking his chops here as
he's just an calculating these
variations get rid of the bishop on F3
because that's the attacking piece
that's trying to hurt you on D5 what
does he what does he have on Bishop D1
though Bishop D1 let's go back to this
position check Bishop D1 will this deter
him from playing this line we can always
play Knight F2 if we want absolutely
trade off the bishop anyway I well okay
at least white has an option here but
that looks pretty straightforward looks
like the same variation yeah it does and
he has played it Queen C2 how are we
going to see the streak come to an end I
think we're going to see gam wow I mean
this is I mean is there some way uh for
veran in one of these variations I mean
for for for so to consolidate into like
a worst position Knight vers Rook rather
than just get made it cu the problem in
all these variations is The Rook crashes
in exactly um
um well I haven't found it I mean to
answer a minut he he did not play Queen
C2 what he did not play Queen C2 he
played Queen D3 and that's a draw what
he played Queen D3 Queen C2 was
completely winning but he played Queen
D3 we also him Rich for the queen then I
looked up and he's played Queen D3
allowing the move Bishop takes D5 check
all right first the engine said it was
completely drawn but now saying well it
looks more equal than anything else
still this looks like a dangerous attack
sorry I'm just flabbergasted King to G7
and now the move Queen to B3 and where
do you go this check King E1 Rook check
down here King takes Queen check King up
I mean boy this looks deadly a rook
check is Me by King
E4
wow wow and and what do you do I mean
queen G2 check would be the human move
but King back and now you're searching
around for moves but Queen D3 allowing
Bishop takes D5 check certainly an
unusual thing to do in time pressure but
VAR must have just thought that by
pennying this KN and threatening Knight
F2 check he's he's crushing that's
exactly right he that's he saw that the
King was running and he didn't try Queen
C2 check which was much better and
there's he's just given his opponent
respit we saw the street coming to an
end once we've now comes on it twice but
now still alive after this move Queen to
D3 is Wesley so can he actually survive
this game it looks like after Bishop D5
the game has completely switched around
amazing that VAR has allowed this when
he had the very straightforward check we
always say check the forcing moves check
the forcing moves remove the one the
most active piece in White's position
that three just take exactly
resignation has has occurred got kamsky
five-time Champion going down to
reigning Champion five on Carana in a
terrible game for G just it was a
blunder Fest for him today his best game
two days ago and his worst game today
which just goes to show you the rest day
it's supposed to make them play better
chess but in fact G playing a stunning
gem before the rest day and then falling
and belly flopping and after I think
it's just sometimes it's more random
than you think but true and by the way
after this move Queen D3 this blunder
there's no other way to mistake Bishop
takes D5 check I mean uh for Wesley he
had absolutely no choice but the problem
is is that Bishop takes D5 is really
good for Wesley and Maurice you have
another game that's caught your eye just
a quick update on this game Nakamura
versus shabal Shalo with the white
pieces we loved his position a moment
ago we hate it now after Knight takes on
C5 he played the move Knight to A5 think
he was attacking a rook and maybe going
down after this pawn and Naka said take
my Rook please go ahead I'll go after
your Rook as well and now if you play
Knight takes C6 Knight takes B2 and
black is back after Queen takes he can
play B takes C6 and black is now up upon
Pawn all those advantages have
completely disappeared Nakamura has out
played his opponent in the space of four
or five moves and shaba is just changing
all kinds of shades of red looking at
this position saying how is this
possible that I allow this to happen
after having such a golden position just
a few moments ago wow again I was
thinking that the Rook was coming to B2
so that he could play B5 but after this
well what dare I say it blunder time
time trouble makes fools of his all I'm
sure he simply overlooked the strength
of this move Knight C5 A4 turning the
tables not having to defend his Rook on
C6 but going after this Rook on B2
really a shocking move uh let me just go
back to that game of Wesley uh uh Wesley
so for a second because we have seen the
move Bishop takes D5 King G7 came very
very quickly by VAR and Wesley played
the move Queen B3 and it looks like he's
surviving in that line that um Maurice
had mentioned Knight F2 check King over
and I understand we have another result
Jennifer that's right nitki um has drawn
and we also nark vers Jeffrey Jang so
two of the youngest players in the
championship um the two youngest uh have
drawn their game and in the women's we
still have all of the games going by and
uh Maurice has an update for a game that
we haven't looked at as much in the
women's yeah we say it's a lot to play
but is not left to play in this game Don
a rook is well sorry down on a big
attack virtually a rook is a pro of her
could her Rook on h8 is about to drop or
the attack is just going to crash
through this Rook is hanging Queen takes
G7 is coming and she has to move Rook to
D2 on the board but here's the problem
after this move guarding the pawn on B2
F5 is going to come and there is no
counterplay anywhere anyway you can look
this is just busted just a few minutes
and this game will absolutely be over so
we will keep our eye on this uh count as
we're seeing a lot of blood being
spilled in this round already or
potentially so Karina mov she was
particularly upset at herself for
playing and seeing so little in the game
against ainaa fer but it looks like
she's bounced back now and she's going
to get a victory thank you Maurice just
looking at the final position between H
Fabby and
G Dreadful uh f g after blundering his
A6 Pawn which led to the loss of his B5
Pawn through the kitchen sink at Fab but
after simply Queen takes E3 there was no
attack for G and it was over uh Maurice
back to you on our game of the day
that's one king that wasn't any trouble
but this white king we thought might be
in trouble this probably I bet you VAR
saw this position he said I'm going to M
him I must be winning that's happen I'm
going to mate him no problem the problem
is your king is a bit exposed King F3
and how do you continue the attack Rook
to G1 also threatens mate on G2 nobody
can guard the square but the king's
going to dance like Michael Jackson I
mean hey I'm out of the middle of the
board uh and look at that the king
cannot be attacked consistently yes but
look at this the king might even March
over to the other side now of the board
and after this check the king will go up
the board and suddenly white is better
what white is better that's what the
engines say anyway in this position as
the king is now going to go down here a
crazy position Wesley so is surviving
we'll keep our eye on it eye on it as
the next minutes they reaching time
control only four moves to make time
control wow that move King E4 could have
escaped Fan's eye um with just you know
5 minutes on the clock remember that was
what Irena said she missed against Emily
NN in an earlier game that could have
resulted in a draw she ended up winning
anyway but she's like King E4 um came
from nowhere to her right yeah well this
idea I mean in grandmas chess you think
whenever you blast uh the opposing King
into the center of the board you quickly
discount it and think to yourself oh I'm
winning in this case VAR when he played
into this line with Rook G1 he probably
expected that he was simply mating
White's King but at that very unusual
move King E4 don't forget that it's an
exchange but guess what Wesley's got
three count them three pawns for the
exchange and you don't want to play too
frisky in this position Maurice and a
wild position happening in the game
between the youngsters Maggie Fang and
Jennifer U Jennifer marcher King
remember the King was over here Castle
she saw these pawns she marched the king
all the way to the other side of the
board and in this position now she play
the move Knight to B8 both of them in
time pressure particularly Maggie with
the white piece she said enough I'm just
going to sack a knight she's just played
night takes on F7 that's a piece she
sacrificed but she got to play this move
Bishop to E6 her point being that she's
after this B Pawn and if she can move it
then these pawns will start to March and
then she's saying why'd you march a king
all the way over there now I'm going to
get some counterplay to be able to
attack it and all of these pieces will
be lined up with these pawns so Bishop
to E6 a great shot this peace sacrifice
on of seven by Maggie who knows what's
going to happen in this game as it just
completely exploded don't forget the F
Pawn is passed as well so a super sharp
position from these two youngsters as
they duke it out as the time ticks down
speaking of time ticking down baruan
niobian now with less than uh two
minutes on the clock or just about two
minutes left on the clock as he tries to
figure out what to do in this position
where's my Checkmate and certainly King
E4 is occurring to him now he didn't see
it when he played that move otherwise he
would have hung down and look more
closely at Queen C2 you kind of have to
understand he thought that wesle so was
busted so when he sees this line with
Queen D3 he's thinking like okay it's
normal that so is losing right and you
know it's funny because one variation
involves getting rid of the night the
other involves getting rid of the bishop
and it looks like veran just he just
chose wrong yes and no question about it
uh well I mean what can I say
Wesley got lucky it's concrete
variations but but um there is some
logic to um to the idea that the uh the
bishop in this position is better
because it can be both an attacker and a
Defender and we have another result in
Katarina mova has won against aova
verude um aova was starting off really
well but unfortunately um lost a couple
games in a row meanwhile um Katarina um
hopping back closer to an even scorer
also not having her best tournament so
far look at VAR not sure what to do in
this position yeah let's this time let's
take a look at his clock he's got less
than a minute now um which is the only
four moves to make but still yeah he's
got to make them well exactly and you
know we're talking about this move Rook
G1 threatening Queen G2 mate the other
move uh attractive move that you want to
make is Rook C2 with a similar idea in
this case you know you're kind of
securing a Perpetual check until you
look at this move King G4 could white
really essay such a dangerous looking
move and he's played he played Rook E1
just trying to tie down he Rook E1 and
used a lot of time for that as well Rook
E1 oh my goodness Fano kanano who also
has a very big interest in this game he
just won he's now got his first win of
the tournament and he's with
Maurice the US champion reigning champ a
pretty much an easy win today you must
have been shocked when he Blended on A6
yeah I I was surprised by H6 first of
all because it I guess the idea is to
trade Queens with Queen G5 but then he
just has a bad ending um I mean I think
there's some Theory where he castles and
plays Bishop B7 and and it's really it's
a question if I get my knight on D5 in
time and stop his pawns after he takes
it um or not and um after H6 Knight B4
is just bad and Bishop B6 loses a
pawn when you when you you saw that you
could take a pawn were you thinking wait
wait a minute is this I
I assumed he he I mean I had seen it
before that I could do this and I
assumed he just bler KN A6 the funny
thing is that normally Tempe will count
for a lot in this position more than a
pawn but here the night on before I mean
the a pawn is the one of the most
important pawns for black because it
kicks the knight from B4 with A5 and
with my knight on B4 not I mean
immovable it just he can't do anything
and he has to start sacking pawns left
and right right so you had just this
winning position we're GNA we're in time
pressure everywhere so we have to keep
this short what does this win obviously
obvious question what does the win mean
for you you finally got a win in this
Championship that you know obviously
you're trying to defend yeah it's it's
Pleasant to win especially in such an
easy game um I can I mean it was a
pretty quick game so I I think I'm still
in the tournament it was important for
me to at least start winning one game so
we'll see if I can make it more than one
final question have you looked at the
game with Wesley so at all today it's
been just a roller coaster ride for us
uh Christian showed me a few important
moments I I mean I I thought it was very
unclear and then it looked very dubious
for him and apparently he was just
losing and I guess he missed Rook G1
King E4 which is um or or mix something
up um I wouldn't be surprised if he wins
this position although it's very
difficult for to win but but if I mean
if he can actually get his King to a
safe place uh get out of checks then he
might start to get better although the
most likely result is still a draw all
right well we'll take that and we'll let
you go as these games are heating up the
US champion finally got his first win
and the rest of the field did not want
to see that happen Fabiana Carana Back
In Contention thank you mauce thank you
Fabian congratulations for getting
yourself back in the tournament very
very important win for the tournament
standings and very fun for us to watch
now isn't it can't VAR bail out with a
rep petual in these lines I'm looking
for it how does he do that though Jen he
just played this move Rook E1 where's
the the
pret oh I was just thinking that if you
play King E4 with my Rook on E1 I can
sometimes I might be able to play like
F5 Jack so that could be a
problem
F that's a fourth Pawn isn't it can I
just take it I mean your king is going
to come up underneath
some I think how I could take the the
pawn on oh I could take on E3 first and
then no I can't because you have King F3
all right right yeah well you don't win
my k you don't win my queen after
trading trading F5 check I can simply
Park my king back that's what I'm saying
so I'd have to start with F5 that
doesn't look that promising indeed
considering a tough choice sorry but
we've got a a guest in our studio Karina
and nanova getting back into the swing
of things with a victory all right
Karina mova with a win badly needed
Karina I remember yesterday after we
were going to to play a Simo against
some young men and you were were
disgusted I could see it in the way you
respond you were barely answering my
questions as I I chatted uh how did you
shake off that feeling from yesterday to
play this good game today uh it was very
hard but yesterday was was a huge help
because this uh school school visit that
we had I think it was very nice very
energetic and then I had a lot of
support from my family from my friends
and they were like you have to play you
have to play better you have to get back
to the tournament everybody blunders you
just have to get back it seems that you
did were you you use this opening
variation that uh naris used did you
notice it and decide let me try it
against her actually it was my coach
suggestion so I was just looking at the
line then I actually uh I went back to
to what Danielle said what Ray was
analyzing and I thought okay they are
saying it's interesting line so why not
to try it were you surprised you got
this great position it looked like you
were crawling all over her fairly
quickly yes that's what I thought but
then she played this Knight A5 Knight B6
and I was like wait what's happening
here and I was a little worried what to
do there but then I just simplified and
it was good all right well
congratulations on the Victory and we
had a lot of fun yesterday I was telling
people that you were setting me up
you're G me the easy checkmates in most
of those positions so looks like it was
it was indeed a very nice day to do some
community service and I certainly
enjoyed being with you congratulations
and good luck tomorrow thank you very
much thank you uh katcha
um 27 seconds what move did W played a
move that we weren't looking at he
played the move Bishop to C4 after Rook
to E1 Bishop to C4 stopping any ideas of
Queen E2 check but has this allowed
verian a chance to close the net with F6
F5 we don't know they still Queen B7
checked he played Queen H2 Queen
H2 very very hard to guess the moves of
this players in this incredibly tense
situation is there any threat here is he
trying to play Queen H1 now and then
Queen H1 check definitely is on the
agenda now White's Queen on B3 really
needs to do something in these types of
positions um and that is a that would
actually be a perpet if we wanted it I
mean if there's no M Queen H1 and queen
G1 well so I'm thinking Queen check just
let's take a look at the human moves for
a moment uh followed by Queen F7 trying
to drum up my own counterplay now I
agree Jen that there's a pet Perpetual
that check that is to say for VAR in
disposition but is there anything more
than that so starting yeah we're
starting from this position Queen H
Queen B7 check King H6 Queen F7 does VAR
have any shot that I missed oh hold on
Queen H the E3 ising Queen H1 no Queen
H3 Che Queen H3 check sorry I I'm blind
I apologize so instead but can't you
play Queen E7 instead
maybe um okay so this is current
position I need a queen B7 first and
then and then after King H6 hit the hit
the pawn on um E7 instead of F7 so Queen
E7 to
defend hanging on to that pawn very good
point and Maurice you've got enough are
we are we hanging on here what's going
on someone who's not hanging on is the
game with Sabina foer and tatv
abrahamyan tatv is going down she's
about to get mated and it's Unstoppable
according to the engines in this
position she took on B2 Queen takes B2
and then she had the gumption to play
the move G5 going in the wrong direction
to start and then taking this Pawn on A4
allowing Queen B7 and now she got even
greedier and took on D4 sacrificing this
Rook she thought except uhuh I don't
want the Rook let's go for your king and
now Rook to B7 crashing into the
position she played the move F5
F5 of all things in this position
burying her King in this situation and
Bishop to E3 and now what to do with the
queen as she's about to get mated she
resigned in this game as this king is
going to come under H4 attacks and
checks this King will go to G2 tatev
abrahamyan one of the favorites to win
this event she was right behind the
leaders that was a devastating loss for
her pushing her further away from her
chances and her hope of winning her
first US Women's Championship and now is
doing great she's going to be tied for
the lead she's got four points four wins
two losses what a toxy two losses and
she's already played Arena she's already
played TV puts her in Pole Position
sabinaa big big victory sorry we left
Wesley so
and when VAR had just little time and
Wesley had hasn't moved after this move
Queen H2 is on the board H2 Queen H on
the board and now we're waiting for
Wesley to make a move he's got three
minutes and veran has less than one
we've got three moves till time control
Maurice and we have a big result which
we expected but she has closed the deal
Carissa Yip has won her game as well so
we see another favorite going down an as
Zony losing against the youngster this
Rook turned out to be the difference we
talked about that extra exchange it was
too much and Carissa Yip the Giant
Killer now Anna zatonski has to be
disgusted as she is Frozen in place with
a zero meantime though the two other
leaders are battling it out in a
position where black nazzi piny might
have a small Edge against Arena crush
and meanwhile there's another time
pressure situation you couldn't have
guessed it Ray Robson um we've got just
a couple moves left oops wrong game uh
where are you Ray right next to there
are you he's playing against Sam
Shanklin there's just a couple moves
left to make before they make time
control um and he's got a 30 second six
seconds in the clock looks like the same
exact clock times as soan basically in
this game with the two moves to make and
white is up a pawn what do you what do
you take what do you make of White's
chances here well I really like this
night on E5 and I really like this
bishop on D3 in other words I think that
White's very very active pieces are
giving him control as well as that extra
pass Pawn I like Sam's chances but
Maurice another game of not much import
but certainly Dynamic and interesting
the move Knight B4 by Jennifer U going
or at least putting some pressure on
this pawn and an interesting and good
decision Bishop takes Knight that
important move removing all of the
protectors on light squares except this
anemic piece this bishop very strong and
after Queen takes on B4 Rook to H6 and
this is what I mean by the white squares
look how look how powerful they are
there's no way to break the bind on the
light squares and this this light Square
Pawn is looking like it's about to drop
as well since you can't play Rook G8
because of this bishop guarding the G8
Square now Rook G6 is coming she's going
to have two connected pawns Maggie Fang
and it looks like it's difficult for
black black is up a piece though so
she's going to have to figure out a way
to activate some of those forces but
it's not easy to see how and they are
both well actually Jennifer U it's going
to be her 40th move as Maggie has made
time control and Jennifer is looking for
a move right now approaching the 40th
move of as well are Wesley so and veru
aov in and they have entered that
variation that we were discussing yes
Queen B7 check followed by Queen E7 the
move that you caught I misplayed it with
Queen F7 but Queen E7 was played and 20
seconds if my clock is that's right
we've got we got 16 seconds that's four
seconds left before he's made his move
and uh let's Queen H1 sha King obviously
an immediate King F2 by Wesley right and
he got uh what 25 seconds left on his
clock Queen H4 he needs to make his last
move Queen H4 and an update in the rson
game Mar Sam Shanklin going uh all the
way in and about to win the game Ray
Robson is about to lose this game as the
Knight is on G6 we all know this kind of
simple formation that is a winning
formation for white it looks like he
can't make any moves Queen h8 is coming
if you try to stop this piece he has
Knight E5 and if you go back to F6 in
this position Bishop G6 is what the
engines want to do and just create a
whole mating net around here it looks
like white once he makes time control is
going to be on cruise control to win
this game and meanwhile so aobi in
they've made time control and it looks
like it might just be steered towards
Perpetual has Wesley escaped again yes
he has yes he has what can I tell what
can I say uh going to another crucial
game Alexander shabalov who has not
played successfully in this year's us
Championship is up against Hikaru
Nakamura Hikaru is weathering an awful
storm in this game and the players have
made the time control as well hi Caro's
two Bishops extra Pawn but still a lot
of work here for hikaro uh to score a
much much needed uh tournament Victory
against the tail Ander Alexander shabala
but here right now we have a woman who
is leading the women's Chess
Championship right now as Nazi bidi and
Arena cross are still battling it out
she's ahead of both of them right now
Sabina fer is with Maurice
Ashley Sabina the most contentious of
all the players so far uh on the ladies
side in the championship having won four
games lost two no draws have you decided
that today or this tournament is
Gladiator tournament because it seems
like every game is going one way or the
other well I'm just uh you know trying
to play for the win if I have the chance
obviously you know you have to play the
position so
um I think in the two games that I lost
I was kind of you know going from a
winning position to a loss position and
um yeah so I don't know you beat one of
the favorites if people were to chalk a
name as one of the people who could win
this tournament tat abrahamyan you've
played her certainly before you've been
Olympic teammates as well have you so
what was it like to play against her at
such a tough game it was tough you know
I I lost a lot of games against her I
think six so far but I always got black
so the past uh I think the past 8 years
or seven years I kept getting black so
it was good to have white and you know I
just wanted to play chess and I think I
had okay it was a balanced position and
at some point she made a mistake she
waken her king and you know big mistake
she got greedy in the game and you just
suddenly crawled all over her King
you're leading the tournament that might
seem like a surprise to you at the
moment what are your feelings right now
as you sit at top the tournament
tournament and it's unlikely that anyone
will win to pass you I'm really not
thinking about that you know there are
five more rounds so you have to I have
to stay focused and and play well the
rest of the games all right well we look
forward to seeing you play well good
luck in uh the rest of the tournament
thank you and rest up Sabina because
having all decisive games that's
exhausting it is but here you see the uh
women standings with sabina's result uh
launching her to four points at plus two
Jenifer and an's lost so she's going to
be behind Sabina meanwhile naidi and
Arena Crush can catch up with the draw
or Sur pass her if that game ends up
being decisive exactly but uh
Tat's uh dreams are fading a little bit
here with today's loss and meanwhile um
verion of cobian's dreams also fading
they made time control but is he just
going to acquest to Perpetual here he's
got time now it looks like he's
grimacing a little bit here he feels
like maybe he blew it and he's going to
find out later that um it's true indeed
that's absolutely right uh he he really
had a big arguably decisive advantage in
a very Topsy Turvy game indeed yeah
since um and meanwhile uh as you
mentioned Sam Shanklin it looks like all
all Shanklin in his game vers Ray Robson
and Ray was the one who had a plus score
so this would this Victory would bring
them both to even and further Clump up
the standings in the open side but we've
got a heroine of the round uh Carissa
Yip she just defeated Anna zatonski so
um young Talent Reigns she's with
Maurice yes the youngster 13y old 13
years old the youngest player in the
competition on both sides taking down
Anna zatonski who we know knows how to
win these championships having won in
four times Carissa congratulations first
of all what does it feel like beating
Anna
zatonski happy I don't know you don't
know I'm okay with it wow that is not an
you get some emotional responses out of
you one of these points you've got to
feel good that you beat a four-time
champion in a game that looks like you
were never ever in trouble it looked
like it was just a smooth victory yeah I
guess um I think she just made a mistake
and then I I got the exchange and then
kind of all over when you played F4 F5
did you feel like you were in just a
tremendous position at that point or
when was it that you felt like you had a
basically a one
game um after she played R CIA and then
I saw this queen G2 and then D takes E5
I a and then uh yeah I'm pretty sure it
was then that I knew I was winning after
F4 F5 I wasn't really sure if I had a
good position or not
but once you got Queen G2 you got a big
attack uh then you had the chance to
trade Queens there was a point where you
could have traded Queens immediately in
play H4 we have the diagram here in
front of us but you chose instead to
keep the Queens on why did you do that
when you later in just a couple of moves
you're going to try to trade Queens
anyway well I mean I got the exchange in
the game but
uh here I think I just get a pawn I no
I'm
greedy well that look like greedy too
you could have had a winning end game uh
in that
position what are your thoughts having
won this game any optimism moving
forward uh yeah I didn't really expect
this win I guess so it's nice to bring
my score back to even I
suppose yeah that's it what what's the
difference between this championship and
the last one you do you feel any
differently now that it's your second
time around no just mostly less nervous
I guess uh besides that it's pretty much
the same well less nervous is important
because you definitely showed today and
good luck in the rest of your games
thank you guys thank you Karissa Carissa
a quick question for you because I
really like the way you played it once
you did trade Queens you played a series
of really accurate moves I was really
very impressed as were we all Bishop E3
King F7 Rook D1 controlling the open
file B4 very good very good and you got
to this position where you'd really you
the table was set you had done
everything right and then you went with
the move H3 why did you re reject Rook
B6 which is what you had been playing
for for the last half dozen moves or so
because H3 just made it a little bit
tougher for you oh yeah because I saw uh
Bishop C7 but then I missed she had a
knight E6 I guess it was just l later
that this was the move that slipped your
M yeah because I didn't really want to
give her any chances on King side yeah
understood there was the move you missed
Knight E6 but I get it H2 H3 is a safety
move but Rook B6 that was a real good
one too well done
congratulations thanks Jennifer what a
round it's been that's right we still
got plenty of excitement I feel
breathless Victory guys Sam
Shanklin I'm hearing has won his game
wow very decisive day so far and note
that in the women's championship before
the rest day we had an all blood round
right right six decisive results and
guess what so far in the win the
championship in this round we've got
another three so nine decisive games in
a row and it could be all decisive again
today AER because um Nazi pidi you liked
her position a little bit but now she's
just up a pawn exactly and that that
could be and the other two players also
seem to be Anna sharich we saw a long
time ago um is uh seems to be crushing
against Emily NN and U Maggie Fang and
Jennifer
Yu um also seems to be going in Whit's
Direction so uh big another big day with
lots of decisive results oh actually
yeah that game between Fang and you is
just really rich I mean right a
sacrifice there that that may be the the
juiciest game we have left yeah well one
of the a beautiful Finishing Touch I
must say by Sam shankland a very famous
uh Queen Sacrifice from the matches of
spasy and petosan as well as alak alakin
and Max irva this move Queen h8 check
why do we want to trade Queens well just
have a a look see at that pawn on A6 and
how important that was uh with with that
move a queen h8 8 check Sam Shan
Franklin uh finishing the game in great
style that's right knowing his Classics
knows his Classics and he's with Maurice
right now to talk about um a big victory
which uh put both Ray and Sam on even
scores Sam Shanklin needing a victory
badly today and doing it against his
Olympic teammate Ray Robson Sam you were
not happy with the tournament was going
so far but this win is uh just what the
docs ordered yeah it was just what I
needed I mean the tournament wasn't a
disaster by any I mean to be on minus
one after five games with two with world
number two and three included it's not
like a disaster but it wasn't feeling
good and so you know a nice win was it
it really helped turn things around and
back on 50% and I you know think I'm
doing just fine you didn't seem to have
a dominant position coming out of the
opening it seemed like it was just a
chess position It's Tricky I mean onest
Tru played a very similar line against
me but I had this idea to avoid B3 so do
some funny move orders so that uh I
don't have to play B3 Bishop B2 and
instead I get my Bishop out and I just
had some slightly better position I
think by the time I get Knight E5 in I
wouldn't be surprised if it's
technically lost just because black can
barely move I just can't I
mean he maybe could have tried Knight E4
instead of H6 I don't I wasn't sure
exactly what was going on I was
calculating Knight E5 Queen C8 and I
couldn not play Rook D7 because wait
show us the line flee so get to the
position yeah so here I mean knight4 I
think was the critical move I thought
knight5 was okay now so he must play
Queen C8 and now I cannot play Rook D7
because F6 and if Queen H3 Knight G5 and
he holds everything together see that
Rook D7 F6 and I mean I feel like I
should have a knockout on the seventh
rank here but I just don't like if Queen
H3 Knight G5 or queen F4 also Knight G5
and I'm actually just losing material
now but um I uh but instead of Rook D7 I
can play something simple like Rook D3
or Rook D1 and after F6 I think Knight
D7 is working and if it is I just just
win but if it if it doesn't have some
Pro then Black's probably okay if I have
to go back to F3 but here uh I was
trying to calculate exactly what was
going on but it wasn't easy I think
Queen C7 is critical because if Queen C6
I have F3 and there's no Rook d8 on
account of Knight F6 so black must play
Queen C7 and now I wants to play F3 rook
d8 and I thought I could take on C5 here
um and probably I'm doing well uh I mean
after Knight takes C5 Rook takes d8 and
queen takes C5 my king is a little open
but I don't think it should be
especially problematic so but if black
cannot stop Knight E5 I mean it's it's
hard to call it lost but I mean it just
feels like he can never do anything the
Knight on F6 is stuck forever because
Rook D7 he has trouble playing Rook d8
because the C5 Pawn is hanging and
everything is loosened I think that at
this point it was going pretty smoothly
good win for you you seem like you're in
good spirits now going into the next
five years oh yeah I mean I haven't won
any games yet it's like a a miracle but
you know it happened so uh and
especially Ry who's been well the last
few games have been draws but a while
ago when we were kids he he tooled me a
lot and I I got some revenge in a rapid
game in playoff in the US Junior once
but I never actually beat him in
classical so this it feels kind of good
and especially considering uh even
though our ratings are about the same I
may be a little bit higher uh his track
record in the US Championship is just so
much better than mine that it it it
feels like a big win to me all right
well we hope you can take this big win
and do bigger things in the rest of the
round okay have black with aaro tomorrow
this will be a challenge that indeed
will be well good luck and uh best to
play in the rest of the games thank you
thank you and Sam just quick question
for you there
uh the classic uh Queen h8 check
combination you know uh tell us what
your emot tell us your emotions when you
were just you know like at I saw it I
saw it a couple moves before I mean I
saw it when I played uh Queen H3 because
Wow way back well after Queen H3 I mean
it's very forcing I mean Bishop C8 is
too ugly to consider and here I saw
Queen H I saw Bishop D3 and I saw this
idea to play Queen h8 and he has trouble
stopping it uh because he can't move the
queen anywhere if Queen E7 there's
Knight G6 and it has no other Square so
he actually can't stop Queen h8 this
much I saw but after Bishop B7 I wasn't
totally convinced by it with my two
minutes on the clock so I thought I
might as well repeat move once and then
uh figure out around time control
because here if Queen h8 first of all
the knight's much better on F6 because I
don't get Bishop E4 so here I didn't
think it was as clear I don't know if it
wins or not but uh I played Knight G6
which forces Knight H7 and Knight E5 and
I thought he was just going to play
Knight F6 back and then I would
calculate Queen h8 properly but after
Knight f8 there's really no discussion
because if the my Bishop has the E4
square there's there's just no way he's
going to hold this together wonderful
thank you so much and congratulations a
win in this us Championship is so strong
it always feels very good
meanwhile we've had a bunch more results
coming in Yas it looks like uh shabal
Nakamura that game was a draw owners Jer
book a draw yeah the shabalov one shocks
you right not the owners one so let's
see how that came to pass well let's
just see we left it right around these
Parks maybe even earlier than this and
uh Maurice was explaining that well an
extra Pawn for Hikaru uh uh
Alex Ander was going to have trouble
holding this but seems after this trade
of Rooks things got easier for white and
a draw was agreed at move 42 so hikaro I
thought that this was a big big game for
him that he needed to win this game to
get back in that hunt for the first
place hand shake in Wesley so and vuan
aoan that game treated us to so many
cool variations ended in a draw and
veran wow he was so close to being the
man to take down Wesley streak and and
that would have been quite an
accomplishment because Wesley's played
um you know all the world class players
in that that street in that stretch in
veran acopon but he didn't quite Do It
um almost there and you see him now kind
of acknowledging so close yet so far
that means that all the games in the US
Championship are over today as and we've
got a couple still going in the Women's
Championship Anna sharich finally won
that game against um enal Newan um and
Irena crashed in huge trouble against
Nazi B kidy I mean wow she's the higher
rated player she's the seven time
Champion but she looks like she's headed
to 03 against this woman that what is
what is up with her in the matchup
against Nazi is it just bad luck or is
it a kind of a Carlson Nakamura
situation Brewing where she just has a
lot of trouble with this particular
opponent it seems to be the latter right
I mean uh sometimes just stylistically
for whatever ever reasons you just don't
match up well against a particular
opponent and nii if she were to score a
victory here three and0 against Arena
that would be well a remarkable record
and how big is this Advantage he's up a
pawn and she's also um got that past a
paon um so let's see can the can the a
paon start running let's take a look um
the move King D1 was just played
and so for the moment the pawn on A7 is
untouchable because of course the Knight
is hanging on C3 so now Arena wants to
try to play um something like King C2 to
allow um her to capture on A7 so sorry
the last move in fact had been King D1
and so uh you're right arena is as is
playing for this opportunity to play
King C2 but it's Naji to play and there
is a weakness over here on the king side
that oo I really don't think you could
uh let slip uh lose that pawn on G3
Knight H5 looks like now King C2 King C2
and I'll just have to find a good Square
for my Rook let me choose one I like my
p o well I've been allowing Knight to D6
Don it um you mean Knight B5 Knight D6
well just a second how how does how
would something like this go I mean that
Knight takes G3 will give black a very
powerful past gon so maybe it's better
for me to keep Knights on the board try
to play Knight A7 so that I can get
counterplay via Knight C6 E5 against
your idea okay let's see Knight takes G3
Knight C6 again you what you were just
mentioning Jen bring your knight to E5
Fork these pawns on F7 and
G4 okay so the game's not over yet Na's
got a lot of work to do she's up yes
still work cut out for but it should be
uh
black uh a victory for for for black uh
after all and boy I don't know exactly
where Arena blew up because we were
watching Wesley and hakaru and other
games but uh
yeah and with all the games in the
championship complete let's take a peek
at the standings well Wesley so still in
the lead with four points but now he's
got um Fabiano Carana as well as
Nakamura at his heel so the number two
and number three players in this
tournament are in that pack of wolves as
well as nitzki
jobian one guy to fall out of the pack
of leaders is Ray Robson who lost today
to Shanklin so they're both on even
Steven as is and Alexander
Onish and meanwhile we've got one other
game in the Women's Championship still
going on um but right now we have a
special guest uh veran niobian who had
everybody in the edge of their seats was
Wesley streak G to finally end so close
but not
today seems like he was in control after
some brilliant preparation but so close
and yet so
VAR I know I know it's one of those ugly
ones still veran acopian uh it looked
like you had him I mean he just looked
like you had all kinds of possibilities
to knock him out but this guy just seems
so slippery these days he's getting out
of any that people said for him yeah he
played really well I mean even at the
end I thought after I'm winning but
didn't found this queen check and queen
E7 which is the only way to save yeah I
yeah Queen D3 was a mistake I think up
to that point I played well I should
have probably just played Knight G1 my
original idea and I think I'm just
winning after Knight G1 oh yeah you were
definitely winning with with Queen C2
Knight G1 all those ideas I didn't see
Queen C2 too much I was just uh
originally I thought if he does this I
just go Knight G1 and uh it looks like
I'm winning because once I exchange the
bishop it's just going to be lost uh but
I went Queen D3 I thought it's just
immediate win but I missed the king
escapes and uh and it looks like a draw
but yeah it was kind of unfortunate
because you know I was pretty close I
think you were very close I mean lots of
we're close is not even the word uh is
this a disappointing draw for you uh
given that last year uh he was he beat
you pretty handily with the white pieces
this time you really gave him a run for
his money yeah no I mean last year I
didn't play well so I play much better
today and uh yeah I'm happy to you know
with black to play well against number
two player in the world and uh you know
I really thought I was going to win you
know because uh it looked like you know
everything was just going to work out at
the end but uh yeah yeah he's still very
good at defense you know which like you
know maybe some other people would just
collapse already but he found the only
idea and in time pressure I I you know
blundered no I'm happy with the game I
mean you know if I had the one I would
be fantastic but I'm still happy with
the draw as you said you drew the number
two player in the world after hunting
him and making him sweat so hopefully
this is a sign of things to come good
luck in the rest of your games thank you
uh VAR a question for you if if I may uh
when Wesley played the move Rook G3 I
found that personally shocking because
of that G5 opportunity to move that pawn
sacrifice that you found if you could
just tell us about your emotional state
when you realize that suddenly the
initiative was in your hands and hey I'm
gonna win this game what went through
your mind well I wasn't so sure about
winning here it's still complicated but
uh um no I like this queen C8 move it's
very important move because now I want
to play Queen F5 and uh it's going to be
all kinds of problems so Queen B3 was
the only move again and I don't know
whether or not this Knight f8 to H7 is
the best but uh it seems like I have
some uh initiative here there was Bishop
D6 in this position um that did you look
at this yeah I did
knight5 I wasn't so sure what's going on
after knight5 just you your instinct
told you Queen F5 that was the move with
this big massive threat of Queen yeah I
know but ah I forgot that he cannot
Castle
here yeah I saw this line I just forgot
he can Castle
now oh boy there was one beautiful line
that went F3 and this surprising move
Knight D7 he wouldn't have looked at
this cuz he thought castles was vable
yeah I just thought castle
Yeah I think the way I played was uh
probably still pretty good no according
to the
engines wi is fine after this spoiled
what the engines were thinking was just
a huge Advantage for you hug I missed
Queen F5 and the idea that I you just
cannot Castle I just completely forgot
that the bishop is guarding the D1 yeah
right and the Knight was on F3 so it
stopped that as this I thought just
probably about equal here I wasn't so
sure but I think uh
uh the engines did give equal I was
about equal here by the way before this
now yeah now it's just I think winning
yeah take take yeah just yeah just again
I have to stay with the intuition here
just then KN G1 here it was my original
idea when he was thinking I saw this
idea and I just say Knight G1 it looks
like I'm probably just winning
I mean I know that Queen C2 is probably
winning winning as well but I I didn't
calculate Queen C2 I just Knight G1
because I just want to get through of
the light score bishop and I should be
able to win here
uh well thank you for giving us a real
Topsy Turvy game you kept this on the
edge of the seats
throughout and well played game
thanks yeah it's almost um very
unfortunate that uh for forar of course
and and his fans that this thing existed
because it looks so promising the line
that he selected too so right it's so
understandable and it's too bad that
just by the luck of the draw he didn't
um come across the other promising line
indeed he would have played that exactly
but um of course uh unlucky for VAR
means lucky for Wesley who continues her
his his streak and he's approaching uh
an undefeated game for every square of
the chess board almost there almost
there what two more games right he's 62
and Counting uh that's that's an
enormous Milestone uh especially in
today's game where it's so competitive
and literally at any single day somebody
could beat you and here he is um Wesley
so still leading the US Championship
with mauce Ashley well just an
incredible save today for Wesley so
we've seen him in trouble before he's
gotten out the guy's as slippery as an
eel somehow escaping all the time Wesley
today
you must have seen the trouble when G5
landed on that board you must have felt
like there's some real danger in this
position yeah G5 but I was happy also to
get my my phone
back so I wasn't really sure actually if
you go back the position instead of
castling long I was thinking maybe King
D2 but in my game that hard to say well
well this this wasn't the point the M
the main point was Bishop D6 he had not
Knight H7 this is where ah Bishop D6 you
had some real danger in this position so
Bishop D6 Knight E5 take take take
Taking Queen F5 and if Queen B7 just
Queen
D3
yep
ouch that
it that would have been big danger for
you yeah
obviously you did not see see this line
that this was possible no there's Queen
F5 Queen
D3 right that's a slippery idea there's
lots of tactics he'll let you off the
hook with this move Knight to H7 yeah
now take take and here I was thinking
King
D2 it would be interesting to see how
that
defense but even your move castles was
probably not good according to engine
still okay if you just if you play
Bishop D3 immediately opposed to where
take uh this position Bishop D3
according to the engines oh Rook D1 KN
D1 Knight D1 uh they were giving us fine
for you and he would have to go for Rook
C7 Queen
B8 King
E7 then just Queen
h8 I mean probably a draw yeah yeah
interesting interesting this line
because it's a very complex line the
line with with a knight with Bishop D6
Knight E5 it's easy to miss all the
crazy tricks in that position because
it's just so it's so computer esque so
your sensation was that it wasn't that
easy for what for for black that you
were
okay yeah I mean he didn't he didn't
spot Bishop D6 also it's uh it's a very
complex idea but of course it's very
good for black right but he was also
already in some time pressure he had
like 35 minutes when this position
appeared on the board so it wasn't heavy
time pressure but certainly a challenge
to find all these moves yeah definitely
I think though that uh he'll get half
he'll get more time when he reach move
40 so it's it's not particularly big
danger I think if you have more than 15
minutes you should be fine just have to
pace well but
um so yeah probably my my move I made a
mistake somewhere early on yeah Rook G3
looked like the move that caused some
trouble for you a G5 was allowed G5 yeah
but I mean you're you're still unbeaten
it's like is it is just I know chess is
that hard I also know it's hard to beat
someone of your caliber but somehow no
matter what the position you're still
coming out roses what's yeah what's
happening well the point is I'm looking
for another win but it never comes so
then I get all this uh really
complicated positions that turn out to
be worse for me and uh just have to keep
trying it's really difficult to to win I
mean Fabiano won a good game today but
uh but it's really hard to win even a
single game this in this event well plus
61 last year you guys would have to win
five in a row to go plus six this year
that seems highly unlikely now you've
got you've been getting Chase half a
point half a point some mons behind you
now I think it's like a pack of five who
are behind you are you feeling any of
the nerves from knowing that somebody
wants to break through and and tie you
and clearly they're fighting you tooth
and nail as well yeah definitely I mean
BL is not nearly enough I mean I me I'm
surprised that I'm even leading with
plus two I mean uh I mean last year I
think out of seven games I was on plus 4
and Fabiana also was on plus four and so
obviously plus two is never enough to
win a tournament but uh a win or two
should should uh pretty much be turn out
to be really good you know it's pretty
much seal the deal if I can win a couple
more games but just never comes well a
lot of work ahead I'll let you uh Ponder
what to do in the next five rounds we
look forward to seeing your games
tomorrow thank you uh Wesley a question
if I may it comes from the opening and I
know you're anxious to get back and look
at your preparation but a shocking move
for me that I really didn't have on my
radar was pointed out by the chess
engines and Marice it was after you move
Rook G1 and I think every grandmas would
play the move Knight F6 uh rather
routinely uh in fact there's this crazy
move Bishop H5 which would have
I caused you a lot of trouble had you
considered the move Bishop H5 I
certainly had not I was wondering if you
were worried about it the idea is as
simple as it looks to grab a second pawn
and play
G5 it's crazy but you might be in some
trouble after this did you did it occur
to you this move Bishop H5 yeah
definitely I mean I was considering
Knight F6 Bishop H5 and queen D7 but I
thought Knight F6 was the strongest
because here after Bishop H5 I play uh
Queen
C2 Queen
C2 oops sorry I got to put it on on
C2 take
on takes sorry to continue the line what
did you imagine take on H4
yes Knight takes
H4 wi H4 and the problem is I can't
Castle so probably uh just a
just a good position for it's two pawns
for black yeah two pawns and Knight B5
doesn't think to
work5 and if Bishop E5
here knight6 Knight F6 yeah it's a it's
a confounding move isn't it that Bishop
H5 move I just thought it was so unusual
I wonder if it came across your radar as
well yeah and like one to prepare
castling King side soon then he'll be
just better exactly since he can play
Knight D7 and Castle
so so Bishop H5 probably good uh2 Bishop
H4 yeah it's
just in in modern Theory these days
there's so many unusual uh moves and
this one just like I said I caused me to
smile I thought I wonder if it if you
had considered it as
well all right Wesley we'll let you go
you'll consider all this you don't have
to worry about this position anymore
anymore we got another one to deal with
for tomorrow so we'll let you go now
thank you very much for joining us keep
the streak alive Wesley meanwhile we
have two women Championship Games still
going on and they are very different
games indeed one seems like it's going
to be ending soon Maggie Fang um she's
down a piece against Jenifer you but
those two pawns on F6 and G5 um soon to
be G6 and F6 are worth more than a piece
and I think uh Jennifer yua is going to
go down in this game and that will make
uh Maggie Fang uh reach a three and a
half points and she's really had some
impressive wins in this tournament the
junior high school champion and I think
about that wonderful uh game that she
had played against katcha yeah yeah I
was thinking it was wonderful game she
had played against k so she could
actually even be doing a lot better than
oops I just pull up her game it's very
picturesque uh yeah there you go well
actually I clicked it there was a big
delay in the oh it wasn't your fault no
like a lag no there's a very very
serious this is this is really
picturesque I mean look at those pawns
um G5 and G6 Tob soon the bishop on def5
stopping any the black work from even
sacrificing itself and the the on A5
completely nonparticipating this is uh
going to be a very fine victory for
Maggie Fang while meanwhile Nazi pitzi
struggles to convert her extra Pawn but
we actually have um another winner in
the Women's Championship with us Anna
sheric is with
Maurice yes we are with anes sharich
after a good victory today your position
didn't seem like it was necessarily
going to be much better but then you got
this beautiful move B5 in how did you
feel when you saw that move on the board
that it was completely working well you
know I calculated that B5 so I thought I
felt good when I saw it you know it's
like sometimes experience helps because
when you play against young girls maybe
there is something they didn't play in
their games and something that comes up
uh like let's in my mind much faster so
I saw that B5 idea and I thought well
luckily it works did it just jump at you
you just saw it as soon as she moved or
saw it coming when you played Knight to
E5 because she could have played Bishop
to E8 to slow it down she she could have
played Bishop B8 which was much better
than Bishop H7 obviously right so when
Bishop A7 landed on the board did you
just just B5 just start screaming at you
well it was screaming before 95 already
so I was even calculating be B5 before I
played 95 and I thought well I'd rather
Pro probably be safe and play 95 first
but then I thought I was actually
surprised she played Bishop H7 because
bishop8 was really
asking right do we played in that
position so a victory is always good
you've had fighting tournaments so far
how would you evaluate your play past
six rounds now in the
tournament well you know obvious there
were many
mistakes but um just the main thing
tried to keep less and less mistakes
which I don't know how going to happen
because uh the closer were to the end of
the tournament usually the amount of the
mistakes I think increases but just play
normal chess and prepare to every game
and enjoy the game that's probably the
main thing did you actually go to work
yesterday like you promised you would oh
yeah I did plus I went to volunteer
afterward just cool so you see it works
so it work okay well a new formula for
chess go to work volunteer I actually I
think going to work is easier than playe
chess yes nobody's fighting you tooth
and nail just trying to stop everything
you do well congratulations on your
Victory today and good luck in the rest
of your games thank you second in a row
on a herit two wins in a row SOG for
Anna and we also have I am Eric Rosen
pointing out in the hash US chass champ
that three players today got their first
victories of the tournament Karina Nam
Sova Fabiano carolana and Sam shankland
right so a very a very big day for many
of the players here well that's a big
tournament round compared to where they
were going the rest day but let's see
how the uh tournament's been affected by
today's scores in the women well in the
Women's Championship right now we've got
Sabina fer in the lead but don't forget
the one game still underway in the
women's Arena crushing naig pitti will
change that if it's a draw then Irena
and Nazi will both join Sabina and if um
Nazi wins then it'll be Nazi in the
clear lead with Sabina just behind and
if Irena wins then Nazi is uh going to
have to do something very weird
cuz she is off a pawn in this position
but we've got Alexander shabala to talk
about uh a very exciting game today with
Maurice he said it's very hard even to
get a half a point in this tournament
and he had to pull out some of those
shaba pyro Technics to pull this one off
but it looked like you had a really good
position coming out of the opening I was
very surprised Alex that you didn't play
more aggressively in this game
especially given that you your position
just looked so promising uh yes I know I
I just chose to play this fireproof
opening just to you know make sure I'm
not losing in the opening to Hikaru and
uh the way he played it just turned out
to be like super passive I mean he's
normally not doing those things and but
when he found himself in this pretty
tough situation he just like you know
there was a again the genuine you know
he Caro just uh found like a perfect
chance he just like uh I don't know
uh I understand that I probably
shouldn't be playing like C5 too early I
I I don't even know even now like where
I went wrong it looked like really
really promising but uh well it looked
like you had C5 even earlier there was a
moment when you could have played when
your Rooks were doubled and we have this
position here on the screen uh right
here instead of Bishop F2 instead of
giving him the chance to play F5 and
Bishop H6 couldn't you play C5 now takes
on B5 right yes this position yeah I was
thinking about it and uh I was like it's
a little bit too early I just want to
get a little bit closer to you know time
trouble so I would you know play less
moves and uh under you know whatever I
had at this point like 20 minutes or so
I don't understand you're saying you get
to make a couple of free moves for
yourself to get out of time pressure
yeah I thought like this idea is not
going anywhere like position is so good
it's always going to be there so that's
why I played Bishop F2 and I you know
played a couple moves just to before I
played C5 I thought this idea was going
to be there but of course when uh we
came down to calculations well yeah once
he played F5 suddenly all the pieces
were were alive as compared to I miss
this Rook C6 this kind of move like uh
just didn't occur to me yeah I don't
know why I mean looks so
natural so I know it's here yeah B takes
C Knight A4 uh that's what I missed of
course so but uh now that I'm looking at
of this B take C5 as a mistake probably
Knight A5 right away was better
on here I'm I'm kind of uh you know
confused the shaba I know wouldn't be
gaining time on the clock yeah I know I
know uh
I would like now nine game nine games
out of 10 I would play C5 and B5 instead
of Bishop F2 yeah that's that's the the
kind of stuff I'm used to seeing from
you looks like you're playing a little
bit more just when passive if you like
minus four in the tournament like this
you're just thinking twice before doing
this you know and
uh yeah I mean I that that was my chance
yes and uh I think after towards like uh
where did hiar made a mistake he taken
on C6 with a PA I think I I'm not sure
we stopped watching at some point uh
when the game turned and something weing
yeah here instead of B takes C6 was
Queen takes C6
better what I thought just like a exra
pawn to Bishops E5 who's weak but and
the Knight on D5 is good but probably
not enough compensation for me after he
played B takes C6 I'm not sure exactly
what he missed but my knight is clearly
not dominating light Square Bishop so
I'm probably not the not the worst
at right but it still seems like you got
less clearly in this position you got
less than the position promised yes
absolutely which you would have had okay
that's so so what do you do now what do
you do you know obviously you can draw
these
players
okay you're going to keep doing that all
day
expecting that uh no okay five more
games left and uh I hope it's a little
boost of confidence today that I've got
and uh hopefully I'll do a little bit
better in remaining games so all right I
have the same sentiment and
congratulations on positive result today
Ling the rest of your games thank you
shabalov Jennifer very very eventful
rounds but we're going to be taking a
break and as we come back with two games
is remaining in the US Women's
Championship and the key wanted that yes
stay with us to see if Nazi can break
through and uh be the clear leader in
the Women's Championship all
[Music]
righty
la
[Music]
a
he
[Music]
la
he
[Music]
la
n
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
[Applause]
and we're back at the 2017 US
championships and we've got just two
games left both in the women's section
it looks like Nazi pidi is crashing
through against ireena Crush um this
will going be Nazi's third straight
Victory against ireena in the US Women's
Championship and poor arena is going to
have to have a dart board or something
with Irene is with a Nazi space on it
because um this is just a astounding
three in a row how's this work end game
prognosis here it seems to me um that
just uh after this move by after this
move King F7 that there's no hope left
for arena agreed agreed it was a little
bit tricky uh when we saw this move Rook
F3 Rook A5 the move F5 is a move you
just don't want to play without
preparation Rook F2
was more than adequate I really like
that move a lot F5 check gave Arena the
chance to bring back her King and with
King D3 King E2 and make it a lot more
difficult for Nai to bring in the
victory instead another mistake here big
natur she's trying to get active yeah
but after this move King F7 just saying
okay what are you going to do about your
E3 Pawn what are you going to do about
your G G we knew going into the round
what a big game this was for the Women's
Championship and it does now look like
uh Arena crush is going to lose her
third game to the same opponent but I
that in this position she saw King D3
King Rook to F2 beg your pardon that in
the position of F5 Check Yes she saw
King D3 Rook F2 and it's not nearly as
bad as it is now for sure for the still
say your king is cut off and with your
king cut off it's going to be wor to
stop this piece you can't cut off wh's
uh Black's King because G3 is fast right
and this threat is so quick that it's
going to take some time to March this
King down the board if this Rook would
have come back and stop this Pawn but
which it can it can play here and
against
G2 Rook to G1 uh but I mean you what
moves are you going to play you're
running out of moves and this looks
busted and this is busted as a matter of
fact as well so that Rook F2 cut the
king off is the theme that we note in
these end games we saw it happen in
previous rounds as well and so she was
winning obviously she could have played
Rook F2 by itself but the way she played
it was absolutely fine in terms of
maintaining or win and now we see the
move desperate move E4 now on the board
but that must just lose to rookie E3 and
now um she's going to lose another Pawn
or Nazi is going to force a trade of
Rooks which would also be
um a victory and so uh completely busted
as I ran across now absolutely this move
rookie three seals the deal as Maurice
might say here this is over and done it
she quickly and confidently Twisted that
move down against Arena crush and Arena
um down to her increment she's only got
20 seconds left to play but it doesn't
matter the position is just dead lost
yep Rook A7 check and King G6 is about
to appear on the board that's right E6
means nothing yeah because now yeah
that's that's right but you know one
comment Y I think instinctively
especially with low time the the move
knight4 makes sense because she's
thinking um all rook and games are drawn
um I why don't I trade the knights that
should give me more chances to draw and
keeping the knights on the board but in
this particular case it's to the
contrary and I think there's some logic
behind that too because once the Knight
on F6 goes Nazi actually has an easier
time defending her beautiful Pawn on G4
so this is a case where there's conf
iting principles and Ina unfortunately
chose the wrong one which gave Nazi the
easy win yes this move 94 uh she didn't
realize that her King was getting cut
off as Maurice was saying you put the
Rook on F2 in the rook and pawn end game
that appeared and it's just over uh the
move 94 um just essentially made it
easier for naagi to uh with her extra
Pawn to claim a victory yeah 9 it's not
about principle in in the end game it's
really not about principle only in fact
it's mostly not about principle I know
Alexis shurov who uh has had some
beautiful end games people ask him why
are you good in the endgame and he said
because I calculate well and it's you
would say what no that's not what you're
supposed to be saying you're supposed to
say deep play you you know the Deep
principles no he says I can see exactly
what's going to happen next it's it just
gets simpler and simpler
and if he he would not play a move like
Knight to E4 because he would just
calculate and say I'm going to lose that
position I'm not playing that move Alexi
sherff certainly didn't find Bishop ag3
on principles no a sheer calculation
baby one of the most famous n game moves
there is yes one of considered one of
the most shocking moves in chess
actually this move Rook Bishop H3 that
he essayed against vesselin topela
famously in this position nii uh looking
down and realizing hey wait uh after the
move Rook A4 can I just push my pawn and
the answer is yes she can uh
G3 uh will cement her Victory most
assuredly after for example King takes a
E6 G2 uh threatening to Queen would
force Arena's Queen to come back and
then it's the Harvest you just collect
everybody and uh wins very very
comfortably now assured uh you said that
we have two games uh remaining that's
right Maggie Fang is still playing
against Jennifer youu that game looks
still looks delicious uh for Maggie but
is Jennifer you getting a little bit of
counterplay here well let's have a look
when we left it she had sacrificed a
piece that is to say Maggie had to get
these two uh incredibly powerful pass
pawns and we currently have this
position of the board the last move uh
played was Bishop F7 and Rook H4
so that makes sense Jennifer is trying
to get some checks in here I mean you
know
she Magie needs to be a little careful
because she can't go to the file then we
win the all important F6 Pawn she made a
critical error though she made a
critical error just now and by the way
the other game what I was going to say
was very easy we'll be looking at this
one because the other game I could tell
that was going to be resigned soon
because Rook E4 was actually the
simplest move and was played just trade
off the Rooks the pawn ending is
completely lost there's nothing to hope
for here after King F6 you got nothing
you're just going to lose being a pawn
down you're about to get zooked if you
play this move King here you can't make
any moves and the end game even if you
try something else is going to fail for
example in this position here King takes
King F6 let's say you allowed this
position well this is also losing as
well after King takes King here we can
see this position Pawn up we got the
extra Tempo get your king out the way
King down and that's just basic endgame
territory Nazi pidy defeating Arena
crush with black for the second time in
a row in these US championships now her
third Victory simply incredible you
would not expect that this is not a GM
versus another GM arena is the true GM
here and yet she's lost three times to
this rival amazing result for the
tournament and has shaken up the
Championships incredibly absolutely
shocking iena um known for being very
good with the white pieces losing twice
to a low rated opponent with white and
three in a row just insane and good for
Nazi in the Women's Championship as we
see from the standings Nazi bidy in the
clear lead four and a half points and
somebody we haven't been talking about a
lot but we're going to be starting to
talk about more Sabina foer Robert H the
grandm who coached the ladies team in
Baku um draw this name to our attention
earlier in the round and right he was um
right behind that them or Anna zansky
Irena crush and Anna sh also coming in
there and saying hey I might have
something to say about this tournament
as well abolutely we might add the
sentimental favorite by the way Sabina
fer her mom very young passing away
suddenly uh and that was quite a shock
for her it's hard enough for her to come
and play in this tournament and now she
is within a Stones Throw of first I'm
sure this is extremely meaningful and
moving for her family that's right and
um saina's mom was also a chess player
there um taught her the game um so uh
really huge there and uh her um uh
fiance alshan moradi abadi um he wrote a
tribute Grand he's a Grandmaster
residence and he wrote a tribute um on
sabina's Mom on the US chess website so
you can check that to learn more about
that uh amazing chess family but we have
a grandmas and seven time Champion Irena
Crush about a disappointing result today
she's with marce a tough game today for
the champion against one of her key
Rivals Arena it looked like just a
position at some point not much of an
edge for you coming out of the opening
but somehow it kind of slowly went wrong
did you identify where you think that
that problem move might have been well
hanging awn and move uh
30 uh seven wasn't very
good so just a mistake uh in the
position but but before that you you
seem to have had a little bit of an edge
uh was it just
over pressing or just overlooking this
move um well yeah I mean I got nothing
out of the opening it was a really
balanced um end game she tried some
stuff on the king side with G5 and H5 I
think uh didn't go very well for black
because I was definitely feeling that
white was taking over the initiative
around move 30 um my knight got to G5 it
was a really good square and black
playing D5 I mean here I mean I almost
thought it was like very very bad for
black maybe I uh overestimated White's
position um it's a kind of a tricky
moment this Knight F6 uh there's a move
there's a move like Knight B4 I was
looking at here after Knight E4 just to
show you like a nice line Knight E4
Knights
B4 uh there's no no Knight's B4 Knight D
to
B4 yeah there's a rook takes D7
and after Rook D7 Knight takes F7 I
think is a tactic that works for white
um with the idea yeah that there's this
fork and F6 so this an idea of the kind
um example of the kind of ideas that
white had in this position I think
Knight F6 was correct um you know was
had a big Choice Knight F6 so should I
keep the Rooks on the board or not I
mean I thought if I played Rook C2
there's going to be like Knights B4 I
can't take on C5 because of the
unfortunate play placement of my king on
F2 um so I decided to
trade and yeah I mean it's not so bad
for black because in Rook H7 there's
always Rook
f8 um and I also have to be a little bit
careful that my knight on G5 doesn't get
trapped because there's these F6 ideas
which is why I moved back to uh Knight
to
C3 so trade yeah maybe it's it's the
kind of balance thought King E2 was fine
Knight C3 yeah so she played this move
and offered a draw and I just uh lost my
vigilance for a second and played Knight
E4 to thought I'm blundered KN takes A2
of course you know white doesn't have to
give a pawn like that so um if we just
go back yeah I mean after this is just
terrible so um Knight F6 so maybe
instead of Knight E4 a move like A3 is
just fine of course A3 and then Rook
C1 yeah definitely a a tough loss
there's still lots of rounds to go five
rounds to go
but you face another big rival tomorrow
in Anna zatonski uh how do you evaluate
your situation right now you've been in
this situation many times before Oh Well
it's worse than uh it was a round
ago and so your thoughts about this
matchup yeah I mean we try to play
better tomorrow um another
day okay uh we'll let you go and clear
your mind and we'll see you tomorrow
thank you thank you Maurice thank you
Arena and uh Grandmaster H tweeting in
again saying that after surviving four
blacks in six rounds and a bad blunder
versus satony NAA kidy jumps ahead of
the field and that um she's got a
favorable remaining schedule right
she'll have an extra white in her games
uh to come um another Nazi fan CT Curtis
LEL says that Nazi bidi isn't playing
chess she's running a marathon every day
um referring to uh how she's really
playing some long games indeed we can
never forget that uh 129 move game even
though she lost it uh quite an
extraordinary fighting performance by
both players so and always seems to be
in the end
games yeah long games here in the
Women's Championship long and bloody and
we've got another decisive game decisive
day in the women's all decisive games oh
my good well not yet but um it seems
unlikely that uh the Maggie Fang
Jennifer uame went in a draw but we do
have the leader of the Women's
Championship nzi kidy and the reigning
champ with us she'll talk to Maurice
about today's game US Women's Champion
Nazi pidi after a horrible result
earlier result earlier against Anna
zatonski has simply come roaring back in
fine style and today was certainly a
satisfying Victory Nazi what is it about
this opponent you're not supposed to
beat her three games uh in a row and yet
somehow you seem to be very successful
against her yeah well I I don't think
these games are connected we just played
a game she was better um I kind of
tricked myself into playing this opening
that I don't like and I had to defend
the whole game why did you play then um
I don't know no um I had it prepared
until some move and then I made a move
too quickly and realized that I would
have to go to this
position um so yeah I was pretty
disappointed and then actually at one
point I offered her a draw right before
she blundered a pawn but I think she's
better there if she plays E4 when I
played Knight F6 uh but yeah after I won
that pawn um she does have chances
to uh make a draw but of course I'm
better and I don't risk to lose anymore
so after that uh I was pretty confident
what's the story you played this game
this long game against Anna that was
extremely difficult you had draw after
draw well it was first losing and then
then you had a chance to draw and
somehow you've shown Championship medal
and not let it disturb you because
you've come back with victories this one
nothing bigger than this one it's funny
how uh you keep reminding me of that
game because I have completely forgotten
about it that's that's a Champions
mindset um yeah and anyways I was lost
in that game like 15 times so I don't
really feel that bad about it you have
five rounds to go you're finally by
yourself in the tournament what are your
thoughts on how to proceeded in the next
five rounds actually haven't thought
about the standings yet um I'm just
going to try to do my best every game I
still have some T tough opponents left
not some all of
them you have a tough one in and a
sharich what can you tell us about that
matchup in the next round um I think
I've only played her once two years ago
at the US championship and uh we have
one draw she's a very solid player so
I'm with white so I'll try my best all
right we look forward to seeing you uh
play that game and congratulations again
thank you thank you Maurice and thank
you nii well in pole position as our
reigning Champion with one game to go
here in round six what's happening in
that game has uh Jennifer managed to
find some counter chances it looks like
a little bit of counter chances but man
it's been wild so let's take a look and
of course um it being the fifth hour of
play the players have very little time
um both of them playing essentially in
the increment here with a what what was
a really wild position uh Ted down a
little bit um in the last couple of
moves but you if you go back just a
couple of moves I was about to say we
were seeing it was everything was in
take right B6 and then instead of moving
The Rook just playing King G3 stopping
Rook G4 funny business and then after
Bishop C1 Queen C1 Knight D3 ignoring
the attack on the queen because
unfortunately no unfortunately for Fang
if most places she brings to the queen
allow um some counterplay for black for
instance we have to hold on to the E1
Square um otherwise we could lose the
game right so she actually needs the
queen C1 paradoxically to stop all those
types of nasty checks and invasions so
she jettison that and plays G7 jettison
her queen in fact yes and promoted her
queen of course she gets a new one and
then she's able to take the rook and now
what's the situation is there are there
a lot of checks can the Knight and the
Queen coordinate to harass uh Maggie at
all or can she simply March her King up
with King G5 and uh consolidate Victory
with the beautiful Pawn on F6 well she
just play King G5 yes she's trying to
escape the Perpetual checks and choose
to bring her Bishop back to D5 so she
can get out of the way of the F7 pawn
and this seems to be a a rushed move
there uh the times for the players are a
minute a piece a minute and a half for
and it looks like Jennifer has just
taken the pawn on e4 Queen takes E4 I
see is black I'm I'm so sad because it
seems like black should be able to get a
counterplay but the problem is that for
Lauren Knight um on on C1 isn't
participating and a huge problem and
this move now is also bringing a queen
A8 check followed by Queen B7 back into
the game and queen F4 queen4 check was
played but quickly came King
B6 yeah we can hide away with on G6
right this is not going to be a problem
hiding right
after to the Eng completely winning for
white because the king will hide in
front of this pawn and that pawn is
thinking about becoming a queen while
black is without pieces black doesn't
have that Knight working and the the
black king is going to come under
terrific attack in just a couple of
moves so after King F7 um Queen D7 check
well I'm thinking Queen G4 check has
been played she did play quickly King F7
Oh I thought she was going to dance with
King H6 first uh and not allow the check
on D7 but she did play King
F7 if Queen D7 we can play King f8 and
then when you check us we can go back to
G7 and then you and and that's a problem
right I mean after Queen d8 check yeah
now we can go King G7 and now your
checks are are no bueno because we have
a just play Queen F7 totally winning
right
exactly um cuz our Pawn so far Advanced
yeah that's the problem everything is
winning right now so there's just no
real counterplay for black that F Pawn
is way far down the board and with the m
threat and that Bishop much much better
than that Knight in terms of fighting
past pawns yes so your Pawn your Bish
your Pawn's not getting to D1 that's
just not going to happen Bishop F3 is is
waiting to happen while your knight is
so far away from that F6 PA yeah let's
show one of those variations I mean
although has been played King so so
saying or I thought even when you trade
Queens yeah something like this white
has prepared to meet D2 with Bishop um
F3 and G8 is all you can't play you
can't play Knight C1 to F6 that's
exactly why the bishop is better than
the Knight here but I was and there's so
many variations similar to that aren't
there like after Queen d8 check King G7
um Queen D7 cheack Queen F7 if you play
Queen takes F7 you might think well I've
got some pawns that are ready to Queen
too but the problem is they're very easy
to stop unlike um my beauty on F6
precisely and again the Knight on C1
just can't even come close to
approaching that pawn on F6 and it's a
goner it's a real 27 out of 36 games
decisive wow on the ladies side and 12
in a row 27 and 12 in a row that that is
absolutely astonishing 75 % win rate and
here Jennifer is she realizes she's
going down she's shaking her
head and not much time on the clock to
worry about it 24 seconds left these two
players are going to be facing each
other in plenty of future women's
championships um they could be Olympic
teammates one day I I have no doubts I
mean it's the rise of the Millennials uh
for especially in the women's
competition some of the young talents
that we have showcased here in St Louis
they're she realized the end games were
dead lost so she played a different move
entirely she just played Queen to F5 so
after Queen D7 sha Queen F5 is on the
board yeah she realized those end games
were were were completely kaput so she's
trying something
different and I'm supposing Queen E6
along with lots of other moves including
Queen F7 check that might actually be
the more oh yeah she's playing Queen F7
check there's no question there you you
get a chance to start checking you're
going to check
yeah I agree Queen F7 check uh most
decisive looking move here for
white and she has she done it Maggie
Fang and a very B6 very very quickly was
played by Jennifer there's Maiden six on
the board but I'm not sure it's going to
happen can we play so can we play B B4
here just threatening Checkmate well
Queen B7 is mate in six oh starting with
the forcing move huh yeah start with
Queen B6 B7
but the the thing is Queen E6 is also so
attractive I wonder if she'll play that
as the human move Queen E6 trade off
these queens and you'll never see
counterplay and it's just going to be an
easy pawn push but Queen B7 is actually
mate the point being that King C5 is not
playable I'll show this line here King
C5 is not playable because of B4 King to
D6 and your king is just surrounded very
simply in this net Queen B seven pretty
if I go back here and now King A5 and
now she has to find the direct mate by
sacrificing that's why I'm wondering if
she'll find it with little time left on
her clock is she going to play played it
and she has played it this check now
King takes is absolutely forced now this
check and you see it coming King A5 this
check and after King to A4 look at this
pretty mate B3 Knight takes and Bishop
C6 is mate unusual that B3 move cutting
off the running Square so let's see if
she finds that that'll be an impressive
way to finish the game off and she has
Queen B7 check on the board King A5 is
the only way to even make the game last
more than three moves so beautiful
problem like finish there so yeah we'll
we'll see all the lines and Jennifer
sees that her King is just in terrible
trouble right now not sure where to move
she might even resign in this position
but King A5 is the the one that lasts
the longest uh in this position King C5
is just academic that's right and the
time is ticking down down for Jennifer
the third option is to lose on time but
know she's played King to A5 exactly and
again that's a very pretty mate there on
the board Queen C7 check King takes A4
Queen C4 check King A5 Queen C5 check as
Maurice just pointed out very pretty uh
stunning and uh sure there's some other
lines there that work out okay too oh
yeah again it's just not me it's just
everything else is winning but
everything in fact else is winning but
this is mate if she finds Queen C7 and
sees the entire line she is looking now
with one 12 on her clock she got to be a
little bit nervous she might even play
F7 here if she doesn't see the mate uh
but that would be surprising for her to
do but I can see that that happening if
the seconds are just ticking a bit too
fast she has that in her pocket but no
she has started with the
move and now no real Improvement on
theine line Queen C4 check and queen C5
by Maggie's a girl after your own heart
she's a she's a big bug House Fan if
you're looking for a new Bug House
partner all right all right Maggie let's
team up together um I've been very
impressed with her performance in this
game and this tournament pardon me and
in particular her game against katcha
which she didn't win she played a
beautiful positional Masterpiece she
could have many more points in this in
this tournament even though it's such a
strong field that's right very
impressive uh performance by the uh
16-year-old Maggie Fang first girl to
ever win the National Junior High School
championship and was she with the wild
card at the St Louis just not this year
I think she qualified by reading the
wild car this year was Chris Yip oh
really okay so the ratings of these um
young women uh changed like from list to
list they're all kind of uh clumped
together though and one of them I think
we're going to see is going to uh make a
big jump in the next year or so and
maybe it's going to be mate 28 seconds
in ticking she hasn't found the mate 25
make that she hasn't found the problem
like mate with Queen C4 and look at that
she missed it she's played F7 she had
mate in four on the board and instead
she pushed the pawn to F7 that's
certainly winning without question but
she now has mate in
20 I mean she certainly pushed this back
a bit longer than she needed to because
black can bring the Knight back into the
struggle with Knight to D3 and limit
that mating possibility although the win
is clearly still there but suddenly some
swindling chances could appear you got
to be careful she had the mate but she
missed the B3 move I think is the one
she missed that's an easy one to miss
pretty yeah that's really attractive I
think for me the for me the big issue
there is that it would be such such a a
great way like not only is she
performing so well in the Women's
Championship but to show people like
this is how I won this game that's nice
and there we have D3 keeping the mate is
alive is alive once again once again
Queen C4 check King A5 Queen C5 check
King A4 B3 that's the star move B3
robbing Black's King of the Escape
Square she might be forced to find it in
a moment uh as this Pawn is Galloping
down the board and now she's playing the
first of the moves right right Queen C4
check and because of time trouble it's a
it's a very easy move to find these
Queen C4 Queen C5 just gaining a little
uh time on the clock and by the way King
A5 is absolute block so that was played
very
quickly and queen C5 is attractive
because it puts it on a dark Square yes
so you harmonize with your Bishop in the
best way right so she did play that move
so positionally she knows that's correct
and now King A4 now will she see it
very attractive idea B3 and Bishop C6 is
mate now that she's here she's giv
herself she does not see it she has
taken the night she did not see
it that doesn't change the game of the
result anyway but you could have made it
in two you know it's an unusual pattern
and you might say why didn't she see it
because she's never seen it and because
she's totally winning so she's like
maybe just looking for ways to liquidate
and just like get her oppon to rather
than look for like forc M well I can
tell you exactly why uh she's seeing the
same pattern now and now she seeing the
move B3 in that pattern with Queen C4
check and queen C5 check she's saying
well let me eliminate the the the the
Knight to stop the knight from being
able to capture the pawn not recognizing
that the Knight would Rob Black's King
of the Escape Square B3 and Bishop C6 is
the wrong pattern that's not how you do
it you do it along the diagonal the
other way your queen on C5 the bishop on
that D1 A4 diagonal that's the typical
pattern time this one oh no I the king's
blocking the clock I thought that was I
thought that was z00 Z okay it might as
well be because she has no checks her
King is about to get M it anyway and she
has no way of advancing her Pawn there's
just no counterplay oh there's lots of
mating patterns now she can she can
choose between mating patterns now that
the night is gone so of course we can
understand um why chop the night yeah
exactly exactly yeah that's as practical
as the because this probably for
remember Le aronian missed a beautiful
Victory um and just won a queen and um
he quoted somebody who said if you have
a choice between queen or mate pick the
queen they're talking they're chatting
to each other the game is over a
resignation uh after this move Queen
takes C W yeah so um Jennifer just
showed her the mate Jennifer just showed
her the mate to say oh you had mates but
she resign instead Maggie gets the
victory um and uh as as the auor pointed
out uh really an outstanding result from
this uh National Junior High School
champion and she this is her first time
in win this Championship which I think
is remarkable because what you often see
is even if they have similar ratings the
first time of the Women's Championship
is often tough for some of the players
you're Terri cameras the
action the tens of thousands of people
scrutinizing every
yes and let's take quizzing you after
while you didn't play this or that let's
take a look at the decisive games there
you have it Jenn right 27 out of 36 uh
games have been decisive in the Women's
Championship uh so 13 36 in the in the
open section that's right and all
decisive this round and last round of
the Women's Championship let's take a
look at the standings in the
championship we've got Wesley so his
streak almost ended today but he kept it
going with a draw against veran niobian
that easily could have resulted in Sp
blood for him um right behind him baruan
niobian yaroslav jeru hikaro Nakamura
Daniel nitki and Fabiano Carana well
that's a pack one of these guys is going
to start winning and put the pedal to
Wesley sty well I'm telling you
fabiana's Victory today really gave him
much much needed wind in his saes as
he's looking at the second half and
saying what I'm only half a point behind
the the leader oh let me string together
some wins now meanwhile in the Women's
Championship we have also got a clear
leader Nazi pidi big victory today over
Irena Crush which could have easily
ended in a draw in fact Arena pointed
out in her interview that Nazi offered
her a draw and pointed it out yes and
Sabina fer um uh with a great Victory
today and um her tournament is just as
dramatic as can be six games six
decisive games she keeps playing like
that and stays in the Wind
um you know it might be uh her day here
at the Women's Championship and Anna
sheric with backto back victories
pulling her campaign into uh well
contention let's say let's take a look
at tomorrow's pairings um Fabiano Camana
playing Black against the SPO student
Yos J but that's huge because they're
both in that pack of Worlds exactly and
there's bar playing against Alex owners
and then Ray Robson versus Wesley so
quite a big game that is for our
tournament standings Ray would certainly
like the breast a to be tomorrow because
he just had a rest day but he lost today
so he's going to have to recuperate for
that and and play um one of the biggest
g games of his tourament against Wesley
Carl s Shanklin and out csky Daniel n Dy
all good matchups and what about the
women's in the Women's Championship well
we've got Nazi bidy against Anna sharich
as you pointed out Nazi on a three- game
winning streak and Anna on a two- game
winning streak so both of these players
red hot but who will um flame out
tomorrow look at that Anna Zony Arena
Crush that has usually primally decided
this event those two players both
needing a victory to keep Pace with our
defending Champion yeah it's just
amazing that that is not the game with
the most number of points in the Women's
Championship um who would have thought
that um but we have uh Maggie Fang who
played uh absolutely thrilling game
today we could have been um watching
that one the whole game yes indeed and
uh she's with
Maurice absolutely a wild game between
the two youngsters today but it ended in
Victory for Maggie Fang Maggie what did
you think about this game I mean her
King was on one side you you pushed your
Pawns in front of your king then her
King marched over to the other side of
the board you sack on F7 I mean this was
complete entertainment for the viewers
but for you it must have been just heart
racing yeah it was a really crazy
position like there's like so many
things going on did you think you had
the advantage throughout or was it just
Fighting
Chess I thought I may I thought it was
like a little bit better before but then
when his King like moved to the other
side I wasn't sure about my position
when her King got to the other side she
had this Pawn on B3 it looked like there
was some spatial Advantage but then you
sacrificed on F s uh suddenly these past
paw as we look at this board here that
move Knight F7 what made you go for it
did you feel like you had to play This
Way well I I like I didn't like my my
pieces were like didn't have any space
and then I take a a couple pawns and
then and my pieces get more space and
also have the two pass pawns which I had
absolutely those two pass pawns uh
became terrific in a moment and then you
got this maneuver in with Rook uh to H3
and Rook to H6 after this exchange now
when you're about to pick this Pawn up
what what do you think about your
chances right here I I think I had
really good chances because it's hard to
stop those two pawns from pushing makes
a lot of sense now let's proceed pretty
quickly as you were you managed to trade
off some Rooks and get into this end
game wasn't entirely clear that you were
winning this position you got wild you
got to sacrifice your Que in this
position how did that feel when you
realize a queen sack would allow you to
to have some great chances right around
right here after Knight takes you got to
play
G7 Oh I thought that was like the only
move makes a lot of sense now you're
completely winning in the position we
can fast forward because she's
completely lost here apparent you did
did you find out that you missed a
maiden four in the position and then a
maiden two at one point I I there was
probably a mate but oh yeah I didn't
have like a lot of time right so you
miss this you play the variation if we
could we could move forward sorry I
refresh the board I apologize to our
viewers here uh I had the I had a lot of
analysis and not the actual uh game
score but I'll be back come on you can
do it load up yes uh one Mo before this
before this one actually it's two moves
before this right
right here after King to A4 the move
B3 did you look at this at all B3 well I
guess if you had looked at it you would
have noticed I forgot you forgot about
that possibility all right well you are
tied for third after six rounds before
you came to this tournament would you
have felt that you'd be tied not only
tied for third but you're tied with
Arena crush and and Anna Zoni uh for the
position you're in very close to the
lead I want I didn't think I'll be doing
this well so how does it feel it feels
really good that's that's the answer we
expect and we look forward to seeing the
rest of your games thanks Maggie Fang
the youngster showing that she can play
in this tournament after six rounds
definitely in a Stones Throw of the
leaderboard congratulations Maggie wow
and yer had another question for you no
I didn't oh I was going to say will you
be his Bug House partner oh I do have
another question in that case uh Maggie
it seems that you and I both enjoy uh
love if you will the game of bug house
uh after the tournament I don't want you
to uh injure your tournament want to be
bug house partners uh okay okay that's
what I wanted to hear that's a yes all
right run away with that and uh great
day here at the US Chess Championship so
much more blood spilled and there could
have even even be more if that game
between aoon and so was decisive right W
that's so big for the streak uh two two
games away from Wesley Wesley so getting
a 64 game winning uh non- losing Street
he's on a 62 game streak will he keep it
alive Jen well that will determine the
fate of the US Championship it's not
just about his streak right right and
we've got a final thought from Maurice
Ashley on today's exciting action
absolutely incredible as the ladies are
showing that they are all about Fighting
Chess every single round 12 decisive
games in a row so many victories there
but of course as well equal number of
losses so everybody feeling it no more
so than the one Arena Crush seven time
champion this has got to be a bitter
taste in her mouth today and Wesley so
he could have lost as well so close to
losing fuan niobian would have been in
first place by himself if he had won the
game but he came ever so close still did
not silon was not able to seal the deal
but Wesley doesn't look so confident I
when that interview he just seemed like
he's not sure of how he's playing right
now and he's got five people hoping that
he has those doubts remaining we'll see
whether or not any one of them can catch
him tomorrow here in round seven of the
US championships thank you Maurice well
we can't wait to see as this uh
Championship progresses if today is any
indication it's going to get hotter and
hotter so join us tomorrow at 1:00 local
time here in St Louis and two on
Eastern good evening
everyone
[Music]